Hallo und herzlich willkommen bei Mobile Max, der Supershow rund um Apple mit...
Ist das jetzt schon der Anfang oder hatten wir das?
Ich versuch grad möglichst kommerziell rüberzukommen, Dennis. Bitte.
Ich nehm mal einen Schluck Marthe.
Wie soll uns denn jemals...
Heute, live aus Berlin.
Genau, wo wir dann alles so virtuell runterkommen, aus dem Internet heraus, runtergeladen.
Live aus dem Internet.
Live aus dem Internet. Mit Max, mit Dennis und mit Tim Prittler am Apparat.
Und wir bauen nur noch so einen Button zum Klatschen einspielen.
Genau.
Zum Pfeifen und Jolen und so.
Und einer von uns muss so ein Keyboard haben, auf der sie lauter Köhne drauflegen soll.
Ich finde, in diesem Bereich können wir einfach ein bisschen mehr dazu legen. Wie soll man uns sonst ungerechtfertigt vorwerfen, wir wären kommerziell? Das findet viel zu wenig statt. Aber ich hatte neulich wieder so eine Diskussion. Oder wir machen so ein Bild. Wie ich denn das mit meinem Gewissen vereinbaren könnte, für so eine Firma Werbung zu machen?
Ja, Apple.
Also im Bezug auf Mobile Max.
Machen wir Werbung für die?
Nein.
Nein, wir machen keine Werbung.
Aber wenn ich sage, mein Fahrrad...
Also wir machen unbezahlte Werbung.
Mein Fahrrad X Epsilon ist voll toll, das ist ja auch Werbung. Da dürfte man ja über gar nichts mehr reden.
Ja eben, das ist doch vollkommen bekloppt.
Und mein Motorrad fährt auch super.
Stell dir mal vor, Apple würde unsere Sendung als Werbung ausstrahlen. Alle Leute, die diese Datei, jeder Mensch, der diese Datei auch nur auf 20 Meter gesehen hat auf irgendeinem Computer, wird auch von Steve Jobs höchstpersönlich perforiert.
Dieses Tablet?
Nein, unseren Podcast.
Ach so meinste.
Ja, da wird gestieft. Naja, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall begrüßen wir hier aufs herzlichste unsere Hörer.
Und auch die Ausländischen in Rom.
Genau. Also wir haben es jetzt trotzdem wieder erwartet, geschafft hier mitten in der Sommerpause noch eine Sendung zusammen zu stückeln. Wenn die nächste kommt, lassen wir mal ganz offen, weil es ist irgendwie August und die Sonne scheint und die Mädchen sind hübsch und wir müssen uns auch mal um andere Sachen kümmern. Stimmt's?
Ja.
So, aber auf Twitter meint gerade einer, wir haben eine Meise. Endlich versteht es mal einer. Also, was ist passiert im Internet? Womit wollen wir anfangen? Wollen wir anfangen mit den anderen? Apple oder iPhone? iPhone, wirklich? Aber da reden wir sehr lange drüber, oder?
Da reden wir sehr, sehr lange drüber.
Und dann ist der Rest schon wieder so, wenn wir schon total debil sind.
Ja, dann lass uns mit dem anderen anfangen, weil zum iPhone kommen wir sowieso automatisch irgendwann.
Genau, mal sehen, nach wieviel Sekunden. Wollen wir uns erstmal bei Nils bedanken?
Ja, wir beitragen uns mal bei Nils. Wofür?
Wer ist Nils? Der hat uns dieses Skript so geschickt, mit dem man in einer Sidebar jetzt endlich auch ohne diesen hässlichen Google-Kalender sehen kann, wann die nächste Sendung stattfindet.
Ganz schick, ich schau es mir auch gerade nochmal extra an. Das ist so ein bisschen JavaScript, dass sich dann so da in dem Moment wirklich live auf den Google connectet, so mit API und so?
Ja, ja, und wenn man mit Opera kommt, dann sagt er, äh, äh, das geht nicht in Opera.
Braucht man dafür dann nicht irgendwie auch so ein Application-Key? Um darauf zu greifen über API?
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Oder hat er das von vornherein für unsere Domänen gemacht? Das weiß ich natürlich ja nicht.
Ich bin gar nicht im... Ich bin gar nicht im Yorck-Channel. Ich bin noch in dem anderen und hab jetzt auch den Hashtag an den falschen Dings gepostet. Das ist mir ja peinlich.
Du treibst die auf anderen Servern rum?
Ja, das ist ja Autolock-Inner bei Transmission-Dings.
Transmission?
Da hängen die ganzen Developer vor sich rum.
Ach so. Ich dachte jetzt, Transmission hat jetzt auch... Das unterstützt jetzt auch IRC neben Beton. Damit fangen wir gar nicht an. Ja, also, dann fangen wir doch mal mit anderen Sachen an. Was ist mir so aufgefallen? Habt ihr das mitbekommen mit... Trim?
Ja, ich fand ja Trim total toll. Ich hab ja Trim gerade erst vor wenigen Tagen für mich entdeckt.
Du hast es vor wenigen Tagen für mich entdeckt.
Ich bin mal ein Idioten. Was ist denn Trim?
Tja, Trim ist eine von diesen vielen sogenannten... Wie nennt man die eigentlich? URL-Shortenas. Was Tiny URL mal pioniert hat. Also, dass man einfach eine... Ich sauf jetzt hier. Du hast eine lange URL und du gibst sie da ein und dann wird dir diese URL in eine andere URL umgesetzt. Und wenn du die dann verwendest, die du dort bekommst, dann wirst du eben auf die Domänen von diesem URL-Shortener weitergeleitet. Und dort wird ein Temporary Redirect rausgefeuert. So ein Move Temporarily ist das, glaube ich, in der Regel.
Ohne 2 oder sowas, ne?
Genau, und der führt dann halt dazu, dass dein Browser oder was auch immer du gerade da irgendwie verwendest, um diese URL aufzulösen, dann eben auf die eigentliche Seite geht.
Und wozu sollte man sowas brauchen, Tim?
Na ja, ich glaube ursprünglich hat sich das halt entwickelt, damit man in E-Mails nicht so diese meterlangen URLs drin hat, die dann von irgendwelchen bekloppten Programmen umbrochen werden. Beziehungsweise kannst du ja auch relativ früh dann auch so Vanity-Wörtchen dazu geben, dass du eben auch, wenn der String halt noch nicht vergeben war, eben auch definieren kannst, was hinter dem Slash-Date-Domain steht. Also kannst du da was weiß ich, tiny URL, der Weg zu meinem Geburtstag eingeben und dann ist es halt das und dann kannst du dir das eben auch selber besser merken. Und lange Zeit hat eigentlich außer tiny URL das keiner gemacht, bis dann eben irgendwie Twitter kam und alle natürlich URLs posten wollten und dieses 140 Zeichen-Limit hat eben alle dazu gebracht zu shorten. Wobei ich immer nie so richtig verstanden habe, welche Mechanismen denn da eigentlich wirklich greifen. Ist es nicht so, dass Twitter mittlerweile auch selbst, wenn man URLs drin hat, die auch automatisch shorten?
Na die arbeiten mit Bit.ly glaube ich zusammen.
Mittlerweile, ne?
Genau.
Aber anfangs war es tiny URL.
Kann sein, dass die ja tiny... Wobei tiny URL ja schon erstaunlich lange URL eigentlich ist, muss man mal sagen. Klar, aber im Vergleich zu maps.google.com/ja, im Endeffekt kannst du das merken, aber ich meine so isgde und so kann man sich ja irgendwie auch echt nicht mehr merken. Istgut? Merke ich mir das einfach. Aber Trim war wieder einfach zu merken.
Trim fand ich cool, also Trim war wirklich mal echt scharfer Name auch. Bit.ly finde ich so ein bisschen.
Trim hat auch schöne Statistikfunktion.
Genau, das war ja auch der Grund, deswegen habe ich mir auch da selber gerade mal vor ein paar Tagen einen Account geklickt, sollte nicht viel Freude daran haben. Sozusagen zwei Wochen später.
Aber jetzt sagen sie auch wieder, dass es sich wieder klingt?
Ja, sie haben halt irgendwie dicht gemacht, weil sie ein bisschen resigniert haben. Erst mal sehen sie kein Business-Modell, dann sehen sie halt, dass Twitter eben Bit.ly bevorzugt und da waren sie frustriert und hatten einen schlechten Tag und haben zu viel Alkohol getrunken und haben dann einfach mal sagen und klagen, so ist ihren Laden dicht gemacht.
Aber was passiert, wenn die ihren Laden dicht machen? Geht das dann alles nicht?
Naja, das ist nämlich jetzt genau die Diskussion, die das auch ausgelöst hat. Ich meine, die Diskussion gab es auch schon vorher.
Gibt es da bestimmt schon viele andere, die so einen Service hatten und dicht gemacht haben, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe bisher jetzt noch keinen wirklich dicht machen sehen. Also soweit ich weiß, sind alle, die jetzt wirklich so halbwegs populär waren, auch nach wie vor im Betrieb und das ist jetzt eigentlich der erste, der Halbwegsverbreitung hatte, der dann eben auch wirklich dicht gemacht hat. Aber natürlich ist es eine generelle Frage und es war jetzt auch schon bevor Trim dicht gemacht hat, eigentlich eine generelle Frage. Ich hatte das Thema auch schon ein paar Mal hier auf der Liste, aber wir sind immer irgendwie nicht so richtig dazu gekommen, dass es ja eigentlich totaler Quatsch ist, dass man eben einen Link auf einer Webseite, auch wenn er lang ist, auf einen ganz anderen Host macht und ihm die Zuverlässigkeit dieser URL von einem Anbieter abhängig macht, der damit eigentlich gar nichts zu tun hat. Und du natürlich auch eine ganze Menge Sicherheitsfragen damit verbinden. Was sammelt der dort für URLs? Viele Leute verwenden unter Umständen da auch Links auf potenziell non-public Sachen vielleicht.
Man könnte die URL einfach umbiegen.
Man könnte es halt auch einfach ändern und dann verfällt es halt. Es könnte die Festplatte ausfallen bei diesen Providern, dann sind sie alle weg. Ich meine, kompletten Datenverlust, das hatten wir nun schon mehrfach bei solchen Webdiensten. Wie hieß ja noch gleich diese Link, diese so delicious-artige Bude, die ihren kompletten Datenbestand verloren hat. Jetzt komm ich gerade nicht drauf. Die danach einfach sang- und klanglos alles einstellen mussten. Was wird in der digitalen Welt immer häufiger geben? Das Ding ist natürlich, warum gibt es eigentlich dieses Konzept von kurzer URL nicht sowieso im Web quasi als Systematik. Und es gab ja vor kurzem, also vor kurzem, Magnolia war der Anbieter, genau, kommt hier gerade im Schalt, richtig. Danke für den Hinweis. Also Magnolia sind alle irgendwie Platten verloren gegangen, Backups im Arsch und so weiter und es war halt einfach irgendwie alles. Es war nicht alles so 100% weg, aber es war so weitgehend irgendwie, alles so weit im Eimer und dann war es halt irgendwie im Arsch. Es gibt jetzt ein Proposal, ein Short URL Proposal, wo man quasi seine Webseite so konfigurieren kann, dass mit jeder Seite im Header auch noch gleich eine alternative URL mitgegeben wird. Dass man sagt, wenn du auf diese lange URL, die du jetzt gerade siehst, kurz verweisen möchtest, dann benutze doch diese Short URL. So hast du sozusagen entweder in derselben Domain oder in einer speziellen Kurzform Domain, die man hat. Also wenn du irgendwie meinelangewebseite.com hast slash Bekanntmachung slash Sonntag slash Nachmittag slash geburtstagseinladung.html dann könntest du halt dann in dem Header sagen und hier ist die Short URL für den ganzen. Das ist irgendwie fc39. Und wenn du dann in deinem, damit wüsste sozusagen dein Browser oder jeder andere in irgendeiner Form Enable to Client und das ist ja nicht so das Thema. Was weiß ich, auch Twitter könnte sozusagen so eine lange URL nehmen, sie resolven und da würde ja auch schon ein Headrequest reichen. Und bekommt sozusagen die kurze URL und nimmt die dann halt. Das heißt, die Webseite definiert selbst über welche Domänen und welchen String sie verkürzt wird. Und damit ist es sozusagen benutzt du quasi dieselbe Infrastruktur.
Headrequest geht ja nicht, weil der Browser weiß ja nicht, dass es irgendwie ein Redirect ist.
Das kann er ja dadurch ganz gut rausfinden. Da muss ich ja nicht den ganzen Body schicken lassen, nur um zu checken, was dahinter ist.
Aber das weiß er doch vorher nicht, dass er ein Redirect kommt. Also macht er eine normale Anfrage und wird ja dann redirected.
Ja, mir geht es weniger um den Browser, sondern mir geht es eher um Systeme, die diese URL jetzt als solche speichern, wie Twitter. Wenn ich jetzt in meinem Twitter-Client diese URL gebe zum Posten, dann könnte er ein Head auf diese URL machen, dann steht da drin, das ist die Kurzform und dann nimmt er halt die. Und wenn keine Kurzform angeboten wird, dann nimmt er eben optional so einen Service zum Verkürzen. Ja, also ob ich nun Bit.ly sage, bitte gib mir die kurze Version oder ob ich die Webseite selber frage, gib mir die kurze Version, spielt ja an der Stelle überhaupt gar keine Rolle, wäre aber sozusagen der elegante Weg, weil man damit eben den Webseiten die Gelegenheit gibt, ihre eigenen Verkürzungsmechanismen zu machen.
Naja, ich weiß nicht, bis ich das durchsetze würde, aber einige sind Zeit vergehend, weil du brauchst dann noch eine ganz schöne Infrastruktur, um so einen Kurz-URL-Dienst dann quasi aus dem Boden zu stampfen.
Das kannst du einfach Teil deines CMS machen. Du kannst ja einfach eine Hashliste machen.
Wenn du CMS hast, aber so richtig sehe ich da den Vorteil noch nicht von diesen...
Ja, wenn du CMS hast, aber das kannst du problemlos in jedes WordPress einbauen.
Das kannst du problemlos in jedes WordPress einbauen, aber das brauchst du für diverse Dienste.
Es ist ja auch optional, es ist ja nur so, dass du eben, wenn man halt einfach erstmal checkt, gibst du da eine Short-URL, dann nimmst du die, sonst nimmst du halt einen Verkürzer. Achso.
Wäre es nicht eigentlich besser, wenn Twitter das selber anbieten würde?
Das wäre die andere Variante, aber dann hättest du auch immer noch das Problem, dass deine URLs dann eben bei Twitter...
Ja, aber sagen wir so, wenn bei Twitter, also wenn der Tweet...
Ja, aber du benutzt das ja nicht nur für Twitter, du benutzt das ja dann vielleicht auch für Identica und du hast ja auch immer noch deine E-Mails und du willst einfach generell irgendwie mit kürzeren URLs arbeiten. Das ist einfach ein Bedürfnis, dass man URLs eben auch leicht schreiben oder zumindest leicht unterbringen kann.
Wir kopieren die doch, also niemand tippt doch mehr URLs, wir kopieren die doch eben nur irgendwie Copy, Paste, direkt geklickt und was auch immer.
Ja, aber was ist, wenn du so eine URL in SMS packen willst oder halt in so ein Tweet und wenn sie halt einfach kurz sein sollen? Oder was ist, wenn du sie merken willst?
Na ehrlich gesagt kann ich mir dann die geschortneten Dinger auch noch nicht so wirklich gut merken, mit ihren ganzen komischen Buchstaben und Zeug, also das geht auch nicht.
Ja, das finde ich eher lang-URLs.
Ja, lang-URLs haben ja auch noch andere Probleme, das Umbruchproblem, das Sonderzeichenproblem und so weiter.
Das sollte man so wie auf Webseiten lösen, dass das halt ein Link ist, wo steht, was es ist, kurz und knapp und dahinter ist irgendwo die URL versteckt.
Ich sag ja HTML-E-Mail, aber auf mich hört ja keiner.
Warum was die jetzt bei Twitter nicht? Die könnten ihre 140 Zeichen ja auch mal ein bisschen pippen.
Die könnten das auch einfach mal sein lassen mit den 140 Zeichen-Links. Das wäre halt die andere Variante.
Die könnten URLs rausrechnen.
Ja, sie könnten halt sagen, URLs sind ein Zeichen.
Genau.
Ja, dass man sozusagen URLs generell einfach intern mit einem Hash-System speichert und dass sie in Tweets eben sind. Nur, wenn sie dann halt wieder ausgeliefert werden und sie sind größer als 140 Zeichen, dann crashen wir wahrscheinlich 90% der Twitter-Kleins erstmal für drei Monate.
Man kann ja auch DMs ohne Probleme mit mehr als 140 Zeichen verschicken. Damit kommt ja auch eigentlich jeder Klein klar.
Kannst du mehr als 140 Zeichen verschicken?
Ich 900 glaube ich.
Ach wirklich? Ich glaube, ich habe noch gar nicht angekündigt, dass wir live sind. Das fällt mir gerade ein.
Bei Mobile Max habe ich das gemacht.
Ah, du hast das gemacht. Das ist ja super. Ich sage ja mal Shared Collaboration. Das ist doch einfach mal geil. Ja, so viel zum Thema Kurz-URLs. Also ich verstehe alle Leute, die vor diesen Diensten warnen. Und das ist auch richtig. Und man sollte sich wirklich darüber Gedanken machen, in welchem Kontext man seine URL postet. Ob das irgendetwas ist, was eben nicht vergänglich ist. Und da gehören eigentlich auch Tweets dazu. Es könnte einfach sein, dass diese URLs als solche wechseln. Ich finde auch, muss ich auch sagen, was ich wirklich scheiße und am beklopptesten überhaupt finde, ist, dass eben durch diese URL-Verkürzer, die Domain selbst, also die URL selbst, ihre vollständige Aussagekraft verliert. Es könnte halt irgendwas sein. Also vom Sicherheitsaspekt jetzt mal ganz abgesehen. Einfach dieses, wenn zumindest die Domain die gleiche bliebe. Dann würde ich dir zumindest schon mal ansehen, was sich dahinter verwerfen hat.
Ich hatte mal angefangen, so einen URL-Shortnerdienst zu entwickeln, in dem das so ein bisschen drinsteckte. Also der dann so für bestimmte Seiten Kürzel drinne hat. Also kannst du zum Beispiel sagen, YouTube fängt immer mit YT an oder sowas. Also dass du noch ein bisschen Metainformation mit einbaust in die URL trotzdem. Was mich wundert, ein bisschen das Finanzierungsmodell. Ich finde, das sollte eigentlich relativ simpel sein. Indem man sagt, muss man natürlich transparent machen, den Nutzern gegenüber, aber indem man sagt, wenn ihr einen Amazon-Link da reinpappt und jemand kauft das darüber, wir packen da unsere Fleet-ID rein, und dann verdienen wir daran ein paar Cent. Und dann besteht die Chance, dass mit jedem tausendsten oder jedem zehntausendsten Klick ein paar Cent verdient werden.
Mit anderen Worten du forderst, dass die UALs dann auch noch modifiziert werden.
Vielleicht machen die das ja schon so.
Also ich weiß ja nicht.
Wenn man es transparent macht, finde ich das echt okay. Und wenn man im Idealfall sogar noch sagen würde, wir spenden davon, von den Einnahmen geht noch die Hälfte an irgendeine gut nützige allgemeine Organisation und schon könnte man die Welt retten, indem man Links postet. Ich weiß nicht. Ich fände es legitim. Ich fände es, wenn man es vernünftig macht, kann man das...
Ich glaube, das würde alles irgendwie nicht so richtig ankommen. Wie auch immer. Wir können jetzt auch zum nächsten Thema fortschreiten. Ich finde das jetzt nicht so spannend.
UAL-Shorten ist nicht so spektakulär, oder?
Nee, aber das muss ja mal gesagt werden. Ja, ich habe mir leider diesen Link jetzt mit dieser UAL-Shorten in den Geschichten nicht gemerkt, aber......leicht zu finden. Unix ist 40 geworden. 40 Jahre alt ist das Ganze jetzt.
Und? SCO ist pleite?
Na, die sind schein-tot.
Naja, da ist jetzt ein Insolvenzverwalter dran, der sagt, oh mein Gott, wie sieht das denn aus?
Ja, das war aber auch einfach richtig so.
Ja klar.
Und das war mir auch echt von Tag eins klar.
Wie lange ging das Spielchen jetzt?
Ich weiß nicht, ewig.
Aber Heißer hat schon darauf hingewiesen, dass dieser Insolvenzverwalter jetzt der Erste ist, der jetzt diese Beweise auch mal zu sehen kriegt, die sehr angeblich... Also SCO hatte ja irgendwann mal für dreieinhalb Minuten die Rechte an Unix, also AT&T Unix, und behauptet ja nun, dass IBM daraus Teile dann in Linux eingebaut hätte und dass damit Linux komplett illegal ist. Und wollte dann irgendwelche Lizenzen anbieten. Wie hießen diese Dot irgendwas Lizenzen? Egal. Und IBM hat gesagt, beweis das mal. Und SCO ist ja wirklich die ganzen... Ich glaube, das geht jetzt seit acht Jahren, dass die nicht mit den Beweisen rumgekommen sind.
Die Eier sind da noch rum.
Total. Und jetzt ist der Insolvenzverwalter der Erste, der sich jetzt mal außerhalb der Firma diese angeblichen Beweise angucken kann. Und wahrscheinlich wird der dann auch sagen...
Ja, das scheint schon immer mehr als auf Töne an den Füßen. Das war einfach klar, dass das das Ende von SCO ist. Also mir war das klar.
Mir war es nicht ganz so klar, aber die haben es wirklich geschafft. Eigentlich ging es der Firma ja vorher gar nicht schlecht. Das war so eine Softwarebude.
Die hatten eigentlich auch kein Businessmodell mehr. Ich glaube, das war so ihre Strategie, dass sie jetzt als Businessmodell in die Verklarung sind. Ja, klar. Verklarungsindustrie. Das hat ja eine Weile ganz gut funktioniert. Jetzt läuft das gerade so ein bisschen schlecht in den Markt. Aber da waren einfach komplette Loonies am Start. Die Leute, die diese strategische Entscheidung gefällt haben, die haben so dermaßen geringes Verständnis von Unix und der ganzen Computerwelt gezeigt. Da konnte man doch nur noch mit dem Kopf schütteln.
Ja klar, aber sie haben es wirklich geschafft. Sie haben eigentlich, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, okay, da stehende Firma innerhalb von acht Jahren wirklich in die komplette Pleite zu treiben, indem sie gigantische Anwaltskosten produziert haben und das in komplett albernen Prozessen verblasen haben.
Ja, und es ist wirklich schade, weil ja SCO, muss man dazu sagen, war ja mal eine Zeit lang wirklich ein Pionier. Also es war ja mal wirklich eine interessante Firma, die so im Unix-Bereich auch die Sachen in Bewegung gebracht haben. Also insbesondere auf den 386er und auf den 286er. Also mein erstes Unix überhaupt war SCO Xenix.
Okay.
Also als es noch Xenix war. Also dieses von Microsoft für 286 speziell angepasste Unix, was eben mit diesen 286er-Macken klar kam. So mit irgendwie 64K-Data, 64K-Codechunks und so eklige Sachen. Genau, aber es war so sagen wir mal vom Feeling her schon richtig Unix. Und beim 386er waren dann diese Segmentbeschränkungen des Prozessors weg. Und man hatte eine richtige MMU. Und dann war das halt so das erste Mal so richtig Unix wie auf so einem großen Computer. Und da konnte man dann eben dann doch ganz brauchbar arbeiten. Ich bin dann zwar auf Interactive Unix gewechselt seinerzeit, weil das war mir irgendwie lieber als SCO. Aber SCO hat dann lange Jahre lang eigentlich einen ziemlichen Höhenflug im Mittelstand gehabt. Und ja gut, aber irgendwann sind sie dann einfach auch nicht mehr attraktiv gewesen. Und Linux hat sie natürlich dann auch da komplett verdrängt.
Ja, aber in bestimmten Bereichen ist doch zumindest das AT&T Unix noch relativ verbreitet. Zahlt mich auch Apple schön, damit es...
Das AT&T Unix.
Naja, das was davon übrig ist sozusagen. Das ist doch sprönglich von AT&T, oder? Das was nach wie vor da rumwabbelt an Code. Wem gehört der jetzt gerade?
Novel? Gute Frage, ich hab so ein bisschen den Überblick verloren.
Noch die Letzte, die da streiten mit SCO, ist doch IBM und Novel, oder?
Genau. Und ich leh mir an, dass der guckt, nach wie vor Novel gehört. Und das SCO den lizenziert hatte.
Ich hab den Überblick verloren, wer jetzt der Letzte war, muss ich sagen. Ob das jetzt bei SCO liegt oder so, wie auch immer. Es spielt ja jetzt auch nicht mehr so die große Rolle.
Auf jeden Fall hat Apple sich mal fett auf die Seite draufgeschrieben, dass sie jetzt Unix sind. Naja. Richtig, mit Unix, Unix.
Das sind nicht so viele Üren.
Ja.
Es gibt nicht so viel wirkliches Unix. Linux ist kein Unix.
Genau. Das ist dann auch nicht. Der Kernel heißt der Xnu. X-N-U. Xnu ist not Unix.
Ist genau das gleiche wie GNU. GNU ist not Unix.
Wirklich? Ist das die Definition?
Was Offizielles gibt es natürlich nicht, aber so habe ich es mal gelesen.
Rekursive Akronym. Da könntest du eigentlich auch mal einen CRE draus machen.
Ich dachte, das wäre eine Referenz an den GNU-Kernel, den sie damals bei Mac OS weggehauen haben.
Aber davon ist doch gar nichts mehr da, oder?
Naja, eben. Deswegen so eine Referenz. Das ist jetzt Mac OS XNU oder so. Wahrscheinlich auch die verschiedensten Verschwörungstheorien zu dem Thema. Mein Chat Eichenhopst. Wahrscheinlich gibt es hier schon wieder interessante Hinweise. Die unterhalten sich über Posix.
X ist not UNIX, soll es wohl heißen. Steht hier bei Pure Darwin.
X ist not UNIX?
Wenn es jetzt ein rikursives Axorhymne ist, dann muss es schon XNU ist not UNIX heißen. Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall ist das UNIX genug, als dass man das so nennen darf. Das steht ja vollkommen außer Frage. Na ja, jetzt ist auf jeden Fall 40 Jahre alt ist diese Scheiße.
Und mittlerweile recht erfolgreich, oder?
Ja, ich meine, es benutzt ja fast keiner mehr was anderes. Nur Nokia behauptet, dass sie es noch nicht von würden.
Microsoft behauptet, dass sie es auch noch richtig okay in Marktanteil haben sollen.
Ja, ja. Hast du das mitbekommen mit den von mir häufig zitierten Vögeln? Na, diese Web-Statistiker.
NetApplications. Und was?
Nee. Die haben irgendwie ihre Statistikbasis umgebaut.
Ach so, und das ist jetzt nicht mehr so amerikalastig?
Ja, die haben da irgendwie jetzt versucht, zu China ein bisschen reinzurechnen und haben sozusagen den Gesamtreffig dann, wie war das nochmal? Also sie haben sozusagen sich angeschaut, okay, hier sind sozusagen jetzt diese Zugriffe, ja? Und dann ist irgendwie aber, ihr Sample-Material ist irgendwie 80% USA und die Zahlen sind jetzt erfunden. Also es ist sozusagen irgendeine Verteilung, so und so viel kommt aus dem westeuropäischen, nordamerikanischen Raum und so und so viel Prozent dieser Daten kommen aus China. Aber es gibt ja in China so und so viele Leute, die das benutzen, nur der Traffic von denen bleibt halt im Wesentlichen im Land, sodass sie quasi sagen, ok, da kommt jetzt zwar nur 5% China, aber diese 5% wird höher gewichtet. Wir rechnen das jetzt mal auf die tatsächlichen Computerbenutzer, die es da gibt, oder Rechner, die auch immer diese Zahl da in Relation setzen und blasen damit sozusagen das auf. Und dadurch, wobei ich jetzt zugeben muss, ich habe die Sachen nur zur Hälfte der Herr recherchiert, das eine war eine Meldung eben dazu, wo das irgendwie beschrieben wurde, und es habe dann sozusagen eine Halbierung des Mac OS X Anteils.
Also auf jeden Fall Safari ist abgestürzt.
Ja genau, und auch Mac OS X wäre so die Hälfte. Dann habe ich bei NetApplications nachgeschaut, mir die letzten Zahlen angeschaut, da konnte ich dann allerdings das nicht nachvollziehen. Vielleicht habe ich an der falschen Stelle geguckt.
Ich nehme an, die werden auch das bereinigt haben, dass sie nicht so eine Statistik haben, in der plötzlich jetzt Batsch von einem Monat auf den anderen Safari abstürzt.
Naja, das sagte dieser Bericht, sondern das ist nicht wiedergefallen. Aber Tatsache ist, da verschiebt sich das nochmal ein bisschen. Das ist natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht auch ein berechtigter Punkt, dass man eben mit unserer, die Welt ist nicht Amerika. Genau, in unserer US-lastigen Betrachtungsweise dann eben auch mal China berücksichtigen muss.
Naja.
Und wo ich jetzt gerade Nokia erwähnt habe.
Die haben jetzt die Lösung für ihre Probleme.
Ja.
Und zwar indem sie mit Microsoft zusammenarbeiten.
Na, das ist ja noch das nächste Ding.
Das heißt, zwei, die im Grab stehen, reichen sich die Hand.
Was war die Einigung? Die Einigung war, wir machen jetzt eine Applikation für Symbianen, damit man da Word-Dokumente lesen kann.
Und das andere war...
Word darf doch gar nicht mehr verkauft werden. Jetzt schmeißen wir mal schön News durcheinander.
Ähm, die eine Meldung, dass jemand berichtete, dass Nokia von Symbianen Abstand nehmen will und dass sie auf dieses, was heißt das jetzt?
Memo.
Memo umsteigen wollen. Aber da kam ja gleich Dementi von Nokia, was man ja eigentlich nur macht, wenn man es wirklich ernst meint, oder? Weiß nicht so genau. Sonst würde man ja einfach die Klappe halten.
Ich glaub denen nicht. Ich steh nach wie vor der Meinung, dass Symbian ein Auslaufmodell ist. Die werden das nicht aktualisiert bekommen. Ich meine, wie sollen die bitte in diesen alten scheißen IPv6-Stack reinkriegen? Das werden die einfach nicht hinkriegen. Die einzige Möglichkeit, einen soliden IPv6-Stack auf die Reihe zu kriegen mittelfristig heißt einfach, sich an das Development der anderen Systeme anzupassen. Das heißt einfach mal...
Aber sowas kann man doch einkaufen, oder nicht?
Was heißt einkaufen? Man muss ja den Kack gerne auch noch zum Laufen kriegen. Wo willst du das kaufen? Wer baut den IPv6-Stacks für Symbian? Und andere Sachen. Vor allem im Networking-Bereich, da kompetitiv zu bleiben, im Sicherheitsbereich mithalten zu können. Wir reden jetzt in zunehmendem Maße bei diesen Mobile-Devices von Network-Geräten. Die sind nicht deshalb toll, weil sie Telefone sind, weil sie rumtragen können, sondern weil sie Internet haben. Wenn sie Internet haben, werden sie in zunehmendem Maße auch wie ein normaler Desktop-Computer auch Sicherheitsprobleme etc. pp. haben. Ich glaube einfach nicht daran, dass sie die Mittel haben, dieses Symbian entsprechend zu härten und auch nicht technisch weiterbringen zu können, geschweige denn, dass sie eben noch Leute auf den Zug setzen, dafür Anwendung zu machen. Dass sie jetzt Microsoft dazu überzeugen können, da ein paar Symbian-Sklaven hinzusetzen, die dann versuchen, irgendwie diese kacke Wörter anzuzeigen. Okay, klar, natürlich. Das ist nicht so das Ding. Ich glaube, Microsoft ist derzeit glücklich über jeden Kooperationspartner, der überhaupt noch mit ihnen mitspielen will im Telefonbereich. Natürlich logen sie da auf diesen noch, was weiß ich, wie viel haben sie jetzt noch, irgendwie nach den letzten Zahlen, 47% oder so, ist da wieder irgendwie 2% eingebrochen, ne?
2%, aber naja.
Naja.
2% ist 2%.
Andere wären froh, wenn sie sich überhaupt hätten. Ich guck grad nochmal, das war doch hier vor kurzem. 2,4% haben sie irgendwie eingeböst im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr. Und, also Nokia. Und so wird's weitergehen.
Also ich nehme an, dass bei Nokia, die wissen nach wie vor, also die wissen nach wie vor einer Hand nicht, was die andere tut. Und es gibt bestimmt innerhalb der Firma, die genau sagen, Symbian ist tot, lasst uns schnell noch das Schiff wechseln, bevor wir mit untergehen. Und es wird die geben, die schon seit 15 Jahren an Symbian rumarbeiten und rumdoktern und da jedes Quartal gesehen haben, wie viele Millionen sie da reingesteckt haben und sich denken, das kann doch nicht schlecht sein, das muss doch modernisierungsfähig sein. Und ich nehme an, die beiden Kräfte oder wahrscheinlich noch viel, viel mehr werden innerhalb der Firma kämpfen und darum wird man von der einen Seite die Gerüchte kriegen und von der anderen Seite die Dementis. Und irgendwann wird das Ganze in einer Richtung ausgehen. Da wird eine Bewegung drin sein, aber ich glaube, die ist noch lange nicht abgeschlossen und die ist nicht so stringent, dass die jetzt irgendwie in einem halben Jahr nur noch Memo-Geräte draußen haben oder in einem Jahr.
Die sagen einfach deshalb noch nicht nein zu Symbian, weil sie einfach noch keine Alternative am Start haben. Warum das allerdings so lange dauert, da kratze ich mich ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen am Kopf.
Das hätten sie schon lange haben können. Das Memo, das gibt es jetzt seit wie lange gibt es das? Das habe ich mir glaube ich 2006 gekauft, das Nokia 770 oder so. Oder 2005 sogar noch.
Ja gut, aber das war halt mit ohne Telefon drin.
Na ja Gott, was dauert das da so ein GSM-Stack reinzupappen? Also es sollte für eine Telefonfirma wie Nokia wirklich innerhalb von...
Na gut, es wird ja noch mehr dazu. Es muss ja auch eine Telefon-Applikation und Syncing, ein Adressbuch und Papapa und so weiter.
Adressbuch und so hatten sie vorher schon. Das funktioniert so, HerrPix.
Ja, aber es funktionierte in dem Kontext mit ich bin ein mobiler Internet-Browser-Terminal-Dingsbums und nicht ein Telefon.
Sie hätten schon lange mitfertig sein können.
Na klar, sie hätten sich an alles Mögliche tun können, bloß sie tun halt nichts. Es geht halt nicht voran.
Mit allen großen Buden.
Ich will da nicht länger darauf einschlagen. Es gibt ja auch Leute, die der Meinung sind, ich liege da total falsch. Das mag ja sein. Das heißt nicht, dass ich da meine Meinung geändert habe. Ich denke, wir werden auch weiterhin jedes Quartal signifikante Verluste an Marktanteil sehen. Und sie verlieren ja auch nicht nur an Apple. Sie verlieren ja genauso an Rim und alle anderen.
Ich glaube, so richtig Angst können die vor Android haben. Das wird der Massenmarkt werden.
Ja, das denke ich nämlich auch. Also ich denke, dass Android und Apple sich im Wesentlichen den Markt teilen werden.
Aber so Rim bricht jetzt nun auch noch nicht wirklich ein, oder? Die legen ja auch noch ordentlich zu.
Ja, die gewinnen, na klar. Ich meine, sie haben zumindest eine Customer Base, die da ganz zugewandt ist. Und sie profitieren generell von dem Trend zu Smartphones. Also Nokia, das Marktanteil sinkt ja im Smartphone-Sektor. Und sie verdienen auch noch mit den anderen Telefonen. Rim macht nur Smartphones. Sie trainieren dazu, dass überhaupt der Smartphone-Markt an sich wächst. Aber obwohl der Smartphone-Markt wächst, kann Nokia davon nicht profitieren.
Also Rim, diese E-Mail-Applikation muss wirklich gut sein. Also ich kenne Leute, die haben Blackberry gehabt, sind dann irgendwann aufs iPhone gewechselt und nach ein paar Monaten reumütig zum Blackberry zurückgegangen. Weil die E-Mail-Applikation auf dem Blackberry ist wohl nach wie vor unschlagbar. Und da kommt wohl das iPhone...
Was ist daran so toll?
Ich weiß nicht, es sind irgendwelche Shortcuts. Du kannst alles unglaublich schnell machen. Wenn du dich mit dem Ding auskennst, soll es wirklich fantastisch funktionieren.
Wahrscheinlich Leute, die nur mailen können.
Und wenn du nicht... Wenn Mail nach wie vor... Also ich meine, der Blackberry ist gebaut um die Killer-Applikation Mail. Das ist sein einziger Zweck. Und wenn du auf diese Killer-Applikation angewiesen bist, und das bist du im Businessbereich vielleicht, da geht es dir nicht so sehr ums Twittern und ums Surfen, sondern geht es darum, dass deine Mail funktioniert, dann haben die bestimmt noch ordentliches Wachstum auch noch in den nächsten Jahren. Weil Mail wird jetzt sobald nicht sterben. So lange nicht wafel.
Nee, Mail wird nicht sterben, aber ich glaube, dass andere Dinge auch wichtig werden. Vor allem werden die Applikationen wichtig werden. Und da ist RIM auch noch nicht so weit. Sie sind jetzt noch nicht so weit, dass sie jetzt auch mit so einem Upstore glänzen könnten. Sie müssen auch erst mal zeigen, dass sie eine kritische Masse an Entwicklern überhaupt attraktiv auf ihre Plattform ziehen kann.
Ja, aber sie machen auch den Eindruck, als ob sie ein Betriebssystem hätte, was nicht beim leisesten Anfassen zusammenbricht. Jedenfalls hab ich da in der Richtung noch nichts mitbekommen.
Ja, also da können wir nicht aus.
Die haben halt die Business-Kunden, die werden sich da schon ein bisschen bemühen, dass alles ordentlich läuft, sonst würden die das ja nicht so toll finden.
Ja, also es ist nicht der allerletzte Dreck, so wie dieses Symbian, aber es ist irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, also mich überzeugt das auch nicht so.
Ich kann gar nichts sagen, weil ich hab noch nie eins gesehen.
Hast du noch nie ihm das gesehen?
Blackberry.
Aber ich hab vorhin einen gesehen, der mit einem 3GS auf dem Fahrrad gefahren ist und hat dabei mit dem iPhone seine Freundin, die auch auf dem Fahrrad vorgefilmt ist, zu zweizulang gepresst. Und das kann ja nur ein 3GS gewesen sein, weil die können ja nur Video.
Oder ein gehacktes.
Oder hat er mal Bilder gemacht die ganze Zeit.
Nee, ich denke mal, es war ein neues. Wir waren jetzt bei Microsoft noch. Und irgendwie Kooperationen.
Das heißt Microsoft-Bashing-Häkchen.
Nokia-Bashing-Häkchen.
Also dass jetzt Microsoft und Nokia da zusammenarbeiten. Ich weiß nicht genau, was da noch alles in diesem Agreement drinsteht, aber es ging doch im Wesentlichen eigentlich nur um dieses Wörth-Kram. Oder gab es noch irgendwelche anderen Ausfälle?
Nee, richtig, da gab es noch nicht drinnen.
Das ist halt das heiße Luft.
Und das Nokia meinte vorher, dass die Symbianen da committed sind und so, dass sie nicht auf diesen...
Im Prinzip haben sie nur angekündigt, dass in ihrem komischen Ovi-Store demnächst noch ein Programm mehr verfügbar ist. Das ist doch hervorragend.
Ach, noch eins?
Na ja, Microsoft hat sich ja dann auch irgendwie Yahoo noch so ein bisschen einverleibt und weiter an ihrem Niedergang gearbeitet.
Was da schon noch so ein bisschen mit drin stand, ist, dass Microsoft diese Office-Produkte auch fürs iPhone rausbringen will.
Das stand da drinne?
Das stand da auch mit dabei. Ich glaub schon. Hab ich da nicht geträumt, oder?
Yes, Axel auf dem iPhone.
Ja voll toll, ne?
Erfüllung meiner feuchten Träume.
Ja, darauf hat die Welt gewartet.
Also ich kann das ja nochmal kurz hinterher googeln, aber so hab ich das da rausgelesen.
Das wird dem iPhone sicherlich nicht schaden.
Habt ihr das Mittel bekommen, dass Microsoft jetzt in Texas verurteilt worden ist und angeblich in zwei Monaten Word nicht mehr verkaufen darf?
Das war so ein Link, wo ich mir gedacht hab, da klick ich jetzt nicht drauf.
Also, die sind verurteilt worden, wegen irgendeinem XML-Patent. Also, wenn ich das Patent richtig verstanden habe, im Wesentlichen dafür, dass man einen Container nutzt, in den man sowohl sozusagen XML-Daten reinpackt, als auch Binaerdaten. Also, dass man die Bilddaten nicht direkt in die XML-Datei packt, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Darauf haben die irgendwie seit 1998 einen Patent. Diese Bude, der Name, die wahrscheinlich auch, gehe ich mal von aus, nicht mehr lange existieren werden. Und die sind jetzt verurteilt worden, sollen irgendwie, also Microsoft ist verurteilt worden, sollen irgendwie so und so viele Millionen, 100 Millionen, 130 Millionen waren es glaube ich Zahlen. Was glaube ich auch für Microsoft nicht so ist, dass die sich das mal eben sagen, alles klar hier, Überweisung war.
Aber das ist jetzt noch nicht final und der letzte Beschluss, da ist jetzt erst mal ein Urteil gefällt.
Das Urteil ist gefällt, das geht jetzt noch mal ein bisschen weiter. Aber die haben halt ein Verkaufsverbot ab in zwei Monaten für Microsoft Word ausgesprochen. Das darf in Amerika nicht mehr verkauft werden.
Ganz Amerika.
Das wird bestimmt halten, das Urteil.
In ganz Nordamerika. Naja, aber ich meine, im schlimmsten Fall wird es Microsoft eine sehr, sehr große Latte Geld kosten.
Der Staatsanwalt von dem Staat wird Office benutzen können. Schon deswegen geht es nicht.
Hätten Sie mal XML gleich mal so benutzt, wie man das benutzen sollte.
Nämlich einfach ein XML.
Wieso? Ich pack eine XML-Datei rein und pack binäre Daten woanders hin. Das ist ja nun, das macht ja Open Office...
Aber woanders, nicht in dieselbe Datei.
Sozusagen, genau. Also wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ist genau das der Weg. Ich glaube, das ist relativ ähnlich dem Open Office-Format. Bei Open Office ist es eine ZIP-Datei, die du da außen rum hast. Du packst halt alles, du packst die XML-Datei rein.
Also das ist quasi ein Bundle.
Genau, genauso wie auf Mac ein Bundle oder sowas. Und das haben die sich patentieren lassen, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Ja, aber darüber müssen wir wirklich nicht reden.
Aber kann man irgendjemanden skype?
Aber vielleicht reden wir darüber, dass Microsoft ja auch mit Yahoo! noch eine Partnerschaft eingegangen ist? Habt ihr das begleitet?
Da hab ich wieder nicht geklickt.
So, so. Naja, also Yahoo! stellt seine Suche ein. Also ihre eigene Suchtechnologie und geht halt auf Bing, die Maschine mit dem Bing, was ja wohl ganz gut funktionieren soll.
In Amerika?
Ich hab's jetzt nicht so benutzt, aber das sei jetzt wohl ordentlich so schlecht.
Wie war es in Deutschland? Darf man nicht nach Strumpfhose suchen bei Bing?
Das war glaube ich noch MSN Search.
Gilt für Bing genauso.
Ja? Man darf es nach Strumpfhose suchen.
Also auf jeden Fall ist es...
Weißt du, was die Übersetzung von Panties ist? Und Panties ist schon XXX oder was?
Ich hab keine Ahnung nach welchem Prinzip das ist.
Aber, naja, wie auch immer.
Auf jeden Fall haben sie da sozusagen jetzt ein Deal gelandet. Ob der ihnen so hilft, weiß ich nicht. Ich meine, was bedeutet das schon? Sie übernehmen jetzt sozusagen 30% des Suchanfragen marktes. Das heißt, den müssen sie sozusagen auch noch bedienen. Also sie verdienen ja damit nicht automatisch auch mehr Geld. Sondern vor allem haben sie das Problem, dass sie jetzt sozusagen den Kram, den bisher Yahoo! getragen hat, auch nochmal tragen müssen. Und ihr ganzes Suchmaschinengeschäft macht ohnehin Minus. Und ich hab so ein paar Berechnungen gesehen, wonach das irgendwie sehr offensichtlich ist, dass sie dann sozusagen noch mehr Minus machen. Nur weil sie jetzt sozusagen den Suchtreffekt von Yahoo! auch noch nehmen, machen sie ja noch nicht automatisch mehr Plus. Weil ihr ganzes Suchgeschäft ist defizitär. Wie die meisten ihrer Non-Office, von Betriebssystem Segmente.
Ja, aber Moment mal, war da auch noch nicht noch ein bisschen Werbemarkt mit drin, in dem ganzen Bundle?
Ja, aber sie verdienen nicht genug Geld mit dem ganzen... Achso, du meinst jetzt in dem Deal mit Yahoo!
Genau, dass die teilweise die Yahoo! Websites mit vermarkten. Mit Werbung etc.
Ja, das kann sein.
Und so rein trafiktechnisch sind die Yahoo! Seiten insgesamt ja gar nicht schlecht. Also wenn du, wenn man jetzt nur jetzt nur das Suchgeschäft nimmt, klar, dann ist Google ungeschlagener Meister und Yahoo! hat keine Chance und MSN auch nicht ernsthaft. Aber wenn man so dieses ganze E-Mail-Geschäft, so Hotmail und Yahoo! Mail und wenn man das mal alles mit einbezieht, dann steht Yahoo! alles andere als schlechter. Dann ist Yahoo! echt ein... Dann haben die wirklich sehr viel Traffic und den zu vermarkten, das dürfte durchaus was bringen. Ich meine, Google lebt ja von der selben Aktion.
Tja, naja, aber Google macht da halt auch wirklich Gewinn und Microsoft macht halt keinen Gewinn.
Tja, zu spät umgestiegen.
Google macht Gewinn und Microsoft macht noch keinen Gewinn.
Er hat noch nie Gewinn gemacht.
Yahoo! oder Microsoft? Microsoft hat noch nie Gewinn gemacht, ich glaube schon. Im Suchbereich? Achso, im Suchbereich.
Die machen halt nur Gewinn mit ihrem OS und den Office-Produkten. Alles andere macht Minus. Aber ich glaube sogar die Xbox macht immer noch Minus, oder?
Ich glaube, die haben jetzt auch mal ein Quartal hingelegt, wo sie dann nicht noch weiteres Minus gemacht haben und so und verdienen auch mal ein bisschen was zwischendurch. Aber bis sie da das Minus der ersten Jahre ausgeglichen haben, dafür geht noch ein bisschen Zeit.
Ja, aber sie haben auch genug Geld mit dem Office und dem Windows-Geschäft auf die Seite gepackt.
Genau, das ist ja das Problem, die wohnen sich auf ihren Lorbeeren.
Ja, aber wir hatten ja nun das letzte Microsoft-Quartal, war ja insofern ein bisschen bemerkenswert, dass das jetzt ihre Serie gestoppt ist. Ich meine, gut, man kann jetzt sagen, ok, big deal, Microsoft hat das erste Mal nicht mehr Umsatz als im Quartal davor gemacht. Aber es ist halt eine Zäsur. Also Microsoft hat ganz offensichtlich die aktuelle Krise, die sogenannte, etwas ausgemacht. Also sie befinden sich gerade an einem Punkt, wo sie nachweislich nicht mehr in der Lage sind, ihren Markt zu vergrößern. Und wir haben es ja hier schon 1000 Mal benannt. Ich denke, dass sie halt einfach vor einer ganzen Serie von Problemen stehen, die sie jetzt alle auf einmal im Prinzip lösen müssen. Und das tun sie eben zu einer Phase, wo sie eben auch Umsatzeinbrüche haben. Übrigens in dem selben Quartal, in dem Apple sein bestes Quartal, nicht Weihnachtsquartal abgelegt hat. Und ich bin ja ja bekanntermaßen sehr skeptisch, was sozusagen den weiteren Ausweg betrifft.
Gerade drei Milliarden Gewinn hätten sie im letzten Quartal gemacht?
Naja, die...
Ja, aber zum ersten Mal weniger als...
Es geht halt runter. Und gut, viel Gewinn hin und viel Gewinn her. Microsoft ist auch eine Firma, die Schulden hat im Gegensatz zu Apple. Also ich kann das jetzt buchhalterisch alles nicht so zusammenrechnen. Und sicherlich ist das jetzt sozusagen auch noch nicht ihr unmittelbarer Untergang, nur weil sie jetzt mal ein schlechtes Quartal gehabt haben. Aber es ist halt offensichtlich eine Wende im Geschäft. Also sie werden einfach in ihrem Kerngeschäft ihren Scheiß nicht mehr so ohne Weiteres los. Warum? Natürlich weil die amerikanischen Unternehmen vor allem, nicht nur, aber vor allem auch die, derzeit einfach sparen, wo sie können. Ist ja klar.
Die haben den Umstack auf Vista nicht mitgemacht. Das ist schon zum ersten Mal.
Ja, und es werden auch nicht mehr so viele PCs gekauft. Damit werden auch nicht automatisch mehr Windows-Lizenzen gekauft. Und das ist eben das Business, auf dem Microsoft basiert.
Aber ich weiß ja nicht, wie das... Also wenn man... Irgendwann gibt es ja einen Investitionsdruck. Oder wie heißt das? Ich weiß es nicht. Also auf jeden Fall, irgendwann sind die ganzen PCs, die da rumstehen in den Unternehmen, sind so veraltet, dass sie nichts Neues mehr mit... Also dass sie ersetzt werden müssen.
Na ja, meistens macht zwei Wochen der Fall.
Das ist bei Menschen wie uns nach Gefühl zwei Wochen der Fall. Das ist bei Unternehmen dort meistens ein bisschen länger. Und viele von denen haben ja einfach gesagt, ach, lassen wir mal Vista aus. Weil Vista ja nicht gerade unbedingt die besten Kritiken damals gekriegt hat.
Klar.
Und dass die jetzt vielleicht so ein bisschen unter Druck stehen, so, wir haben jetzt schon seit Windows XP keine neuen Rechner mehr gekauft, langsam müssen wir mal wieder.
Ja, die kaufen vielleicht auch neue Rechner, aber sie kaufen nicht unbedingt Windows 7.
Ich glaube, die Chancen sind nicht so schlecht, dass sie Windows 7 kaufen. Warum nicht Windows 7?
Das ist immer noch Vista. Ich meine, es ist dasselbe Produkt in neu. Also technologisch stellt es nach wie vor dieselben Probleme.
Also die Reviews, die ich gelesen habe, sprechen eine bisschen andere Sprache. Es soll deutlich schneller geworden sein, zumindest was das Gefühl angeht. Es soll nicht wesentlich langsamer sein als Windows XP. Hat einige Kinderkrankheiten nicht mehr, die Vista hat. Also die Aussage, die ich in den Reviews gelesen habe, ist klar, Mac-User wären darüber lachen, aber für einen Windows-User ist es wirklich ein echter Vorteil.
Ja, aber das mag für einen Home-User ja wirklich relevant sein. Und das mag ja auch durchaus dazu führen, dass die dann upgraden, wo sie bei Vista noch ausgelassen haben, oder keine Ahnung. Aber das ändert nichts daran, dass Windows 7 horrend teuer ist, wenn du das im Vollausbau haben willst. Das kostet richtig viel Geld. Und es ändert auch nichts daran, dass es eben gegenüber zu XP einfach einen systematischen Wechsel bedeutet, was irgendwie Hardware-Support und so weiter betrifft.
Ja, aber ewig können sie XP nicht mehr einsetzen.
Warum nicht? Was glaubst du, wie lange die irgendwie Windows 95 angewendet haben? Wie lange die Windows 2000 gefahren haben?
Irgendwann brauchst du was echt, also irgendwann musst du auf 64-Bit.
Das Problem ist, wenn sie auf Windows 7 gehen, dann müssen sie ihre ganze Custom-Business-Mittelware-Software, die sich jetzt über Jahre zusammengehackt und gekauft haben, halt auch alle durch die Bank upgraden.
Oder sie lassen die in der Windows XP-Simulation. Es gibt ja diesen XP-Emulator.
Hurra! Aber warum sollten sie auf Windows 7 gehen, wenn sie danach wieder alles in einem XP-Simulator laufen lassen? Da können sie auch gleich bei XP laufen.
Teilweise umzusteigen, 64-Bit.
Ja, die 64-Bit-Migration ist ja nochmal ein ganz anderes Thema.
Die kannst du in einem Abwasch machen.
Hast du diese schöne Upgrade-Matrix gesehen? Wenn man sozusagen was man vorher hat und wenn man danach welches Windows... Also das ist so ein, was weiß ich, 7x7-Matrix.
Das war bei Fake Steve Jobs, oder?
Das ist an verschiedenen Stellen verlinkt worden.
Das haben wir letztes Mal nicht erwähnt. Fake Steve Jobs ist wieder da.
Ja. Willst du jetzt gleich wieder das Thema komplett wechseln, während wir uns gerade für dich noch was zu konzentrieren? Du hast halt diese Upgrade-Matrix und ich glaube von den... Oh Gott, ich müsste es jetzt von der Nase haben. Also gefühlt gab es da irgendwie 50 Kästchen und davon waren irgendwie so vier oder fünf markiert. Mit in dieser Betriebssystem von nach Kombination kannst du einfach die CD einlegen und das Upgraden in Place. Bei allen anderen ist ein sogenannter Custom Install nötig. Und wir wissen auch, auch diese 64-Bit-Geschichte ist halt signifikant, auch das bedeutet eben Programme und Treiber und so weiter müssen eben getauscht werden.
Klar, aber irgendwann musst du als Windows-Anwender in diesen sauren Apfel beißen.
Ja, aber die Leute wollen nicht in diesen sauren Apfel beißen. Und deswegen werden sie das so lange aussitzen, wie es nur irgendwie geht. Insbesondere in einer Zeit, wo alle ihre Kohle zusammenhalten und sie bestimmt keinen Bock haben, sich da so eine Scheiße an die Karren fahren zu lassen. Denn sie haben jetzt mit Vista schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht. Sie haben alle irgendwie Angst. Jetzt müssen sie erstmal davon überzeugt werden, dass Windows 7 wirklich eine Änderung herbeibringt. Nur weil da jetzt so ein paar Windows-Lonis der Meinung sind, ist es jetzt zehn Prozent schneller und wir haben jetzt irgendwie 30 Prozent weniger Probleme, wenn die noch nicht gleich alle Hurra schreien. Da haben die irgendwie ganz andere Prioritäten. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass sie jetzt alle losgehen werden und Macintoshs kaufen werden. Das ist nicht das, was ich sage. Ich sage nur, die warten. Das heißt, der eigentliche Kernmarkt, nämlich die Erwartung, die sich ja auch lange Zeit immer erfüllt hat von Microsoft, dass die Firmen einfach kontinuierlich neue Rechner kaufen und kontinuierlich auf ein neues Betriebssystem gehen. Früher oder später. Früher war es halt tendenziell früher als später. Das geht jetzt eben so nicht mehr ohne weiteres auf, was so einen großen Laden wie Microsoft schon in die Bredouille bringt.
In die Bredouille auf jeden Fall.
Ihre Workforce und sie haben Image-Probleme und was und was nicht alles.
Ich sage jetzt nicht, dass es wieder super besser wird, aber Windows 7 scheint deutlich besser zu sein als Vista.
Na hurra!
Und insofern wird es Ihnen erstmal einen kleinen Ausflug geben.
Ja, aber ich glaube nicht, dass Sie mit dem... Ja, ich meine, was ist denn das für eine Leistung? Nach wie vielen Jahren XP? Sieben Jahre oder wie lange liegt das jetzt zurück?
2001 oder 2002 war es, ja ja.
Ewig. So, ja. Und alles, was Sie bringen können, ist, wir haben jetzt ein Betriebssystem, was ein bisschen weniger scheiße ist, als der erste Versuch, der komplett in die Hose gegangen ist. Das ist doch irgendwie nix. Also, das mag ja sein, dass Sie es schaffen, ein paar neue PCs zu verkaufen, ein paar Upgrade-Lizenzen und so weiter. Aber das wird Ihr Core-Business-Modell bestenfalls gerade so eben auf einem leicht abgeschwächten Level erhalten können. Aber, dass Sie jetzt wirklich Switcher wieder zurückgewinnen, das sehe ich einfach nicht. Wirklich. 6 x 10 oder was? Also diese Matrix, die ist wirklich großartig. Was haben Sie da alles? XP, Vista Starter in 32-Bit und 64-Bit, Vista Home Basic in 32- und 64-Bit, Vista Home Premium. Da blickt doch kein Schwein durch. Vista Business und Ultimate. So, und die neuen Versionen von Windows 7 sind ein bisschen übersichtlicher. Da gibt es Home Premium, Professional und Ultimate. Wenn ich also kein Professional bin, dann bin ich Alt-Mit?
Na, Ultimate hat alles. Es gibt Sachen, die sind nur in Home Premium. Das heißt, es gibt Sachen, die sind Professional.
Okay, also Business heißt jetzt Professional und Home Basic gibt es nicht mehr. Das ist sozusagen die Vereinfachung.
Home Basic war ja diese ganz widerliche Version, ich glaube, da sind sie sogar mal verklagt worden für. Weil Home Basic ist so diese Version, wo sie nur, wo gar nichts drin ist. Wo nicht mal dieses Aero, dieses transparente Fenster drin sind, wo ihr natürlich richtig schön einmal gegen die Wand scheißt, wenn ihr...
War da ein Basic dabei?
Wahrscheinlich, konntest du alles noch... Hello World...
Schreib mir so ein und dann kommst du mit Ready.
C64? Aber das ist mal Aero Look, nein.
Also es ist die Hölle. Mit anderen Worten, das Einzige, was du in-place machen kannst, ist...
Du kannst immer...
Von Home und Home auf Home und Home, auch nur wenn es 32 ist oder 64 ist. In derselben Architektur, in derselben Kategorie. Du kannst immer dasselbe Upgrade machen.
Das ist ja eigentlich auch was, was man normalerweise verwenden wird. Ich glaube, Microsoft hat sich hier mal wieder... Dieses Chart hat echt ein Usability-Problem. Man könnte nämlich auch einfach sagen, mach doch erstmal das Upgrade auf Home Premium und danach schaltest du die Ultimate Features frei. Ja, ja, das kann man. Du kannst mit einer der selben DVD...
Okay, also jetzt müssen wir das mal ausrechnen. Was hast du gesagt, das sind 60, ja? Wie viele Sachen sind jetzt grün? 1, 2, 3, 4? 14. 14 zu 60, also ein Viertel.
Genial.
Ein Viertel.
Ein Viertel wär 12. Aber man kann auf jeden Fall nicht zwischen 32 und 64 Bit wechseln. Das geht auch nicht. Da muss man immer gleich neu installieren.
Das ist doch krank.
Ich weiß nicht, was ist denn so ein Custom Install?
Custom Install heißt neu installieren und irgendwie wahrscheinlich gibt's so eine Migrationsgeschichte.
Wir nennen so was Clean Install.
Ist das bei Mac Archive and Install?
Weiß ich nicht. Da reden wir nachher. 14.6 hat sich auch noch was geändert. Aber wir müssen mal von diesem Microsoft weg. Das interessiert doch alles. Gar keine Mac User. Ach, also sowas doch nicht mehr. Ich behalte meinen XP zu Hause.
Ich behalte auch XP auf meinem iPhone.
Wir sagen nichts mehr zu Microsoft. Es sei denn, der Chat will, dass wir über Microsoft reden.
Nee, die haben sich vorhin schon gelang gehält. Haben schon gefragt, ob das der Microsoft Mobile ist.
Ah, echt? Okay, alles klar. Wir entschuldigen uns. Sorry.
Gut, dann lass uns mal schön Apple bashen.
Ich hab noch was Non-Appliges.
Du hast noch was Non-Appliges?
Was denn?
Ach, gibt's da News?
Ja, es gibt jetzt... Was war das? Das SDK wird an Einzelne herausgegeben. Ich hab von verschiedenen Leuten gelesen, die jetzt damit rumspielen.
Also, naja, es gibt... Nee, es sind zwei Sachen. Ich glaube, in so Teile des Codes kann sich jeder runterladen, der mag. Also, das ist... Da gehst du auf die entsprechende Google-Code-Website und lädst dir das einfach runter und dann hast du es. Ist allerdings nicht ganz so trivial, das Song drauf zu bringen. Ich hab mir den Code mal runtergeladen, glaube ich. Also ich weiß gar nicht mehr, in welcher Stelle ich dann gescheitert bin. Aber so ist es nicht so, dass man was runterlädt und dann klickt man doppelt und dann hat man einen schönen Server, tralala, sondern da muss man schon eine ganze Menge machen. Die andere Variante ist, dass... Das wird garantiert etwas unterschiedlicher sein als dieses offizielle Google-Wave, sondern es wird wahrscheinlich nur ein Protokoll-Stack sein, auf dem man dann Anwendungen entwickeln kann oder sowas. Das andere ist, dass sie diese Sandbox haben. Und die Sandbox, das ist, da werden Entwickler so peu à peu eingeladen, wenn man sich anmeldet, doch teilzunehmen und das mal zu checken und sich anzugucken. Und dann kann man auf dem Entwicklungs...
Was ist jetzt die Sandbox?
Quasi ein Alphasystem, würde ich mal behaupten.
Was ist das? Ein SDK, eine Software?
Nein, das ist eine Webseite. Das ist eine Seite von Google, und auf der kannst du Wave nutzen.
Ah ja, da braucht man aber so ein Invite oder was?
Da braucht man so ein Invite. Ich nehme an, die wollen, wenn die jetzt alle auf einmal drauf loslassen würden auf den Server, der noch nicht stabil ist und so was, und wir dann alle mit unseren Google Wave-Accounts da rumrennen.
Ich habe nur gehört, es ist halt alles noch relativ eckig und kantig. Also es ist alles, wenn man es so benutzt, nicht so flüssig, wie sie es auf der Demo sozusagen hinbekommen haben, den Eindruck zu machen.
Also ich habe schon so mitbekommen, so wow, geil, geil, geil. Oh, schon wieder abgestürzt. Mist, aber geil, geil, geil.
Ja, geil ist das.
Und ich habe es auch auf dem iPhone, ich habe so ein iPhone-Video gesehen, das ist jetzt auch, du trittst was auf den Rechner ein und dann hast du auf dem iPhone in der Webseite, siehst du sofort die Änderungen alle auch. Also dass auch das dann geht, dass eine mobile Anwendung kam, also es scheint schon dann...
Da ist halt Web, ne? Es ist hier Web-Profit, das läuft halt im Brauch.
Ja, aber vorher hatten sie nur, naja, aber jetzt haben sie eine explizite mobile Anpassung. Vorher hatten sie im mobilen Bereich nur, dass du, ich glaube, du konntest Daten nur angucken überhaupt. Weil von der Seitenaufteilung her, dass du nicht mit Framesets arbeitest und so weiter und so fort. Google liegt auch noch ein bisschen Wert. Und jetzt ist es so, dass es offensichtlich schon zu einem ganz ordentlichen Teil auch in mobilen Anwendungen geht.
Verstehe. Das basiert ja, wenn ich es richtig gelesen habe, also es wird quasi als Plug-In-System ausgeliefert für ein Framework, was OpenFire heißt, was wohl mal Wildfire hieß. Und was so eine Social-Network-Framework ist.
OpenFire kenn ich eigentlich als quasi XMPP-Server.
Genau.
Ist das nicht, was Jabba benutzt oder Jabba ist?
Ja, Jabba ist der Projektname, der letztlich ein Standard hervorgebracht hat, der XMPP. Jetzt heißt der sozusagen Standard, der Standard ist. Und Google Talk ist ja auch XMPP. Und im Prinzip haben sie auf der Basis weitergearbeitet. Und Google Wave ist eine Erweiterung von XMPP. Das sagt ja das X in dem MPP aus, dass es halt extensible ist, dieser Messaging-Protokollbereich. Und das ist jetzt ihr Beitrag, das Ganze zu erweitern. Und aber als Implementierung haben sie halt Jabba gewählt und keinen Standalone-Software gemacht, die jetzt einfach so für sich installiert. Dann hast du da Google Wave, sondern sie basieren eben auf der Basis von OpenFire, was wiederum ein XMPP-Server ist, in dem man eben reinconnecten kann. Das Ding bringt sozusagen schon mal so Administrationselemente und SSL-Support und so weiter, Installationsprozesse, Webinterface, LDAP, Backend und so ein Kram mit. Und dann kommt eben das Wave da sozusagen als Inject rein. Und überall, wo du eben eine OpenFire-Sache installiert hast, kannst du da quasi Google Wave dazu installieren. Was schon mal ganz interessant ist, dass das eben alles auf Java basiert. Ich meine, das überrascht mich überhaupt nicht, weil das ist halt einfach der Weg, den Google ja geht, auch mit Android und so. Das heißt, da werden sie da auch gut zum Einsatz bringen können, denke ich mal, auf Android. Dass sie eben dann auch so native Wave-Clients machen, dann in Java und so weiter, vielleicht eben nicht in HTML. Sprich auch auf Devices mit weniger Prozessor-Power da schon ganz gut Leistungsfähigkeit sein zu können. Das ist jetzt eine reine Mutmaßung. So kann auch sein, dass sie da den Webweg gehen. I don't know. Aber ich halte das ja immer noch für die heiße Scheiße des Jahres und bin echt gespannt, wenn das rauskommt.
Was ich den schönsten Teil daran finde, ich weiß nicht, ob wir das schon mal hatten, ist, ich saß irgendwann mal vor einem Jahr mit einem Kumpel zusammen und wir haben dann beim Bion so gedrückt, es könnte eigentlich so das nächste große Ding sein im Netz. Also was macht das Web 3.0 sozusagen aus? Und unser Gedanke damals war, es wird Push sein. Push ist das große Ding. Und zwar nicht dieses Pseudo-Push, was wir jetzt haben. Also was wir im Augenblick haben, ist ja, es gibt diese Webseite, also klassisch Webseite, gehst da drauf, musst, wenn du Inhalte sehen willst neu, musst du ein Reload der Seite machen, ist doof. Dann gibt es so dieses Ajaxi. Ich frage alle paar Sekunden nach. Bamm, ist was Neues da, ist was Neues da, ist was Neues da. Und ist auch noch keine schöne Lösung, weil kostet unglaublich Ressourcen und wird nur informiert, wenn der gerade mal nachfragt. Was jetzt auch Google geht diesen Weg, ist ja explizit zu sagen, der Webclient stellt eine Verbindung zu unserem Java-Server her und wird dann, ohne dass es uns extrem viele Ressourcen kostet, sau schnell darüber informiert, wenn was Neues da ist. Und ja, ich glaube, dass es wirklich, dass dann diese Vorhersage, Web 3.0 wird about, it's about push, stupid.
Naja, also jetzt nur für das Push-Feature gleich die nächste Generation weltweit Web auszupacken.
Das wird eine komplett neue Generation von Applikationen ermöglichen.
Also wird halt alles dauer-live sein. Du connectest dich auch zu dem Wave, das Wave kommt nicht zu dir, sondern du connectest dich hin und dann sagt er, da ist was. Oder er kann dich auch benachrichtigen, dass was da ist, aber es wird nicht mailsmäßig oder IMAP-mäßig zu mir geschickt, sondern es ist alles dort und bleibt auch dort. Es wird mehr so IMAP-mäßig. Und du kriegst nur noch eine Nachricht. Es wird auch gar nichts mehr lokal gespeichert, nehme ich an.
Lokal auf deinem Remote-Client sozusagen.
Also IMAP liegt zwar auf dem Server, aber ich hole es ja trotzdem noch und habe auch offline eigentlich alles da. Bei Wave wird das wahrscheinlich wegfallen, man hat wirklich, weil man ist sowieso immer dauer online, man hat alles auf dem Server liegen.
Bei Wave gibt es beide Möglichkeiten.
Beide?
Es ist explizit vorgesehen, dass auch dein Server, also wenn ich einen Server habe, dass dann noch mein Dokument liegt.
Aber dann ist er nicht mehr wirklich live, wenn der andere dann rumeditiert, das kann er nun mal nicht.
Ich rede jetzt über zwei Sachen. Du redest von deinem eigenen Server haben, er redet von dem Client.
Aber auch im Client wird das Ganze wahrscheinlich nochmal gespeichert werden, damit du offline aufzugreifen kannst.
Aber dann fallen ja diese Interactive-Features weg, oder?
Du kannst live sein, du kannst online sein oder offline.
Also du kannst einen Client entwickeln, der eben auch offline eine Kopie vorhält und so weiter. Das ist ja klar. Aber das Prinzip ist halt vor allem, dass du serverbasiert arbeitest. Was ja auch eigentlich total Sinn macht, wenn man eben weniger in Richtung E-Mail denkt, sondern eben mehr in Richtung komplexe Dokumentenbearbeitung und Historie. Quasi eher so wie Wiki. Also, grob gesagt ist ja WAV so ein bisschen das Zusammengehen der Wiki-Idee und E-Mail.
Subisa-Mail.
Duketaheddel hat eine neue Version. Das haben wir durchaus erwähnt. Das trauen sich bestimmt bei Bits und so noch nicht mal zu sagen.
Folding.
Sind da immer so bescheiden. Ja, wenn sie jetzt noch dieses Projektfensterchen machen, was Textmata hat, dann wechsle ich vielleicht wieder.
Und wenn sie endlich mal einen Server einrichten würden, wo man irgendwie ein Dokument anmelden kann, der übernimmt es, und dann können sich alle hinconnecten, ohne dass ich jetzt auch gerade irgendwie da sein muss, also dass der Server das auch weiterhält, wenn vielleicht gerade gar keiner da ist. Und wenn der Server das auf dem Server live speichert, dass es sozusagen auch eine Webseite sein könnte, dann wäre das nämlich eine Art Sub-Isa-Wiki-Tralala, was gleich auch live geschaltet wird. Und das wäre mal ein Feature. Das könnte man wiederum mit einem ganzen Baum machen und nicht nur mit einer Datei, in der man so ein bisschen rumbrausen kann. Und schon hat man seinen Live-Web-Server, wo alle editieren können mit den entsprechenden Rechten. Aber nee, wollen sie irgendwie nicht.
Ja, ich hab's ihnen auch schon 1000 Mal gesagt.
Vielleicht hören die ja gerade zu und dann...
Das muss sein.
Das muss über das Internet gehen, das muss über das HTTP gehen.
Ja, ich hätte auch gerne einfach so einen Server, wo die Dokumente einfach so drauf sind.
Ich kann mich anmelden, kann ich sagen, übernimm mal. Der kennt das voll gar nicht. Also das ist eine Möglichkeit, dass du sagst, hier, halt das mal weiter fest, ich muss mal weg. Aber mein Kumpel, der gleich weiter editieren will, der kommt gleich, der hat von mir den Link schon bekommen. Oder der Server gibt mir dann den Link, weil...
Genau, das ist ja der Grund, warum man eigentlich dazu tendiert, Google Docs zu benutzen, wobei mich das auch nur so begrenzt lütlich macht. Was hast du da jetzt nochmal?
Isapad heißt das.
Isapad geht jetzt noch ein bisschen auch in diese Live-Edit-Geschichte.
Naja, was da noch in der Richtung ist, wie heißt das, dieses von Mozilla, ich kann mir da den Namen nicht merken. Mozilla hat hier diesen, ich hab's hier noch in einem Tab offen. Das sollte mal ein Copyright werden. Die haben doch diesen Code-Editor für einen, sind sie gerade dabei, in HTML geschrieben, entwickelt. Der heißt B-Spin, da hab ich ihn. Und die haben gerade eben eine neue Version angekündigt.
Warte mal, was ist das? Also Mozilla Projekt und dann B-Spin.
B-Spin, also B-E-S-P-E-N.
B-Spin, was heißt denn das? Und B-Spin.
B-Spin, keine Ahnung, woher es kommt. Und das ist erstmal das einfachen Code-Editor, der in JavaScript ist. Also das ist quasi das Text-Area für Leute, die gerne an ihrem Code arbeiten. Also zum Beispiel, wenn man Jetpack einsetzt. Jetpack ist auch so eine Erweiterung für Firefox. Und in Jetpack kann man, wird das Extension, die Erweiterungsplugin-Entwicklung für Firefox wesentlich vereinfacht, weil es geht halt über eine einfache JavaScript-API und man muss nicht, wenn man ein Plugin testen will, jedes Mal in Firefox neu starten, sondern es geht sofort um eine Änderung und die Änderung ist sofort live. Und dafür bauen die in die Seite B-Spin ein. Das heißt, du...
Das heißt, ein kompletter Editor in JavaScript geschrieben, der dann einfach lokal...
Ein kompletter Editor, der lokal läuft, der kann auf dem Server liegen oder du kannst lokal installieren, wie auch immer du willst. Und im Wesentlichen wird das irgendwann mal darauf hinauslaufen, du lädst dir ein paar JavaScript-Dateien runter, packst die irgendwo rein und dann hast du deinen Editor.
Und ist der jetzt auch gleich kollaborativ oder was?
04 ist jetzt kollaborativ. Ich hab's noch nicht getestet, ich hab jetzt hier wirklich bisher nur einen Tab offen, aber wenn wir schon bei dem Thema dran sind und...
Was mir ja fehlt, ist so die Mischung aus Sub-Ether-Edit und Omni-Outliner.
Na du willst immer noch eine Outline-Funktion mit drin haben, ne?
Ja, ich find einfach Outlines sind für Notizen so essentiell, also zumindest wenn man sich daran einmal gewöhnt hat, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man mit einem normalen Texteditor Ideen notieren kann. Also das ist mir ein Rätsel.
Ich mach's nur so.
Weil du noch nie einen Outliner richtig benutzt hast. Ja, benutzt mal Omni-Outliner und gewöhn dich erst mal da dran, wenn man so dieses einfache Indentieren und Zuordnen und gegebenenfalls sogar auch in Spalten zu arbeiten, als nächste Stufe, wie das bei Omni-Outliner ganz nett geht. Das hat einfach was.
Nee, ich fang damit gar nicht erst an.
Und gerade das eben kollaborativ, dass man da eben einfach die Struktur leicht ändern kann. Weil versuch mal in Google Docs mit dem Text-Editor mal einen größeren Blog von Sachen neu zu indentieren. Das ist ein riesen Act. Da musst du ja irgendwie alles markieren und dann gibt es diese Funktionalität des Indenting nicht und dann vertipselt dich und dann wird das ein großer Mischmasch.
Das mache ich entgegiert oder Text-Made per Einrückung und rück dann eben den gesamten Blog-Wandel.
Ja, aber dann hast du kein Folding und so. Das sind halt einfach diese ganzen Sachen, die einen Outliner mit sich bringen. Ich kann dir das nur empfehlen und ich würde gerne mal so einen kollaborativen Online-Kram machen. So, und hier fragt schon wieder einer, was denn Outlines sind. Schlagt doch mal in der Web-Pikipedia nach. Outliner sind eigentlich wirklich auch so, das ist so Software, die gibt es seit Ewigkeiten, aber keiner weiß immer genau, was es ist. Jeder weiß, was ein Editor ist, jeder weiß, was ein Browser ist, aber ein Outliner. Vielleicht sollte ich mal Frau Cypress fragen. Die weiß das wahrscheinlich.
Das ist, womit ich mir den Strich am Auge so ziehe.
Ah, damit, damit, damit siehst du immer so schön aus.
Sehr spitzfindig, der Herr, sehr spitzfindig. Na gut, jetzt haben wir diesen ganzen online Web 8.0 Collaboration-Teil auch abgearbeitet. Wir könnten jetzt immer noch verhindern, auf das Thema iPhone oder Mac zu kommen.
Ja, und zwar...
Könnten so langsam dahin marschieren, über den Palm.
Ah, über Palm ist natürlich auch jetzt...
Palm ist ja ganz schön dreist eigentlich, oder?
Ja, ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, was die gefressen haben.
Also die Vorgeschichte müssen wir jetzt kurz mal, ich mach mal im Full Speed irgendwie, dass Palm wollte für ihr Gerät ermöglichen, dass man auch mit iTunes da irgendwie Songs draufschreiben kann. Dazu simulieren sie ganz frech eine USB-ID, sage ich jetzt mal ganz grob. Ich weiß gar nicht, weil es gibt ja zwei. Jedenfalls haben sie erst mal nur eine simuliert. Das iTunes hat es benutzt, dann hat Apple schon vorher angekündigt. Naja, wir werden es demnächst ändern. Haben sie dann auch mit der 801 was, oder?
2 glaube ich.
802 haben sie es dann eingestellt, in dem das iTunes jetzt die ID checkt und wenn es kein Apple-Produkt ist, dann machen sie es irgendwie nicht mehr. Und dann hat Palm, weil sowieso gerade ein Update bei denen rauskam, haben die nachgezogen und die simulieren jetzt diese Apple-ID. Also es heißt richtig, wenn man sich die USB-IDs von den Palm Pre anguckt, dann sieht man dort jetzt den Apple-Vendor gesetzt.
Also der behauptet jetzt echt ein iPod zu sein.
Genau.
Oder mehr noch, sie behaupten Apple zu sein.
Ja, nicht nur ein iPod, sondern sie sind sogar ein Apple-iPod inzwischen. So muss man es irgendwie sehen. Genau. Es gibt eine Geräte-ID und eine Vendor-ID und irgendwie so.
Genau. Und jetzt haben sie auch die Apple-Vendor-ID-Firma.
Genau.
Das ist schon ganz schön frech. Und das steht sogar, glaube ich, in den USB-Lizenzbedingungen, dass das einfach mal nicht geht.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht Apple, die sich beschweren, dass Palm irgendwie deren ID benutzt, sondern Palm beschwert sich bei dem USB, wie auch immer die da heißen, dass irgendwie Apple da nach USB-ID sortieren würde, was ja nicht okay wäre. Also eigentlich würde man ja denken, Apple beschwert sich.
Hast du das gelesen, was der Inhalt dieser Beschwerde ist? Ich hab das nicht verstanden, wie die da argumentieren.
Ich auch nicht. Aber es war auf jeden Fall...
Naja, ich glaube, sie argumentieren ein bisschen in der Richtung, dass Apple nicht alle USB-Geräte gleich behandelt. Also das, ähm, ich meine, es wäre...
Sie sollen auch Mäuse sümmen oder was?
Naja, ich meine, ich finde, ehrlich gesagt, also ähm... Also ich find's irgendwie... Ich kann es nachvollziehen. Also ich meine, es hat eine gewisse Rost, das so zu machen, aber...
Was kannst du nachvollziehen?
Was Palm da macht?
Dass Apple auf ihre Wende-ID checkt oder was?
Na guck mal, Apple, die schreiben da irgendwas am Pfeilsystem rum und damit sie nicht bei fremden Geräten, wie zum Beispiel in Palm, was ja ein anderes ist, irgendwie Dateilöschen, die wichtig sein könnten, checken sie vorher ihre ID. Das ist schon eigentlich ganz okay.
Aber ich meine, die machen das jetzt nicht, weil sie Palm-Nutzer und was Gutes tun wollen, sondern...
Das ist schon auch klar, aber...
Sie wollen Palm aussperren und ich finde das einfach doof.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, Moment, man kann jetzt nicht sagen, dass Apple... Ach du meinst jetzt mit dem Update?
Genau. Mit dem Update auf iTunes 802 haben sie explizit Palm ausgesperrt.
Na klar, weil es jetzt ein Gerät gibt, was eben behauptet, ein iPod zu sein, obwohl es keiner ist. So, ich meine, das ist doch nachvollziehbar. Ich meine, die Diskussionen öffnen von iTunes. Können wir gerne hinten heran stellen. Da hab ich auch einen ganz anderen Blick. Aber ich kann jetzt auch mal diesen Schritt nachvollziehen, dass Apple das macht. Ja, aber es ist nicht Apples Verantwortung, für Software für andere Firmen zu sorgen.
Natürlich nicht.
Das halte ich schon für echt frech.
Ja, aber das ist frech.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass man einen Anspruch darauf hätte.
Nö, aber dass Apple sie jetzt aussperrt, deswegen...
Ja, aber ich meine, dann antworten sie mit, ich bin Apple. Das geht nun auch nicht.
Eigentlich geht es nicht.
Na, wenn du jetzt irgendwie Max-Winde-Hardware-Production wärst und du hättest so ein Gerät am Markt, und dann fangen die anderen an, Geräte zu bauen, die einfach auch behaupten, sie wären Max-Winde, dann geht das einfach mal in deine Lizenz rein, wo du irgendwie Kohle für zahlst, wahrscheinlich auch noch ans USB-Forum, um da irgendwie deine ID's zu bekommen.
Ja, aber es ist, ich find's trotzdem okay.
Gut, ich meine, es ist natürlich jetzt ein ganz lustiger Sport, den sie da betreiben. Ich find ihre Argumentation irgendwie nicht nachvollziehbar, zumindest hab ich irgendwie noch nichts gefunden, was man da irgendwie nachvollziehen kann.
Sie probieren es halt, sie probieren jetzt ein bisschen.
Ja, aber es ist doch einfach mal echt unfair ihren Kunden gegenüber. Sie behaupten, dass sie sicherstellen könnten, dass ihr Telefon mit iTunes läuft. Und das können sie nicht.
Behaupten sie das?
Na ja klar.
Oder ist das nicht einfach nur ein Feature?
Sie werben das irgendwie. Sie sagen das. Sie sagen, dass man das mit iTunes sinken kann.
Kann man ja auch.
So, oder? Konnte man, konnte man dann wieder nicht. Jetzt kann man's grad wieder. Und es kann sehr wohl sein, dass Apple demnächst ihren iPods, weißt du, eine neue Firmware gibt durch die Bank und dann fangen sie an mit irgendwie...
Das ist jetzt ein Katz-und-Maus-Spiel. Das ist gar keine Frage. Na klar.
Das werden sie wahrscheinlich verlieren.
Na, da bin ich mal nicht so sicher, weil da könnten auch irgendwann mal höhere Weinen sich mit einschalten. Na, ich meine, wir haben jetzt in einem anderen Bereich das... Dann wären wir jetzt aber wirklich schon beim iPhone. Dieses Google-Voice-Ding.
Das bringt mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen zu weit.
Apple ist in letzter Zeit ein bisschen protektionistisch geworden, wie ich finde.
Das ist aber jetzt eine andere Diskussion.
Nein, ich finde, das ist die selbe Diskussion in einer anderen Richtung.
Nee, finde ich nicht. Ich finde, das vermischt sich wirklich. Das ist so dieses jetzt immer bei dem Apple ist Evil-Bereich. Genau.
Und in den wollen wir Palen Apple weiter reintreiben. Die wollen, dass da entsprechende Behörden darauf aufmerksam werden und dann irgendwann mal ein langes, aber sehr, sehr hammerhartes Hotel werden.
Ja, aber darauf können sie doch keinen Business fanden. Vor allem, das können sie doch ihren Kunden nicht verkaufen. Ich meine, das ist doch unseriös, dass sie ihrem Kunden gegenüber behaupten, sie könnten iTunes verwenden mit diesem Telefon, obwohl sie nicht ob sie es sicherstellen.
Ich glaube, das bewerben sie auch nicht so extrem. Das ist halt ein Feature, was im Augenblick geht.
Sie sagen es.
Die zecken halt beide so ein bisschen.
Ich kann hier gerade keine URL sagen, aber sie sagen, dass das geht. Leute kaufen unter Umständen dieses Telefon wegen dieses Versprechens. Das heißt, sie liefern ein Versprechen, was Apple halten soll. Und das können sie nicht. Also Apple muss ja allein schon deshalb reagieren, damit Leute nicht anfangen, ihnen E-Mails zu schreiben, weil ihr blödes iTunes ein Problem mit dem Palm-Pri hat. Was ist, wenn der Pri jetzt ein Problem hat? Dass er nämlich das, was da hineingesyncht wurde, das iTunes...
Plötzlich nicht mehr geht.
Genau, nicht mehr geht. Dann rufen die Leute bei Apple an und beschweren sich. Und selbst wenn die dann in Support sagen...
Warum geht mein gekaufter Song nicht?
Genau, ich hab ja irgendwie meinen Palm-Pri angeschlossen und mein iTunes funktioniert nicht.
Weil das DRM nicht kann.
Aber es gibt doch kein DRM mehr.
Ja, gut, lass mal das DRM hin, DRM her. Gehen wir mal davon aus, es gibt irgendeinen Bug. Ich meine, der Rubinstein, der hat sicherlich eine Menge Ahnung, was so ein iPod so tun sollte. Ganz klar, ich meine, er hat die mal gebaut. Deswegen hat er auch eine Menge Insiderwissen. Das halte ich auch für relativ schwierig. Und von daher muss Apple da eigentlich reagieren.
Ich verstehe, dass Apple pisst es. Ich verstehe auch, dass Palm das macht.
Na, es fällt ja dann unter Umständen etwas auf sie zurück, was sie nicht zu verantworten haben. Da kommt ein Gerät an und sagt, ich bin ein Apple-Gerät. Apple kann noch nicht dafür garantieren, dass der Palm richtig funktioniert. Aber es ist ja ein Teil von Apples Politik, zu sagen, wir garantieren eine hohe Qualität unserer Chain, eben weil wir alles unter Kontrolle haben.
Das könntest du ja genauso gut für alles andere argumentieren. Du könntest auch damit verbieten, dass überhaupt Dritthersteller-Applikationen auf dem Mac laufen. Damit könntest du sagen, dass man nicht beliebige Seiten aufrufen kann, etc., Nein, das ist ganz anders. Apple sagt zu keiner Sekunde, Palm-Geräte funktionieren mit. Im Gegenteil, sie sagen nach außen hin explizit, Palm-Geräte funktionieren mit iTunes nicht. Das ist ja die offizielle Ansage von Apple.
Apple sagt eigentlich, iTunes funktioniert auf dem Rechner und für ein iPod.
Das reicht ja.
Wieso? Aber es fällt auf sie zurück? Nö, das fällt auf Palm zurück.
Das ist aber in der Wahrnehmung der Konsumenten eine andere Geschichte. Die Leute verstehen das nicht so. Die haben ja den Palm gekauft, und da steht ja drauf, geht mit iTunes.
Ich glaube, das steht nicht drauf. Ich sehe es nirgendswo auf der Seite. Ich habe es auch nirgendswo auf der Seite jemals gesehen, dass es mit iTunes synchronisiert.
Wir sind hier schon wieder in einer Einbahnstraße, Jungs. Wir müssen mal wieder zurück.
Aber wir können jetzt gerne die nächste Diskussion machen, wo ich auch gerne bereit bin, eine andere Position einzunehmen. Nämlich die generelle Frage, wie ist denn das nun eigentlich mit iTunes und der ganzen Musikarchitektur und dem Digital Hub und einer offenen Geschichte? Ich habe andere Probleme als jetzt den Palm Prix oder alternative Player. Fans zwar auch nicht so schlecht, wenn es da ein Standard gäbe, aber ich kann auch verstehen, warum Apple an der Stelle jetzt kein Interesse daran hat, ein Hardware-Standard zu etablieren, weil sie wollen ihre Geräte am laufenden Meter weiterentwickeln. Und wir sehen ja auch, die Transition iPod zu iPhone hat ja auch eine technische Basis komplett anders geändert. Also auch schon aufs iPhone sinken sie ja anders. Und soweit ich weiß, ist bisher noch keiner in der Lage, also bisher ist noch keiner in der Lage, zu einem iPhone hin zu sinken, oder? Gibt es da irgendetwas? Ist das irgendjemand schon mal gelungen?
Was meinst du mit einem iPhone hin zu sinken?
Na du kannst zum Beispiel dein iPod ja auch mit Open Source Amarok sinken zum Beispiel. Achso, ja, es gibt Möglichkeiten. Das ist alles reingeniert, aber soweit ich weiß, ist es noch niemandem gelungen, ein iPhone zu bespielen.
Doch, doch, ich hab schon mal eine Musiksammlung von einem iPhone wieder runtergeholt.
Das meine ich nicht. Ich meine nicht so ein Recover-Teil, sondern dass jemand wirklich auf ein iPhone sinkt, so wie ein iTunes darauf sinkt. Also hast du schon mal irgendeine Software gesehen, die sagt, ich kann ein iPhone genauso bespielen, wie es ein iTunes bespielen kann?
Also ich kenne...
Zumindest die Musik.
Also ich kenne zumindest jemand, der sein iPhone mit Linux befüllt. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie das jetzt geht, aber ich weiß...
Ein iPhone oder sein iPod?
Kann sein, dass man dafür einen Jailbreak braucht und dann einfach das Teilsystem unterschiebt. Ich weiß es schlicht und ergreifend nicht, aber ich kenne auf jeden Fall jemand, der das kann.
Der Chat ist wieder ganz fleißig irgendwie. Also Palm bewirbt das, dass sie mit iTunes singen. Da steht da ganz dick und fett auf ihrer Webseite drauf. Palm.com/us/product slash phone slash pre. Mit Fußnote 6. Compatible with iTunes 8.2. Compatibility with future versions not guaranteed.
Ja, sonst gibt's halt Ärger.
Ja, aber das ist halt irgendwie ungeil. Das ist echt unseriös. Oh ja, und übrigens es sync mit einer uralten Version von iTunes. Großes Kino, die du nirgends wo runterladen kannst.
Was heißt uralt Version?
Versuch mal iTunes 8.2 jetzt im Internet herunterzuladen.
8.0, 8.2 gibt's doch gar nicht. Ist nicht die aktuelle Version 8.0.2?
Die aktuelle Version von iTunes ist 8.2, wo sind wir jetzt? 1.
8.2.1, okay. Also mit der Version von vor zwei Wochen.
Aber du kannst die nicht runterladen. Es gibt nicht 8.2 zum Download. Wenn du jetzt einen, ja, ist so. Aber legal kriegst du es nicht.
Machen wir uns nichts vor. Also Apple sieht, sie sieht, dass es nicht so gut ist, dass es nicht so gut ist, und es hat keine technischen Gründe, warum sie Palm ausgesperrt haben. Es hat reine Marketing.
Natürlich hat es keine technischen Gründe.
Es hat reine Marketinggründe.
Na ja, und auch, die haben ja natürlich auch irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Rechtsabteilung würde ich gar nicht mehr sagen, aber das ist schon so ein Ding, dass die sich auch ihr Image nicht versauen. Weil wirklich die Leute, wenn die ihr Palm mit ihrem iTunes benutzen, dann geht irgendwas nicht, fällt es auf Apple zurück. Also sagen sie, alles klar, fangen wir gar nicht erst mit an.
Mit der Argumentation könnte man Dritthersteller Mäuse, Kameras, Dritthersteller, Drucker, alles was von Dritthersteller kommt.
Nein, da gibt es einen Standard. Das ist wie eine Maus an deinem Computer, sich anmeldet und wie sie bedient wird, ist standardisiert. Und danach verhalten die sich. Und du kannst auch einen Treiber installieren auf deinem Computer. Palm darf auch einen Treiber für seinen Palm Prix auf dem Macintosh veröffentlichen. Das ist nicht verboten. Und sie könnten auch eine Software schreiben, die die iTunes-Bibliothek nimmt und ausliest. Da gibt es einen XML-File, da steht alles drin. Und sie könnten das auf ihr Telefon sinken. Also es ist nicht so, dass Palm nicht der Weg offenstehen würde, Musik aus iTunes da drauf zu sinken. Zu sagen, dass es aber mit iTunes selbst geht, ist eine wackelige Behauptung. Also das finde ich ziemlich unseriös. Ich meine, man kann das jetzt erstmal so als Stunt sehen und vielleicht wollen sie sich auch nur ein bisschen aufplustern, damit sie da, was weiß ich, was sie sich davon versprechen.
Ich höre von denen auch Marketing, weil sie bleiben im Gespräch.
Sonst würden wir jetzt nicht so schnell drüber quatschen. Ich finde das unklug. Also ich finde das keinen seriösen Weg. Sie sollten sich schon darüber Gedanken machen, wie man das anders macht, weil es würde gehen.
Ich meine, du kannst ja auch noch deine Musik einfach per Drag-and-Drop drauf kopieren.
Die können auch Fotos sinken zum Beispiel. Das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Also auf iPhoto und die ganzen Fotos zuzugreifen, da gibt es eine Media-Library und so weiter. Also es ist alles nicht so das Ding. Und auch die iTunes-Musik ginge. So, aber klar, jetzt andere Thematik. Was wir eigentlich alle beklagen, ist, dass das eigentlich so ein geschlossenes System ist. Richtig? So. Und ich zumindest wäre sehr froh, wenn sich das eben anders entwickeln würde, dass man nämlich sagt, es gibt ein Media Sync Framework irgendwie. Also wo sozusagen auch die Musik mit dabei ist. Wenn jetzt Hersteller XY, die Musik, die auf diesem Computer liegt, also so in dem gleichen...
Das kann ja nicht mal Apple selbst. Du kriegst da keine Musik per iTunes wieder runter vom iPod oder iPhone.
Weil es nicht gehen soll.
Wollen ja gar nicht. Das heißt, ich kann jetzt nicht mein iPhone bei dir ranstecken und du kannst meine Musik runter kopieren. Das geht nicht. Das ging auch noch nicht.
Genau. Das ist schon mal ein generelles Problem.
Das ist meine Musik.
Von der Convenience.
Von meinem CDs-Gerät. Das sind noch nicht mal bei Pirate Bay besorgte Musik. Na doch, ein bisschen. Aber das geht halt nicht. Das nervt schon manchmal. Ich muss immer alles doppelt da haben. Und da hat man ja den physikalischen Kontakt. Es ist ja nicht so, dass ich was übers Internet schere. Sondern jemanden, den ich meinem iPhone gebe, den hab ich wirklich so wie es früher war. Wie sagt man? Fair Trade? Das Tauschen, was man unter Bekannten machen darf. Fair Use? Ja, dieses Fair Use. In Amerika ist es so, bei uns heißt es keine Ahnung, wie es heißt.
Gibt es das nicht? Na ja, das ist Privatkopie.
Privatkopie, genau. Das muss ja gehen, weil es ist ein physikalischer Access. Das ist ja eindeutig dann jemand, den ich kenne, sonst würde ich mir mein Phone nicht in die Hand drücken. Gut, haben wir das Thema durch?
Ja gut, was ich meinte, ist ja was anderes. Wir müssen aufpassen, dass wir es nicht durcheinander bringen. Man kann natürlich schon auf die Musik zugreifen. Es gibt ja auch dieses Framework, mit dem man jetzt, was weiß ich, zwischen den Applikationen, wo auch so ein Garage Band auf die iTunes Sachen zugreift, dieser Standardzugriff, den du so iApp-Applikationsübergreifend hast. Dieses Media-Fenster, wo du eben auf Fotos, Filme und Musik zugreifen kannst.
Ach so, das läuft ja nur auf dem Rechner selbst halt so.
Jaja klar, aber du kannst halt auch, also es ist durchaus möglich, dass du eine Software schreibst, die auf dem Mac läuft und die eben auf Fotofilme und Musik zugreift. Da gibt es eine API und darüber kann man irgendwie zugreifen. Also das existiert. Das ist nicht das Problem. Das Problem ist, dass man nicht dem iTunes sagen kann, heute singst du mal auf ein anderes Gerät. Was man aber auch nicht machen kann ist, man kann auch dem iTunes nicht Podcasts, also ich will es jetzt mal konkret an Podcast-Fests machen, weil bei Musik ist es mir ein bisschen egal, aber ich finde halt das Podcast-Management von iTunes, finde ich halt irgendwie bekloppt. So, also es ist immer noch, dummerweise immer noch das Beste, was es so gibt, wenn man jetzt vielleicht mal von Miro absieht, das ist so in etwa auf dem gleichen Level, aber ich würde halt auch gerne Podcasts mir von einem anderen Programm holen lassen können und auch auf meinem iPhone machen und sagen, iTunes, du machst jetzt den Podcast-Teil nicht mehr, sondern den Podcast-Teil, den macht halt eine andere Applikation, irgendwie iPodcast oder iTunes Pro oder NetNews Wire und Stereoiden, was für Podcasts optimiert ist.
Oder ein BitTorrent Client, um mal jetzt mal ein schöner...
Ja, was auch immer, also irgendwie ein Stück Software, wie sich diese Podcasts jetzt holt, das ist ja eine andere Frage. Mir geht es ja einfach nur um die Flexibilität zu bestimmen, was landet auf meinem Gerät, was landet nicht auf meinem Gerät. Und das ist mir halt ein bisschen zu unflexibel. Ich hätte da gerne so eine Pro-Applikation, die ich ein bisschen mehr auch den Platz, den ich auf dem Gerät habe, effektiv nutzen kann. Das ist mir derzeit einfach zu wackelig. Das gibt es halt einfach nicht. Und das finde ich extrem scheiße. Und vor allem finde ich auch iTunes immer noch scheiße. Gab es nicht irgendwie iTunes 9 Gerüchteküche?
Ja, es gibt eine iTunes 9.
Das war aber wieder alles Fake, Scheiße oder was?
Das war Foto, Fake oder so. Da war ein Last FM Icon oben in der obersten Leiste links. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man die genau nennt. Und dann war noch ein Smartlist-Folder, der Social hieß. Den natürlich jeder machen kann, der irgendwie Smartlist. Also da war nichts weiter an Info.
Also es gibt Gerüchte, was war iTunes 9? Dass man iPhone-Applikationen mit neu sortieren kann. Dass man sozusagen sein iPhone sieht und auf den Bildschirm schieben kann. Ist jetzt nicht das erste Mal das Gerücht aufgekommen. Halt ich für, weiß ich nicht, glaube ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig dran.
Ich fände es aber gut, wenn man mal ein bisschen seine Applikationsseiten sortieren könnte.
Ich würde es gut finden, wenn man es auf dem iPhone besser machen könnte. Warum soll ich mein iPhone an iTunes erschließen?
Ich will Ordner haben.
Also dieser ganze Mechanismus sollte mal grundlich überarbeitet werden.
Ich würde gerne, dass es das so sortiert, dass es mir immer die am meist benutzten Applikationen nach vorne stellt. Umso häufiger ich ein Programm starte, umso weiter rutscht es nach vorne.
Ich würde sagen, wir können es... Na ja, das würde ich... Dann wär's jedes Mal komplett woanders.
Irgendwann nicht mehr.
Irgendwann nicht mehr, aber zu lange.
Ja, aber du würdest es einfach immer schnell finden, weil umso häufiger du es benutzt, umso näher ist es dran.
Ich möchte es manuell sortieren können, aber bequemer als ich es im Augenblick tue.
Das Gleiche hätte ich gerne für Telefonnummern.
Dass er automatisch merkt mit...
Dass meine Favorites, die sind die mich...
Die einfach häufig benutzt werden.
Die ich häufig angerufen hab.
Dass man sie nicht exklusiv Favorites ist, sondern dass sie sich automatisch fällig ist.
Dass es sich dynamisch regelt.
Genau.
Und von alleine füllt am Anfang natürlich auch. Ich ruf da drei Leute an, dann sind die gleich da drin. Dann ruf ich andere Leute fünfmal öfter an, dann kommen die da rein.
Leute, die diese Telefonnummer angerufen haben, haben auch jetzt folgende Leute.
Aber das wär auch total albern. Dann müsste ich jedes Mal die gesamte Liste durchgehen, um zu gucken, wo dieser Eintrag jetzt ist.
Du weißt doch ungefähr nach einer Weile, auch welcher da ist und welcher nicht.
Ja, aber wenn ich einfach... Ich stelle mir meine Favorites, die stelle ich mir so einmal ein. Und wenn ich eine Änderung will, dann ist das eine Änderung, weil ich die haben will.
So ist es jetzt.
Bloß weil ich jetzt... Genau, so ist es jetzt. Wenn ich in Zukunft dann, wenn das passieren würde, wenn ich zum Beispiel einfach eine Person, die ich normalerweise nie anrufe, fünfmal nicht erreiche, darum fünfmal an einem Tag anrufen und plötzlich ist aus irgendeinem Grund in meinen Favorites drinne...
Muss ja nicht der Anrufversuch, sondern die für funktionierenden Telefonate.
Ne, das muss...
Umso länger du mit den Leuten telefonierst.
Ne, das auch nicht.
Das ist so was...
Du bist immer in der Hotline.
Ja, aber Favorite-Liste, ich hab mal eine gemacht und jetzt hab ich genau eine Telefonnummer noch in dieser Liste, die ich wirklich häufig anrufe, weil ich das einfach permanent ändere.
Dann ändere deine Favorite-Liste bei Gelegenheit.
Meistens weiß man vom Gefühl gar nicht, wo man eigentlich am meisten anruft.
Aber sag mal so, du hast eine Favorite-Liste, die darauf basiert, dass du... Was du als Last Calls angerufen hast, und das sind die Last Calls. Dementsprechend scheiße ist das auch.
Die Last Calls kann auch einer, den du sonst ganz schön oft angerufen hast, ganz schön schnell nach unten rutschen, weil du jetzt noch mal andere Leute angerufen hast.
Ja, aber wir nutzen nicht die Last Calls, oder?
Du bist heute wieder in einer Opposition.
Doch, ich nutze die Last Calls, aber das sagt ja nichts darüber aus, wie häufig ich jemanden anrufe. Na ja, da erscheinen ja auch vor allem Leute, die mich anrufen.
Also ich hätte das gerne, weil ich hab das gesehen, hier bei Recent Items auf dem OS X, da läuft es ja irgendwie prima. Da sind immer die, die ich ja irgendwie häufig benutze und meistens, wenn ich ein Programm starten will, ist es auch irgendwie mit da drin. Manchmal nicht, am meisten schnell über Spotlight.
Ja, aber ich will das wissen. Ich möchte, dass das ins Muskelfleisch übergehen kann.
Niemand soll gezwungen werden. Also auf dem Rechner gibt's ja auch Spotlight, dann gibt's ja Recent Items und dann gibt's halt den Finder. Also sollen ja mehrere Wege nach Rom führen.
Na ja, gibt's sicherlich noch ein paar wichtigere Themen als diese Favorites, oder?
Ja.
War auch nur so eine Idee von mir, ich hätte es gerne.
Ja, aber ok, das war das eine. Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, diesmal war ich definitiv nicht dran schuld, dass wir komplett vom Thema abgekommen sind, wir waren nämlich gerade bei iTunes. Dann ein Thema, was da noch war, war Blue-Ray-Support, dass der möglicherweise kommt. Won't happen. Ich bin mal sehr gespannt, also irgendwann wird Apple wahrscheinlich auch Blue-Ray-Geräte einbauen, aber Won't happen.
Ich würd's gar nicht schlimm finden, wenn sie gar keine sich drehenden Geräte mehr einbauen. Also bei den Festplatten, da tut sich's ja gerade eher erledigen von alleine demnächst. Dauert ein bisschen, aber wird so kommen. Und ich denk mal, CD-ROM fliegt als nächstes raus. Also ich brauch meinen CD-ROM nie, wirklich nie.
Ich brauch meinen CD-ROM tatsächlich auch nie.
Und ich würd da prima mit klarkommen, vor 50 Dollar oder 100 oder was das Ding kostet, mir so ein USB-External... Nee, das will ich auch nicht, ich find meinen 15 Zoll teuer. Aber ich meine, wenn das Laufwerk draußen wär, dann können sie die Batterie gleich von 7 Stunden auf 10 Stunden hochschrauben.
Übrigens, kurzer Hinweis vom AllesWissen-Chat. Es gibt tatsächlich ein Programm, das heißt Media Monkey, das verspricht, dass es mit einem iPhone 3G sünden kann. Das ist allerdings wieder so eine obskure Webseite, die so ein bisschen mich so an real erinnert. Ja, es gibt die Freie, aber es gibt auch Gold. Full version now free.
Kann man sich da mal angucken. Und was war das dritte Feature? Achso, das dritte Feature war, dass sie irgendwie eine Social-Komponente reinbauen wollen. Und, also dass das so irgendwie mit Facebook und mit diesen ganzen Social-Zeug in irgendeiner Form zusammenarbeiten kann. Und daraufhin sind dann diese Last FM-Screenshots aufgetaucht.
Niemals.
Ich meine, iPhoto kann ja mittlerweile mit Facebook. Warum sollte nicht auch iTunes in irgendeiner Form mit Facebook können?
Also, ok, warte mal. Also Facebook und Last FM hast du gesagt. Da hab ich angefangen mit dem Kopf zu schütteln.
Last FM ist das, was im Screenshot aufgetaucht hat. Ich würde sagen, das ist auch definitiv ein Fake. Aber dass iTunes irgendwie mit Social Media Applikation zusammenarbeitet...
Welche Anwendung siehst du da jetzt gerade?
Welche Musik haben meine Freunde gehört? Lass dir von Freunden Playliste zusammenstellen. Was hört meine beste Freundin gerade? Mein bester Kumpel, mein bester irgendwas.
Ach so, dass sie das sozusagen nutzen, um Hinweise, also schon, dann ihre iTunes-Store backen zu zeigen.
Dass man gemeinsam sehen guckt. Das würde ich mir zum Beispiel geil finden.
Das Ding wird ja noch größer und noch schwerer und noch langsamer.
Ja, iTunes wird ein eigenes Betriebssystem.
Ich hoffe ja eigentlich eher auf iTunes X. Außerdem hoffe ich, dass es nicht so heißen wird, aber du weißt, was ich meine. Eigentlich möchte ich die iTunes-Applikation vom iPhone, wo alles irgendwie schnell und einfach ist.
Wir müssen das mal irgendwie aufsplitten in 4-5 Programmen. Das ist ja irgendwie too much.
iTunes Pro, einfach so eine schlanke Coco, Mac OS X only.
64-Bit.
64-Bit, irgendwie legst du die Ohren an. Genau, volles Programm mit irgendwie, ja, hier so mit Encoding gleich irgendwie eingebaut. Also mit ihrem, wie heißt das Teil noch gleich, hier von Final Cut Studio? Kompressor, genau. Sozusagen so.
Jetzt willst du doch schon wieder mehr Sachen reinschubsen.
Ich hab so eine Ahnung, was da passieren wird.
Sachen schon benutzen, die sie sowieso haben. Also damit integriert sein sozusagen. Gut, das geht jetzt ein bisschen zu weit, aber du weißt, was ich meine. Einfach mal ein geiler Player, der nicht ruckelt. Und iTunes schafft es halt auch im Jahre 2009 nicht zu ruckeln.
Ja, aber mit iTunes ist ja sowieso mal ein Spaß für sich. Das ist ja ganz lustig, dass Apple dieses iTunes nach wie vor aufbläst und aufbläst. Und obwohl es eine Carbon-Application ist. Obwohl, den Finder haben sie auch relativ schnell dann im Endeffekt den Rewrite hingekriegt, oder? Warum soll das denn nicht...
Schnell?
Nachdem sie sich mal vorgenommen haben.
Das hat nur 9 Jahre gedauert.
Naja, aber ich nehme an, dass sie mit Leopard angefangen haben. Also nachdem Leopard fertig war mit dem Coco-Finder.
Tja, keine Ahnung, wann sie damit angefangen haben. Mich interessiert auch nicht, was sie damit angefangen haben. Mich interessiert, wann sie damit endlich aufhören. Angeblich ist ja jetzt Golden Master-Time für Schnee-Leo.
Und am 28.
Nein, aber man kann mal davon ausgehen, weil erstens ist halt Zeit halt einfach, ist so Mitte August.
Wann wollten sie das rausbringen? Einfach nur September.
Und dann, bisher war es ja so, dass seit der WWDC, die ja am 9.6. war, also das ist auch schon wieder über zwei Monate her, dass seit dem WWDC-Bild gab es, also es war die 10A380, seitdem gab es keine Updates mehr. Also keine bei Apple runterzuladen, sondern nur noch als Software-Update über den Software-Updater. Und jetzt plötzlich kommt wieder ein neues Image raus.
Das war sozusagen die Vermutung, dass es dann...
Ja, würde ich mal, das passt alles gut zusammen. Und das ist einfach jetzt auch mal Zeit. So, alle wollen einen Clean-Install machen.
Und jetzt ist auch schon ein Keynote... Es gibt auch schon eine Keynote.
Nein.
Might be planning a Q&A. Ja, ist das das dann sozusagen? Ist das dann so eine Schneelegung?
Also erstmal kursiert ja irgendwie dieses Tablett jetzt doch noch mal... Ja, ist Might be. Ich meine, was heißt denn das?
Requisite Murmuring, das ist ja eine geile Bezeichnung für ein totales Gerücht.
Also irgendwie ist mir das... Also diese Videos, die in letzter Zeit aufgetaucht sind von diesen Tablets, habt ihr die gesehen? Das ist quasi so... Sieht so ein bisschen aus, wie iPhone, OS einfach auf einem größeren Display ausgeführt und alles, was ihnen eingefallen ist... Also die Fenster haben alle die gleiche Größe wie auf dem iPhone und können auch nicht größer oder kleiner gemacht werden, aber du kannst dafür durch die Gegend schieben und kannst mehrere öffnen. Sieht für mich irgendwie nach was aus, was nicht passieren wird. Und dann sind auch so...
Haben wir uns nicht letztes Mal schon irgendwie dumm und delich geredet über dieses Tablett?
Also ich bin... Und das glaube ich erst, wenn ich in der Hand habe. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, warum das jetzt plötzlich so hochkommt.
Also, 7. September. Es gibt das Gerücht, dass da ein Termin sei. Das könnte natürlich Schnee-Löö sein. Andererseits haben sie davon jetzt schon so viel darüber geredet. Warum machen sie da noch mal eine Keynote? Oder ist nicht irgendwie iMac-Update-Zeit langsam?
Aber gleich wieder eine neue Keynote dafür? Da muss schon was bisschen Dickeres kommen, oder?
Ach komm, die machen auch für ein neues MacBook mal eine neue Keynote.
Ja, aber nur ein komplett neues... Na ja, vielleicht ist es ja ein komplett neuer iMac. War nicht das Gerücht, dass sie jetzt schon auf...
Wer weiß, die sind jetzt schon ganz schön lange. So von dem Formfaktor, also dieser Schirm, der so aussieht wie ein Cinema-Display, wo der Rechner drin steht.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie das groß ändern werden.
Aber ist nicht September iPod-Zeit?
Wir sind ganz schön raus, wa?
Also, iPod Touch wird ein neuer fällig. Ich meine jetzt, das iPhone ist lang genug da, das 3GS, da muss langsam mal der neue iPod Touch rauskommen. Und iPod Nano, der vierte, der fünfte oder wievielte Generation ist da die aktuelle oder sechste?
Na ja, lass uns damit einfach droher reden, wenn es soweit ist.
Genau.
Das ist dumm spekulieren.
Ja, das ist...
Möglicherweise wird es also im September...
Okay, wo waren wir? Wir waren beim Palm, wir waren bei iTunes, wir waren bei iTunes 9, was wir eigentlich gerne hätten. Und dann haben wir so ein bisschen Schneeleo jetzt gemutmaßt, aber nichts genaues weiß man nicht. Ich hoffe, dass es bald kommt, damit ich endlich mir diese Services ausschalten kann. Da warte ich ja schon die ganze Zeit drauf. Das ist mein Killer-Feature. Deswegen werde ich mir das kaufen, glaube ich.
Das Snow Lappert.
Ja, ich würde mir einfach so ein volles Upgrade kaufen, nur dafür, dass ich mir die Services...
Leute, die keinen Leopard haben, müssen trotzdem den vollen Preis sein.
Das Upgrade kostet 29 Dollar. Die volle Version kostet... Das heißt, wenn ich keinen Leopard habe, zum Beispiel, dann müsstest du 129 Dollar oder 129 Euro zahlen. Wenn du aber schon... Ja, wahrscheinlich der Fall ist, eine ordnungsgemäß legale Leo-Kopie rumliegt, dann...
Klar, steht es auch so im Schrank.
Na sicher.
Aber wenn man, sagen wir mal, nur einen Rechner hat, wo das Leopard mit dabei war, zählt das auch? Oder muss man es extra gekauft haben?
Das ist eine gute Frage, die ich gar nicht beantworten kann, aber ich vermute mal, dass ich es nicht weiß.
Ich denke mal, Apple kommt da die Tricks noch ein bisschen rum, dass es wirklich nur geht, wenn man sich so einen Leopard gekauft hat.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die an der Stelle, die wollen Snow Leopard möglichst weit verbreiten, darum werden die da nicht rumtricksen. Man kann es doch schon pre-ordern, oder? Können wir noch mal nachgucken.
Bei den Charts höher als Windows 7. Das Windows 7 gibt es jetzt auch schon zu kaufen, oder?
Auch per Pre-Order.
Es kommt jetzt auch so die Tage.
Wobei, da muss man Microsoft echt mal lassen, sie haben ja da echt eine transparente. Man konnte sich ja die Beta-Version schon runterladen, die dann zwar zeitlich begrenzt, aber liefen, mit der man schon... Also ich hab mit zumindest einem VM-WR Windows 7 schon mal angeguckt. Und man kann sich jetzt auch quasi die finale Version schon runterladen, wenn man sich einmal eingetragen hat bei Microsoft als Entwickler. Könnte sich Apple ruhig mal eine Scheibe von abschneiden? Sag ich ja über.
Was sag ich mit beta-Version? Ich will, was funktioniert.
Also von Snow Leopard hätte ich mir bestimmt schon mal eine Version runtergeladen, wenn...
Und jetzt? Mac oder iPhone? Mac oder iPhone?
Weil Snow Leopard muss ich nochmal kurz ablösten. Snow Leopard ist nämlich auch evil. Snow Leopard ist voll toll, ich bin schon ganz heiß. Aber dieses QuickTime X, ja? Also es ist ja... Unten drunter bestimmt alles schön und schick, aber was ja nicht mehr da ist, ist ja der QuickTime Player, der Alte, sondern ist ja jetzt so neuer da, der ja auch wenn er Movies abspielt, irgendwie gar keinen Rahmen und nichts mehr hat, also wirklich den ganzen Fensterplatz nur noch zum Movie gucken verbraucht, was ja ganz schick ist. Aber wenn man so wie du, Tim, du machst ja bestimmt auch mal hier für deine Podcasts und so weiter, guckst du dir die Audio oder die Videospuren von irgendwelchen Filmen im QuickTime an. Mit Apfeljord kennst du ja bestimmt, oder?
Apfeljord ist mein Freund.
Genau, gibt's alles nicht mehr. Siehste, da geht's nämlich los. Es gibt einfach Apfeljord, geht nicht mehr. Ihr habt ja alle einen Leopard noch, ihr habt ja gar keinen Snow Leopard da draußen, ihr könnt ja mal ein Movie nehmen und Apfeljord drücken, da kann man richtig die einzelnen Videospuren sehen, die Tonspuren oder welche Extraspuren. Wenn man ein Tonkey eingegeben hat, gekauft hat. Das sind die neuesten Gerüchte bei diesem 1060 jetzt, also bei diesem Golden Master-Bild, dass, wenn man den Quicktime-Key hat, dass dann automatisch das alte Quicktime von Snow Leopard noch mitinstalliert wird, damit man den Player weiter benutzen kann.
Die haben einfach noch nicht alle Features drin.
Der Player kann... Das ist halt wirklich nur ein Player.
Spur anzeigen?
Ja, wofür brauchst du nur das Spur anzeigen?
Sonst weiß ich nicht, was in diesem Film ist. Ich meine, wie willst du denn rauskriegen, wie die Bitrate und welcher Encoder ist?
Und du kannst ja noch Titel setzen und so. Wie Tagging sozusagen, kannst du ja noch sagen von wo...
Kannst du die Spur drehen, kannst du das Video drehen, wenn es irgendwie ein quer aufgenommener Film ist, kannst du den Hochkant machen, la la la, da gibt es alle...
Ich kann das Aspektratio ändern, wenn du willst. Und speichern.
Das ist jeden Tag in Benutzung bei mir.
Also wenn man ein bisschen mehr mit Videos macht und so weiter, auch mit Streaming und so weiter und so fort, dann sind das schon Features...
Auch für Audio ist das wichtig, also kannst du halt einfach mal genau anzeigen lassen. Weißt du überhaupt, wovon wir reden? Dieses Properties-Inspektor-Teil hier.
Ich hab das schon mal gesehen, ich guck mir, dass alle vier QuickTime-Versionen dann mal an, sage, aha, da gibt's auch noch...
Naja, da steht halt irgendwie drin, was so richtig die Size ist. Dann kannst du halt irgendwie das Video rotieren.
Hab ich noch nie gebraucht tatsächlich. Also schön, dass das geht, super.
Interlace-Settings, tra la la, die einzigen Subtitles und Chapters anmachen und ausmachen. Du kannst auch Spuren auslöschen oder einfach disablen und so, wenn du mehrere Sachen drin hast. Du siehst ja auch die Pfade, wohin irgendwie das Ganze zeigt. Und bei Sound entsprechend kannst du halt hier auch irgendwie Volumen einstellen und so. Also es ist schon sehr praktisch, wenn man häufiger mal mit Sachen arbeitet.
Bei Buff könnte ich das gebrauchen, weil da muss ich regelmäßig Spuren auslöschen.
Du kannst auch Spuren extrahieren.
In der eigenen Datei speichern? Okay, das brauch ich tatsächlich ja nur wieder.
Muss ich nicht mal, das geht.
Will ich ab sofort mal probieren beim nächsten Mal.
Genau, aber ich hab auch so den Eindruck, dieses QuickTimeX will im Player eher so ein bisschen mehr Player sein und nicht so sehr Authoring Tool und das ist die Frage, was dann da kommt.
Na ja, sie bieten ja auf der anderen Seite auch Features an, die ihr aktuell nicht bietet, die durchaus in die Richtung gehen. Also es gibt ja dieses Sharing Feature, dass du schneiden kannst relativ einfach Videos wie in iMovie.
Trimming so wie auf dem iPhone.
Oder wie auf dem iPhone, genau.
Also das es nicht mehr so gut ist wie jetzt, sondern das ist so ein dummier... Was? Ich schneide alles damit.
Also ich kann da aber nicht so richtig super klar.
Du kannst Frame für Frame steppen und kannst deine In- und deine Outpoint setzen und dann machst du Copy und Paste und dann hast du deinen Scheiß.
Ich hab's mir nicht so genau angeguckt, ich hab nur gesehen, es gibt so einen relativ einfachen, es kann ja auch sein, dass das in sich dann noch wieder genauso komplex ist und alle Shortcuts weiterhin gehen und weißt du was?
Ich seh hier nicht.
Dann wird Tim böse sein. Jetzt wirklich?
Scheißladen.
Sehr schön. Wir machen hier den Leopard-Mobile.
Ja, ich meine das ist das, was ich seit 1900... Wann? 14.
Robba erzählt vom Krieg.
Ja, seit 1993 geht das einfach. Auf meinem McIntosh. Ich seh nicht ein, warum jetzt nach 13 Jahren der Liebe da auf einmal Sexverbot herrschen soll. Das ist ja wie, dass man da so ein Konton übergestrahlt bekommt.
Weil dich die junge Braut nicht mehr ran lässt. Aber ich mein, du kannst ja auch erstmal probieren.
Genau, weil so eine eingeschnappte, verzogene Tussi.
Zum einen kann ich mir vorstellen, dass dein alter Quicktime-Player, ich glaube der funktioniert schlicht und ergreifend weiter.
Naja, den hast du ja dann auch erstmal nicht. Dann kannst du den nirgends wo runterladen. Und irgendwann hast du dann deine letzte Kopie davon auch noch vergeigt und es gibt immer noch keine Lösung. Naja, okay. Schimpfen wir nicht über etwas, was wir noch nicht gesehen haben. Keiner weiß, ob dann nicht schnell noch irgendwie ein alternativer Download ist und was da kommt.
Alles klar, du musst jetzt hier iMovie benutzen und da kannst du das machen.
Oder es gibt ein Quicktime X Editor Programm, was sie noch irgendwie anbieten.
Also ich hab mir diesen Quicktime X Player angeguckt. Also ich hab mir Quicktime X angeguckt. Ich fand das sehr schick.
Premium, Final Cut Studio, Premium Starter Kit 7. Da ist auch die 7 drin. Quicktime 7, Windows 7 ist doch alles das gleiche. Scheiße.
Dreck.
Ich wechsle.
Jetzt doch, Windows 7.
Ok, weil wir gerade schon mal beim Movie gucken sind.
Nee, auf Linux.
Weil wir gerade beim Movie gucken sind, man kann ja mit Quicktime, kann man ja zum Beispiel, zwar AVs gucken so einigermaßen, aber auch nur, wenn sie irgendwie einigermaßen ordentlich entkodet sind oder Perien es irgendwie auf die Reihe kriegt. Da gab es übrigens ein Update auf 1.1.4. Aber wenn man hier MKV runterlädt, also weil Leute immer gucken, Serien und Filme, die von Blu-ray kommen, die zum Beispiel 15 GB groß sind, da muss man dann doch immer M-Player benutzen oder VLC. So, und die beide meistens schaffen es nicht, so einen riesen fetten Movie abzuspielen. Und deswegen habe ich jetzt entdeckt, es gibt nämlich einen Multi-Threaded M-Player. Und den könnte man sich zur Not selber bauen, muss man sich halt ein bisschen anstrengen, geht aber. Aber es gibt auch von so einem Typen M-Player Extended, der hat den schon fertig zusammengecodet mit GUI. Und da kann man irgendwie so einen Button setzen, klickt, Multi-Threaded M-Player und dann rockt das wie Sau. Der nutzt irgendwie beide CPUs volle Pulle und dann spielt alles irgendwie ab, was vorher geruckelt hat wie nichts, geht jetzt butterweich. Wobei ich auch schon einen Film hatte, der ging dann immer noch nicht, aber der auch irgendwie wirklich riesengroß den hat er auch dann nicht geschafft.
M-Player Extended. Also ich hab ja neulich wieder mal M-Player, ich hab ja immer so eine Anwendung für M-Player bisher. Extended, was für ein Scheißname.
Also der besorgt sich immer die neuesten Sourcen, baut da so ein bisschen GUI drumrum und...
Na so heißt die Webseite.
Kann sein.
Und wenn das hier das ist, was... Bist du sicher, dass er das meint?
Das muss man auch erst einschalten, dass er den Multisthreaded... Das ist wohl FFmpeg, was da Multisthreaded benutzt wird. Und das muss man in Preferences einschalten. Und er meinte, das ist noch nicht so ganz so super stable, aber ich hatte bisher irgendwie noch keine Probleme damit.
Also ich panns M-Player immer als dritten Versuch, wenn ich mir irgendwie so Schrott-Avis angucke, die wieder kaputt kodiert sind, wo dann irgendwie nach der Hälfte der Zeit Ton und Bild auseinanderlaufen. Kennste das Problem?
Natürlich.
Und die einzige Möglichkeit ist halt, einen M-Player zu machen, weil M-Player ist der einzige Player, also der einzige, den ich jetzt kenne, oder zumindest der einzige, den ich kenne und installiert habe, der diese Fähigkeit hat, diese Differenz halt zu fixen.
Manuell oder von alleine?
Manuell. Du kannst so Plus Minus machen, dann geht er in 100 Millisekunden.
Das kann VLC auch.
Seit wann? Bist du sicher?
Weiß ich nicht. Aber ich hab schon gesehen, ich wollte letztens irgendwie Vorspulen oder irgendwie Apfel F, Apfel G oder irgendwie sowas und dann kam auf einmal plus 50 Millisekunden da im VLC. Naja, musste mal gucken.
Echt? Das wüsste ich aber gerne mal konkret, weil ich kann mich nicht dran erinnern, da diese Funktion steht.
Das wird bestimmt im Irk gleich einer sagen, wie es geht.
Im Irk wird wahrscheinlich erstmal gleich jemand sagen, ah, der Stream war weg.
Ja, ich hab auch gerade irgendwas ganz Böses gesehen hier.
Aber es gibt Sachen, die eigentlich vier, vier...
Wieso immer während der Sendung? Ich verstehe das nicht. Was, wie, was wolltest du gerade sagen, Max?
Reden wir weiter oder?
Ja, ja, wir reden weiter. Wir haben nur gerade einfach mal so eine Schweigeminute eingelegt.
Aber grundsätzlich so, dass ich sowieso immer VLC und M-Player und so weiter hin und her schalte, weil irgendwie einer hat immer Probleme und der andere kann es dann und so weiter. Also da muss man so fünf Minuten gucken, bis man weiß, welcher von den Playern die Film jetzt gerade am besten abspielt.
Immer mit Quicktime auf Imperium und hat keine Probleme.
Ich kann dir gerne ein paar Movies geben. Das muss denn nicht.
Das wundert mich jetzt bloß.
Jeder dritte, jeder vierte.
Ich lade immer nur HD-Stuff runter.
Auch ohne HD hast du diese Probleme.
Also ich hab, na gut, vielleicht lade ich die falschen, richtigen Sachen runter.
Vielleicht musst du mal die Pornfilme auch zu Ende gucken, und nicht immer nur die ersten fünf Minuten.
Und bei Porn ist eh egal, wenn es nicht synchronisiert ist, oder?
Ich geh immer vor, bis, bis...
Guckst immer schon zum Ende, ja? Weil du nicht erwarten kannst, die Pornfilme zu sehen.
Wird das Rohr noch fertig verlegt oder nicht?
Ab jetzt hat Mobile Max XXX Rating, ihr müsst jetzt 17 oder größer sein.
Genau, 17 plus.
Weil wir haben das Wort Hahn gesagt.
Hahn?
Jetzt lass uns mal mit AppStore and anfangen, okay?
Sind wir mit Snow Lappert schon durch?
Ich hab zu Snow Lappert nichts beizutragen, aber wir wollten ja generell über Mac OS X reden und da hab ich schon noch ein paar Themen, die ganz spannend sind.
Wir kommen ja zum iPhone noch.
Wir kommen da noch drauf. Es gibt genug zu beklagen und wir können auch dem geneigten Hörer schon mal sagen, wir brauchen Hilfe. Also Macintosh, wo wir gerade dabei sind. Oder wollen wir noch über Mac OS X reden?
Oder über den Macintosh?
Du meinst jetzt, ob wir zwischen Hardware und Software müssen noch irgendwie überlegen?
Ich versuch nur etwas Struktur anzubringen.
Scheiß auf Struktur.
Okay, also meine Mac OS X Themen sind auch alle nicht so wichtig, finde ich. Vielleicht kommen wir dazu vielleicht noch drauf. Aber ich habe jetzt einen Laden gefunden, und zwar bei monoprice.com. Ich hoffe, es gibt auch noch andere, aber in Deutschland habe ich noch nichts gefunden. Da gibt es tatsächlich Mini Display Port Kabel. Also nicht Adapter auf irgendwas anderes, sondern einfach lange Kabel, mit denen man mal seinen Computer woanders hinstellen kann.
Und was muss ich mir jetzt vorstellen? Die haben so eine Dicke von so einem USB-Kabel? Oder von so einem Fireware-Kabel? Oder von den USB-Kabeln, die beim iPhone dabei sind? So richtig schön dünne? Oder wie dick sind die? Weil der Stecker ist nun schon fast nicht da. Also von der Größe her, dann kann das Kabel ja nicht. Muss ja noch kleiner sein, oder?
Ein reines Extension-Kabel.
Ich kann dir hier ein Foto zeigen, aber das sieht jetzt nicht so dramatisch aus. Ich würde sagen, das ist so ein bisschen wie ein Ethernet-Kabel.
Also ich hab hier so ein Sechs-Fuß-Kabel.
Das ist ein bisschen dünner.
Das müsste dünner sein.
Das ist aber wirklich extrem dünn.
Das ist jetzt wirklich ein Verlängerungskabel. Mit einmal Incoming und einmal Outgoing.
Genau, das kannst du einfach benutzen, um das zu verlängern. Aber es gibt auch andere. Das ist jetzt hier Male-Female-Extension.
Zwei Meter müssten das sein.
Und das ist auch Extension. Und hier gibt es aber, hier ist Male-Mail, gibt es auch, aber da ist jetzt kein Foto dabei.
Aber die brauchen wir dann auch nur, wenn man das...
Die sind auch nicht im Stock, aber sind zumindest schon mal gelistet worden.
Die brauchen wir dann aber nur, wenn man das an einen...
Wenn du dir einen normalen Mac Pro kaufst und diesen 24 Zoll Bildschirm, dann kannst du nicht den Rechner auf den Boden stellen und deinen Bildschirm auf den Tisch.
Wieso nicht?
Weil das Kabel zu kurz ist.
Da ist doch so ein ewig langes Kabel dabei. Doch, ich hab das Ding zu Hause.
Du hast diesen 24 Zoll dabei?
Nein, 23.
Das ist kein Display-Port, aber...
Nee, nee, hab ich nicht. Ich hab den alten. Aber, da ist so ein ewig langes Kabel dran, dann so ein Splitter, wo irgendwie einmal, also bei meinem jetzt, DVI, USB und Firewall rauskommen.
Das ist ein ewig langes Kabel.
Was für ein Monitor hast du?
23 Zoll den Vorgänger.
Du hast nicht Mini Display-Port. Ich rede von Mini Display-Port.
Ich hab jetzt nur noch mal die alten Fakten aufgelistet.
Früher war ja auch alles besser, wie wir wissen. Und damals konnte man seinen Computer noch nach unten stellen und den Bildschirm auf den Tisch. Das scheint heutzutage nicht mehr hip zu sein. Apple meint wohl, man verdient heutzutage Geld nur noch mit Notebooks. Und deswegen muss man auch, wenn man ein Mac Pro kauft, das Gefühl haben, dass es ein Notebook ist. Und dazu muss halt der Mac Pro auch neben dem Bildschirm stehen. Oder auf dem Schoß.
Wie lang ist denn das Kabel?
Und legst den Mac Pro quer auf deine Beine, während du vor dem Schreibtisch sitzt und den Bildschirm davor. Dann reicht das Kabel.
Das ist zu kurz. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie kurz es ist, aber ich hab von so vielen Leuten schon gehört, dass sie kotzen. Es ist keine Freude, es ist kein Spaß. Und schon gar nicht kannst du den Rechner irgendwo hinstellen, wo er nicht laut ist. Und dann, weißt du, ich meine, das geht einfach nicht. Abgesehen davon, dass sie auch nicht die Gelegenheit genutzt haben, über dasselbe Kabel dann auch gleich noch USB durchzuführen. Nur wegen ihrer bekloppten Kamera, die aber eigentlich auch USB ist. Also ich verstehe einfach das alles nicht. Wenn sie... Warum? Das ist ein Scheißladen. Ich meine, was ist denn das bitte für eine Technologie? Da haben sie dieses Display-Port. Da ist dann irgendwie in der Spezifikation steht drin, da kann man auch USB drüber führen und dann machen sie es nicht. Was soll denn der Kack? Stattdessen diese komischen Splitter-Kabel. Ich finde das einfach mal inkonsequent. Es muss doch einfach eine Lösung dafür geben. Das wollten sie ja früher schon machen. Die haben ja alles versucht mit ihrem komischen Desktop-Stecker und so weiter.
Ja, sind aber auch jedes Mal schön mit auf die Kasse.
Da haben sie sich auf die Fresse gelegt, weil sie halt der Meinung waren, sie könnten darüber auch Strom zu führen. Und dann haben sie festgestellt, oh, größere Bildschirme brauchen ja mehr Strom und da reicht unsere Spezifikation nicht mehr aus.
Das ist knuffig, dass es mit dem Strom, das machen sie jetzt in eine andere Richtung.
Dass sie den Strom vom, ja genau.
Dass es vom Display zum MacBook schicken.
Ja, das finde ich auch in Ordnung. Das ist ja auch für ein Notebook eine coole Anwendung. Nur ist es halt alles an einem Kabel und am Ende ist diese peitsch. Das heißt, es ist eigentlich nur ein Bildschirm dafür. Wenn du aber jetzt den Bildschirm benutzen willst für dein Mac Pro, ist das Kabel halt einfach zu kurz. Das geht nicht. So, jetzt gibt es wie gesagt das erste Mal, zwar keine besonders hübschen, aber wohl hoffentlich funktionable Kabel, die sind auch nicht mal besonders teuer hier irgendwie, 6 Dollar, das ist ja ungewicht.
Dann reicht der Mac Safe ja wieder nicht bis zum Rechner.
Aber die haben auch einen...
Na gut, ein Mac Pro muss ja auch keinen Mac Safe reinstecken.
Ja, bei einem Mac Pro, ja ok.
Ich rede spezifisch von Desktop-Rechner. Wahrscheinlich ist einfach dieser Name Desktop-Apple irgendwie ein bisschen auf den Kopf gefallen. Sie meinen halt, wenn man einen Desktop-Computer hat, dann muss man ihn auf den Desktop stellen.
Wo hast du die Kabellänge jetzt gemessen? Hast du selber auch gesehen?
Welche, die jetzt mitgeliefert wird?
Von diesen 24 Zoll Display-Dings.
Von Leuten, die das Ding besitzen.
Live, Augenringe, Stress, Spass auf der Stirn.
Bei den 23 Zoll ist es ja auch so, dass nur ein Kabel aus dem Display rauskommt und dann auch irgendwie gesplittet wird und eins davon geht dann ins Netzteil, was dann irgendwie zur Steckdose geht.
Nee, guck mal, da sieht man doch zwei.
Ich muss ja erst mal erzählen, wie es früher war und dann erzählt man, wie es jetzt ist.
Du bist zu alt, Dennis.
Und jetzt geht direkt zwei Kabel aus dem Rechner raus. Eins davon ist das Stromkabel. Ich finde ja eigentlich, dass nur ein Kabel rauskommt, fand ich eigentlich ganz cool.
So, und jetzt können wir uns noch eine Stunde darüber unterhalten, dass es jetzt den Mini Display Porto High DMI Adapter auch bei Monoprice gibt, wie ich gerade gesehen habe. Das finde ich ja mal spannend.
Ja, sie haben da alles Mögliche, DVI, HDMI.
Hat der denn auch, hat eigentlich... Weiß das jemand, ob das, hat der Display, der Mini Display Port, hat der Sound mit? Nein, aber Sound, also er muss ja auch, der bietet doch die Möglichkeit, Sound mit zu übertragen. Ja. Und kommt das auch raus am MacBook? Kommt da auch Sound bei raus? Weil dann wär es nämlich total schick, weil dann könnte man einfach eine Mini-Display...
Na, der Sound geht über USB.
Naja, aber kommt das dann auch bei meinem Fernseher an? Das ist doch die Frage.
Ach so, das Problem. Das HDMI, also du meinst ob... Nein, nein, nein, nein, ach so, jetzt weiß ich überhaupt, wovon du redest. Du meinst, ob du auf Mini-Display-Port Sound mitgeben kannst, sodass das auf einem HDMI sozusagen auch gemeinsam ankommt? Die Antwort ist nein. Du musst dir da so teure Adapter kaufen, die gibt es, die halt, und zwar funktionieren die, aber soweit ich weiß, nur mit Digital-Audio-Ausgang. Also optisch.
Na, das hätte ich ja sogar immerhin.
Genau, das hättest du, das heißt du musst halt einen, so hast du so einen Adapter, der eben optisch Audio nimmt und das quasi in das DVI-Signal, also nicht in das DVI-Signal hinein rechnet, sondern der sozusagen einfach das Digital-Audio nimmt und auf das HDMI drauf macht, weil das ist eben dasselbe. Also wie dein Optischer Digital-Ausgang Sound rausschickt, so geht es auch auf dem HDMI rüber. Also HDMI macht auch nichts anderes als quasi SPDIF. Das ist jetzt eine Vermutung, da mögen einzelne Unterschiede drin sein, aber im Wesentlichen ist das dasselbe in Koding.
Und das haben die nicht mit in den Display-Port mit reingepunkt? Die Schwachmaten?
Na ja, es ist halt für... Ja, gut, da kann man jetzt echt drüber diskutieren, ob das eine kluge Sache war. Ich meine, es ist dann halt...
Ich dachte, das wären eine dramatischen Vorteile davon.
Wahrscheinlich sagen die dann, warum bauen die denn in ihre Scheiß-Fernseher kein USB-Sound rein, so, ne?
Na ja, aber warum... Den Fernseher hab ich schon.
Ja, ich weiß, und du hast ja auch Latenzproblematiken und so weiter, die kommen ja auch noch mit dazu bei USB. Das ist alles ungeil.
Die sind ja auch bei HDMI übrigens nicht zu vernachlässigen, ne? Was ist jetzt nicht zu vernachlässigen? Die kleinen Latenz-Rotstimmigkeiten. Du hast eine gewisse Latenz drauf, also wenn du zum Beispiel an Apple TV, wenn du da HDMI-Signal rausgehen lässt und Audiosignal gleichzeitig. Also ich hab Analogport, hab ich meine Anlage dran und über HDMI hab ich gleich mein Fernseher dran. Und wenn ich beides gleichzeitig anhabe, was natürlich relativ häufig mal passiert, dann hat man ein kleines Echo.
Wenn du was gleichzeitig... Achso, wenn du sowohl Sound über den Fernseher laufen lässt, als auch über die Anlage und da hast du unterschiedliche...
Genau, da hat das Apple TV minimale...
Und was kommt zuerst?
Ich glaube, dass Analoge tatsächlich. So wie man es erwarten würde.
Das HDMI kommt später?
Das HDMI kommt später.
Ja, das ist halt Digital-Audio. Hab ich ja auch hier schon ein paarmal beklagt. Digital-Audio-Latenz sucks.
Das ist ein echtes Problem. Man merkt es nicht, wenn man...... wenn man Film guckt. Also es ist nicht so stark, dass man jetzt die Bewegung der Münder plötzlich nicht mehr synchron ist oder irgendwie sowas.
Aber man merkt es.
Aber man hört es, wenn man beides gleichzeitig macht.
Ja, das ist alles nicht so schön.
Gut, haben wir jetzt lang genug über Kabel geredet?
Ja, haben wir. Aber ich hab noch was zum Thema. Habt ihr dieses schöne Video gesehen von diesem Hack mit der Tastatur-Firmware?
Nee, ich hab nur drüber gelesen.
Ein Video davon hab ich auch nicht gesehen.
Ja, da gab's ein längeres Video, wo das irgendwie mal so demonstriert wurde und ich hab mir das mal so ein bisschen angeschaut. Und das ist schon ein ganz ordentlicher Hack. Was sie halt gemacht haben ist, sie haben halt einen Apple-Tastatur-Firmware-Update re-ingeniert, also diese Applikation, die das Update macht, re-ingeniert, disassembliert und rausgefunden, was die machen.
Sie haben den Updater re-ingeniert? Ja, die haben den Updater benutzt, um ihre eigene Firma reinzuschieben.
Entschuldigung, sie haben ihn nicht, sie haben ihn analysiert, sie haben ihn quasi reverse-ingeniert.
Moment mal, das ist jetzt ein Unterschied.
Das haben sie ja funktioniert, aber sie haben ihn jetzt nicht neu geschrieben, sondern sie haben ihn ausgenutzt.
Naja, sie haben ihn erstmal analysiert, was er überhaupt macht, um einfach zu gucken, wird die Firmware eigentlich in irgendeiner Form autorisiert. Und sie haben festgestellt, dem ist nicht so. Also es wird einfach nicht mit irgendwelchen Signaturen gearbeitet, sondern sie verlassen sich ausschließlich darauf, was die Tastatur per USB sagt. Das ist vielleicht wieder eine Chance für Palm, wenn sie da irgendwie ihre Tastatur reinbringen, dann könnten sie sich eben auch die Firmware Syncs mit Apple Firmware Updater. Ok, Spaß beiseite. So, und dann haben sie halt geschaut, dann haben sie die Tastatur aufgemacht, haben geguckt, was da für ein Stein drin ist. Das erinnere ich jetzt gerade nicht, was das ist, aber es ist alles nicht so kapabler Hardware, aber eben schon ein eigener Chip mit ein bisschen Ram, nicht viel, aber etwas. Und dann haben sie einfach die Firmware modifiziert, haben halt rausgeguckt, wo so Checks um und tra la la, es gibt da so verschiedene Überprüfungen, aber eben alles nicht besonders Hardcore. Und haben es letzten Endes geschafft, eine geänderte Firmware in die Tastatur reinzubringen und haben sozusagen als Demo so einen Keylogger eingebaut. Der war jetzt erstmal sehr simpel, weil im Wesentlichen war es so, wenn du dreimal Return gedrückt hast, dann hat er den Inhalt der letzten Zeile, die du eingegeben hast, nochmal ausgegeben. Einfach um zu zeigen, dass die Tastatur selbst deine Eingaben speichert. Und das haben sie sozusagen in so ein Update da reingeballert. Das Besondere daran ist, also erstmal ist ein Keylogger natürlich eine problematische Geschichte, aber das Besondere daran ist, sie nutzen halt die Firmware dieser Tastatur und wenn du deinen Computer neu installierst, bleibt das Ding da drin. Was natürlich ein echtes Problem ist, weil wenn du es schaffst, und da ja jetzt auch keine besonderen Security-Geschichten drin sind, heißt es, hast du halt einmal Zugriff auf den Rechner gehabt, kannst du die Tastatur eben neu Firmware-Update reinbauen und dann irgendwas damit machen.
Nein, noch viel schlimmer. Du brauchst, wenn der Rechner sogar noch geschützt ist, kannst du im Zweifelsfall, wenn es ein Desktop ist, die Tastatur abnehmen, eine andere Tastatur ranpacken, was jetzt sicherlich niemand als Sicherheitsproblem sieht.
Austauschen und dann hast du halt irgendwelche Passwörter gespeichert. Dann brauchst du immer nur noch gucken, was für Strings speichern wir raus.
Wobei nach Ausschalten kriegt das wahrscheinlich nicht hin oder sowas. Aber ich meine, da kann man sich schon was ausdenken. Man könnte ja irgendeine URL im Browser aufrufen.
Also du meinst, wenn die Tastatur keinen Strom hat, dass sie das irgendwie nicht speichern kann. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob die irgendwie so festes Raum drin haben.
Im Zweifelsfall hoffst du irgendwann drauf, dass du jetzt im Browser bist.
Ich würde jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass der Hack als solcher der Untergang des Abendlandes ist. Aber es ist halt interessant, dass eben dieser Punkt Firmware-Update-Autorisierung bei Apple doch eine relativ schwache Nummer zu sein scheint. Dass sie da einfach nicht wirklich viel Arbeit investieren. Dass die Tastatur sich einfach so von allem Möglichen updaten lässt. Man könnte ja auch sagen, die Tastatur selber prüft irgendwie kryptographisch noch eine Signatur und lässt sich einfach nur von Tools und mit irgendwie Sachen aktualisieren, die sich eben in irgendeiner Form kryptographisch authentifizieren ihr Gegenüber. Das hat natürlich auch irgendwie alles seine Grenzen.
Die haben jetzt wieder eine neue Hacker-Tür geöffnet. Da müssen jetzt noch mal sich einfallen lassen, was sie dagegen tun. Da kommen wahrscheinlich demnächst nur noch Tastaturen mit irgendwie Protection oder auch nicht. Oder wo man die nicht mehr flashen kann. Oder wo man irgendwie eine spezielle Taste drücken muss, damit sie sich flashen lässt. Aber weil hier meinte auch jemand im Chat, wie das denn gehen soll. Wenn der Hacker erstmal auf dem Rechner drauf ist, dann startet er einfach das Keyboard-Update-Firmware-Programm. Da geht es alles von alleine. Da braucht man keinen physikalischen Zugang. Wie sinnvoll das nun am Ende ist und so weiter. Weil man muss ja auch immer wieder auf dem Rechner drauf sein, um es dann auch auslesen zu können. Oder man könnte dann später die Tastatur abziehen und es dann von da holen. Obwohl, es ist ja nur Ram und kein Flash. Also ist alles nicht so easy, es ist auch alles sehr theoretisch.
Ja gut, aber die Tastatur könnte solche Sachen dann einfach...
Auf bestimmte Key-Kombinationen, die letzten 128 Zeichen.
Ja, einfach per Funk verschicken oder auch eine Software, die dann irgendwie...
Bau da eine Bluetooth-Tastatur ein und die nimmt dann einfach zu einem anderen Gerätkontakt auf.
Es ist ja auch nicht nur Tastaturen, es gibt ja auch viele andere Dinge, die so... Wir hatten das ja schon so, auch der Bildschirmadapter hat irgendwie eine Firmware. Also alle Firmwares, die in diesem Computer aktualisiert werden können. Einschließlich der Firmware des Computers im Übrigen. Ja, also könnte es ja theoretisch auch die Firmware des Rechners auf diese Art und Weise aktualisieren. Und das ist irgendwie alles nicht so schön. Jetzt können wir zu iPhone kommen.
Genau, und zwar können wir gleich weitermachen. Und zwar gab es da ein Update, die 301, weil auch auf der gleichen Konferenz dieser Black Hat-Conference da, irgendwie dieser Charlie Miller oder wie er heißt, plus noch ein anderer, habe ich den Namen jetzt vergessen, weil die dort einen Exploit vorgeführt haben, wie sie mit mehreren irgendwie Multipart-SMS oder wie auch immer das iPhone-Lamen legen.
Das ist eigentlich mittlerweile publiziert worden?
Was genau publiziert worden?
Na, wie das funktioniert? Was da sozusagen das Problem war? Oder haben sie das nur so?
Pff, wo fragst du dir Sachen? Du meinst, man sollte mal mehr recherchieren, ne?
Naja, ausnahmsweise. Also ich meine, es war irgendwie angekündigt, dass sie darüber reden wollen.
Ich hab das jetzt nicht so verfolgt. Die haben das da vorgestellt und genau einen Tag später kam von Apple auch schon der Patch. Aber angekündigt war es ja schon vor. Ich denke mal, Apple hat da schon vorher was gewusst. Also innerhalb von einem Tag patchen die das auch nicht.
Ich bin ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen überrascht über die Aussagen darüber, was mit dieser Lücke machbar gewesen ist. Also es war ja auch die Rede von Code Injection und irgendwie Execution auf Arbitrary Code.
Ja, aber das ist doch immer, die finden irgendwie was, was abstürzt und dann sagen sie, möglich wär dann auch, dass das Telefon von selber...
Wo bleibt denn da die Sandbox irgendwie? Also Arbitrary Code innerhalb der Sandbox.
Die meinten wohl irgendwie, dass die SMS-Applikation oder dieses Control-Center, was sich wohl darum kümmert, nicht in einer Sandbox läuft, sondern das ist schon halt irgendwie, wenn du das Ding hast, dann bist du ja schon bei dem Code, der SMS schicken und senden kann, dann ist ja auch die Sandbox egal, weil du den Power sozusagen in deiner Sandbox schon hast, selbst wenn es eine wäre.
Ja, das stimmt.
So, und das ging aber wohl nur irgendwie mit mehreren SMS hintereinander. Da stand auch was von 512, weil sie immer wohl ein Byte irgendwo überschreiben können oder irgendwie so. Also ich glaube, einen Exploit gab es gar nicht. Also sie konnten es wahrscheinlich crashen lassen, aber das war es dann halt auch schon. Weil die Mühe, dann nämlich den richtigen Exploit zu schreiben, der dann auch den Shellcode und so weiter, oder was die auch immer da alles machen, aussieht, das ist schon noch ein bisschen mehr Arbeit. Der kommt ja dann erst, dann glaube ich, wenn es nicht gepatcht wird, wenn es sich dann auch lohnt, den auszunutzen. Aber jetzt da ja alle irgendwie oder viele 301 einspielen, lohnt es sich ja schon gar nicht mehr, sich da diese Mühe zu machen. Wobei man da immer aufpassen muss, wie Leute, die hacken ja zusammen aus Gründen, die sind ja unerfindlich, ich kenne das auch. Und da weiß man nie, was die Leute so für einen Scheiß machen.
Ja, und da gibt es auch einen relativ simplen finanziellen Anreiz, muss man ja auch mal sagen, weil schick, bau dir irgendwie ein Virus da raus aus dem Ding, was sich selber weiter verbreitet.
Na, ein SMS-Bordnetz, da warten die alle nur drauf. Das ist schon ein Anreiz.
Und dann ruf irgendwelche Premium-SMS abmassenhaft und mach dich schnell mit der Kohle aus dem Staub. Also ich meine, das ist wirklich mal eine Sache, wo man verhältnismäßig einfach Geld verdienen kann, ohne dass das jemand bekommt.
Ja, ich denke auch, deswegen hat Apple da so schnell reagiert. Also das konnten sie sich echt nicht leisten.
Ja, aber sie haben ja nicht innerhalb von einem Tag reagiert. Das war ja Tage vorher angekündigt, dass die SMS-Lücke gepräsentiert wird.
Also ich finde das ehrlich gesagt ganz schön erschreckend, dass sie sich sowas durchgehen lassen. Also dass sie...
Dass es so ein Buckle of Guard?
Ja, dass sie einfach da immer noch keine Audit-Maßstäbe haben, mit denen sie das verhindern können. Aber das zeigt eigentlich immer nur wieder mal, dass... Wie heißt es immer so schön? 100%ige Sicherheit kann es nicht geben. Außer natürlich...
Wanda Schäuble als Innenminister.
Genau. Die Vorlage, die du gemacht hast. 3GS.
3GS? Wollen wir direkt? Wir haben ja fast...
Du möchtest doch unbedingt. Oder willst du dich erst mal über den App Store beklagen?
Ich wollte erst mal über den App Store. Okay. Wie wahrscheinlich viele mitbekommen haben, gab es... Also, wir regen uns ja gern mal über den App Store auf. Oder ich reg mich gerne auf. Du fandest das ja bisher immer noch nicht ganz.
Ich rede mich auch gleich mit auf.
Es gibt zwei Punkte, zwei Ereignisse seit der letzten Sendung, wo rausgekommen ist, dass Apple Programme abgelehnt hat, bzw. sogar im Nachhinein entfernt hat. Die eine ist ein Google Voice App. Google Voice ist jetzt, soweit ich das verstanden habe, das, wovor die großen amerikanischen Telcos im Augenblick zittern. Weil es so eine Zusammenführung aller Telefondienste ist, die man hat.
Was soll diese App eigentlich getan haben?
Damit kannst du deine Telefonnummer managen. Whitelist und Blacklist und Weiterleitung und Personalized.
Managen? Das ist nicht eine Telefonier-Applikation. Das ist ein reines User-Interface für administrative Dinge.
Sie wollen es als Web-Interface bauen?
Genau, deswegen gibt es das auch als Web-Interface. Also kannst du sagen, wenn der anruft, soll das gar nicht erst durchkommen. Wenn der anruft, soll auf jeden Fall durchkommen. Spezieller Klingelton oder keine Ahnung, was man dazu einstellen kann. Du kannst auch sagen, wo du hin das weiterleitest, ist das mehr so ein Rufnummer Management.
Und was war das Argument?
Bei der Gelegenheit haben sie auch gleich ein paar andere Programme.
Das ist doch ganz klar. Wenn man es so Fake Steve mäßig macht, die haben uns irgendwie angepisst mit ihrem Andeut. Jetzt pissen wir halt zurück. So hat das Fake Steve das jetzt geschrieben.
Bei der Gelegenheit haben sie...
Und Eric Schmidt Go Home.
Genau. Und er hat auch geschrieben in der Fake Steve, dass der Typi auf jeden Fall raus ist. Er war auf jeden Fall raus.
Er ist jetzt raus.
Der musste das Board verlassen.
Ich hab leider... Ich bin immer noch nicht dazu gekommen, Fake Steve wieder aufzunehmen.
Ich lese da auch nur manchmal, wenn es...
Ist er noch so gut wie früher? Das kann er, ne? Alles andere war irgendwie echt scheiße. Der musste wieder zurückkommen, ne? Wieder lesen, irgendwas. Wer nicht weiß, wovon wir reden, weiß...
Das ist lieber Schuhmacher, der wollte auch zurück...
Gibt's im Chat irgendjemand, der nicht weiß, wovon wir reden, dann erklären wir es nochmal. Wie viel Delay haben wir? Wir müssen immer irgendwie so 10 Sekunden warten, bis da eine Reaktion kommt. Das wüsste ich ja mal wirklich gerne. Hier, sagt einer. Okay, erklären. Also Fake Steve Jobs ist... Wie heißt der denn? Lyons heißt der Typ eigentlich. Ist so ein Schreiberling, eigentlich. Den so recht glaube ich kaum einer gekannt hat, bis er dann mal angefangen hat, einen Blog aufzusetzen, Fake Steve Jobs, wo er halt schreibt, als wäre er Steve Jobs. Und ich muss sagen, das war eine der lustigsten Blog-Actions des... Wann fing das an? Vor ein, zwei Jahren, ne? Und es ist so komisch, weil er sich einfach auf so eine ganz göttliche Art und Weise in diese wahrgenommene Person Steve Jobs hineinversetzt und einfach so schreibt, wie man es irgendwie immer erwarten würde, aber wie Steve Jobs es natürlich selber nie tun würde.
Jedenfalls nicht öffentlich.
Ja genau, er lebt eigentlich die öffentliche Person Steve Jobs aus, die es nicht gibt und die wir aber eine irgendwie haben wollen. Das Geile ist dabei, dass er einfach immer so großartige Wahrheiten dabei auch produziert.
Als wenn er wirklich, entweder wirklich der echte Steve ist oder von dem gefüttert wird oder voll irgendwie...
Aber nicht so sehr, weil er Insiderwissen hat, sondern weil er einfach...
Weil er gut analysieren kann.
Weil er einfach gut analysieren kann und da gute Sachen macht. Komischerweise in dem Moment, wo er selber den Lines ist sind seine Analysen totaler Schrott, aber wenn er irgendwie als Fake Steve Jobs schafft... Es ist ein bisschen überspitzt, weil er... Es ist ja auch so überdreht und dann hat er immer so großartige Namen für alle anderen, ne?
Oh Gott. Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr. Also ich weiß noch, dass der von San war My Little Pony. Wegen seinem lustigen Ferne-Schwanz. Und wie heißt Auma gleich? Steve Auma? Ist doch irgendwie...
Monkey Boy. Sweat all over. Ja, können wir euch empfehlen. fakesteve.blogspot.com ganz großartig.
Ja, auf jeden Fall haben sie jetzt Google Voice rausgeschmissen und bei der Gelegenheit noch ein paar andere Apps, die schon vorher Google Voice unterstützt haben auf dem iPhone. Die sind einfach rausgeflogen.
Ja, die haben einfach keinen Arsch in der Hose. Die Frage ist nur, wer war schuld?
AT&T weist alles weit von sich.
Also waren sie schuld?
AT&T hat ein Statement veröffentlicht, wo drin steht, dass sie keinen Einfluss darauf haben, welche Programme zugelassen werden. Woraufhin dann... Woraufhin dann ein paar Leute gesagt haben, ja, welche zugelassen werden, vielleicht nicht, aber vielleicht welche abgelehnt werden. Sie haben sich zweitundig ausgedrückt. Auf jeden Fall ist jetzt gerade die FCC, was heißt das, die amerikanische...
Bisschen lame, dass die erst dann irgendwie auf den Plan kommt, weil es jetzt so eine große Firma wie Google erwischt, aber über einen kleinen Mini-Developern vorher hat sich keiner aufgeregt. Finde ich ein bisschen...
Ich meine, denen geht es halt da sozusagen um den Wettbewerb und das ist natürlich der Wettbewerb unter den Großen. Dass Google da jetzt sozusagen auch schon eine Rolle spielt, ist auch interessant.
Aber die FCC setzt langsam ihren fetten Arsch in Bewegung und ich glaube vor dem kann Apple auch ein bisschen Angst haben im Zweifelsfall, weil die können den ganzen App Store mal schön deregulieren.
Vorstellbar, ich bin nicht so sehr vertraut jetzt mit der Power, die sie jetzt wirklich da juristisch haben und wie das in den USA so läuft. Aber ausschließend will ich das jetzt auch nicht.
Na ja, das geht noch ein bisschen in Richtung Netzneutralität auch. Und sozusagen das DSL-Netz ist relativ neutral noch. Also das Festelnetz, aber das Mobilfunknetz ist nicht neutral, wie wir alle wissen, wie auch in Deutschland ja nicht, wie in Verträgen das und das gesagt wird, dass man bestimmte Anwendungen nicht nutzen kann. Und darauf achten die halt ein bisschen verstärkt.
Es könnte auch ein bisschen an Obama liegen.
Es könnte auch ein bisschen an Obama liegen. Und wenn da plötzlich ein Hersteller eines sehr populären Mobiltelefons ankommt und unter fadenscheinigen Gründen Produkte der Konkurrenz rausschmeißt, dann kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass die da mal das nicht ganz so gerne sehen.
Es ist schon echt eine Hanebüchen-Aktion. Vor allem ist es deshalb Hanebüchen, weil sie einfach auch noch Applikationen, die sie vorher approved haben, einfach wieder rausschmeißen. Und das ist schon echt eine ganz schön linke Nummer. Wir haben uns ja schon einige Male darüber gestritten und so weiter. Und muss auch sagen, wenn dann halt Apple da irgendwie eine generelle Position annimmt und sagt einfach, okay, ihr seid nicht Teil unseres Produktes, dann muss man das halt ein Stück weit eben auch akzeptieren. Andererseits ist es natürlich jetzt auch so, der Markt, wir sind jetzt nicht mehr am Anfang der ganzen Geschichte. Man kann glaube ich sagen, dieser Upstore ist einfach ein riesiger Erfolg und auch das iPhone ist ein Erfolg. Weil sie sind von einem Monopol noch weit entfernt. So und von daher finde ich immer diese Monopolschreie rein, finde ich immer so ein bisschen albern, weil das passt nicht. Nur weil sie jetzt einen Vorteil haben, den sie sich einfach auch verdient haben, heißt es noch lange nicht, dass sie jetzt Monopolist sind, weil wir sehen, Google kann eine große Bedrohung sein in jeder Hinsicht und auch andere Player sind noch durchaus vorstellbar auch. Wenn ich in zunehmendem Maße Google als... Ja, also ich meine, wer ist in der Lage, Apple wirklich zu ärgern derzeit? Also zu Microsoft habe ich meine Meinung ausreichend kundgegeben, das werde ich jetzt nicht wiederholen, aber ich glaube, Google hat dieses Potenzial.
Ja, sonst ist der Typ ja nicht umsonst rausgeflogen.
Und ich glaube vor allem, weil sie diese unsägliche Ambition an den Tag legen. Wir machen mal ein OS, dann machen wir mal eine Handyplattform, was weiß ich, was das nächste ist. Wir kaufen uns auch noch ein Mobilfunknetzwerk oder sonst irgendwas. Sie sind ja beratet, einfach alles irgendwie zu machen, um ihren Markt auszuweiten und sie haben extreme Mittel und Fähigkeiten. Was haben sie auch? Store? Achso, für Android meinst du jetzt? Ja klar. Naja, das wird ihnen schon nicht so sehr geschmeckt haben. Andererseits glaube ich, dass der Markt an sich groß genug ist, sowohl für Android als auch für iPhone. Das war jetzt nicht die Frage. Die Frage ist, wie verhalten sie sich? Und was wirklich schlimm ist, ist halt einfach die Art und Weise, wie sie mit den Software-Entwicklern umgehen. Weil das geht einfach gar nicht mehr. Und das ist glaube ich auch der Hauptgrund, dass es einfach keine verlässlichen Regeln gibt. Also die haben ja nicht mit den Regeln Probleme, sie haben damit Probleme, dass sie keiner kennt. Das ist ja so ein bisschen Kafka-est schon. Da kommt dann irgendwie jemand vorbei und sagt, sie sind verhaftet. Ja, warum denn? Ja, das können wir ihnen nicht sagen. Aber ich möchte ja jemandem sprechen.
Das ist ja irgendwie mit unserem Zugangs-Erschwerungs-Ding ins Gesetz.
Diese Seite ist gesperrt, warum denn? Das darf ich ihnen nicht sagen. Und das sagen sie einem, das steht drauf. Kippo, andersrum. Wie auch immer. Aber du weißt, Kafka, Prozess, sagt dir was, ne? Genau. Und da ist es ja so dieses, du wirst eingesperrt, aber wir sagen dir nicht warum. Ja, aber ich will irgendwie hier frei sein. Oder ich möchte, oder auch das Schloss, noch so ein Kafka. Also es gibt, der Prozess ist der bekannteste und dann gibt es das Schloss, das ist eine ähnliche Situation, da steht er halt irgendwie vor diesem Schloss, da sind so zwei Wärter, er will halt da rein und die Wärter sagen halt, nee, geht nicht. Und warum ja, nee, erklären sie ihm nicht. So ähnlich ist das so ein bisschen mit diesem Upstore. Also hier stehen sie alle so wie in diesem Kafka-Schloss und wollen da irgendwie rein und es gibt aber keine wirklichen Erklärungen warum. Und noch schlimmer ist, man wird jetzt auch noch aus dem Schloss rausgeschmissen und dann kriegt er dann auch keine Erklärungen warum. Oder zumindest keine nachvollziehbaren Erklärungen. So, das ist halt echt schlimm.
Wo gab es keine nachvollziehbare Erklärung? Bei welchem Fall?
Bei Google Voice. Nein, es ist ja nicht so, dass sie wirklich mal dargelegt hätten, warum jetzt auf einmal ein Approval wieder zurückgezogen wird. Eine Applikation hat sich ja nichts geändert. Das heißt, du hast eine Zusage. Selbst wenn du es geil finden oder akzeptieren könntest, dass du monatelang entwickelst und dann ist es immer noch so ein Glückslos, ob du angenommen wirst. Weil du ja die Regel nicht wirklich genau kennst und auch keine Möglichkeit hast, im Vorfeld, also das glaube ich, das mag für manche Firmen die Möglichkeit geben, aber ich denke im Wesentlichen ist die Kommunikation so schlecht, dass eben ein kleiner Developer im Prinzip nichts anderes machen kann, als erstmal seine Applikation schreiben. Da ist er monatelang unter Umständen dabei. Dann reicht er es ein, um dann festzustellen, es wird nicht angenommen. So, selbst wenn man damit leben könnte, was ich schon für nicht sehr okay halte, wenn man dann aber angenommen wird. Man ist da auch noch monatelang drin und hat vielleicht auch schon Sachen an Kunden verkauft. Es steht ja sozusagen auch da in der Kreide irgendwie Updates oder Supports zu liefern, weil man ja eine Dienstleistung verkauft hat und dann ein Vertrag eingegangen ist. Und dann kommt Apple und sagt so, ach nö. Das geht einfach gar nicht.
Jetzt ist ja noch die Frage gewesen, was passiert jetzt mit den Leuten, die ihr Geld zurückverlangen, weil ich keine Updates liefern kann?
Jaja.
Dann bleib schon mal deine Geldbörse bereit, weil wir zahlen das nicht. Das war die offizielle Ansage.
Ach, das haben sie auch schon gesagt. Das haben sie auch schon gesagt. Das geht einfach gar nicht. Diese Pisser. Ich meine, an der Stelle übernehmen sie sich wirklich. Das geht nicht. Aber sie kriegen jetzt echt einen Einlauf. Und die Tatsache, dass Mr. Fishiller himself schon in der Lage, oder sich gezwungen fühlt, sich zumindest für die etwas übertriebenen Darstellungen in Einzelfällen zu entschuldigen, über diese Google-Voice-Geschichte, haben sie meines Wissens bisher noch nichts gesagt.
Nö, da haben sie nichts gesagt. Das war ja ein ganz anderer Fall.
Ja, das ist dieses...
Mr. Fishiller hat jetzt zu zwei Sachen was gesagt. Und zwar einmal zu dem Diktionary, weil der Wörter wie Fuck vorkam, hat halt erklärt, dass da halt wirklich Schimpfwörter drin vorkamen. Und das Programm halt...
Also das ist Wiktionary, muss man dazu sagen. Also es ist einfach Wiktionary, das Wörterbuch in eine Applikation gepackt.
Ja, aber er hat es damit erklärt, dass sie es halt unbedingt vor dem OS-3.0-Update rausbringen wollten. Also da gab es noch, warte mal, kein Parallel Control mit 17+, und die hätten ihnen wohl vorgeschlagen, dass sie es danach doch rausbringen, sondern auf 17+, dann wäre alles gar kein Problem. Sie wollten es aber unbedingt vorher machen. Das war so im Juni oder so. Deswegen haben die Developer freiwillig diese Wörter da entfernt. Und haben wohl aber auch nicht alle rausgekriegt.
Naja, aber wir müssen auf der anderen Seite auch sagen, es geht um ein Wörterbuch.
Ja, weißt du, wie die Amis so sind? Die sind halt immer ein bisschen komisch.
Nee, die Amis sind nicht so komisch drauf. Es gibt andere Wörterbücher, die auch im App Store drin sind, die von Apple durchgegangen sind, die auch Wörter wie Fuck enthalten.
Die machen ja so einen riesen Skandal, weil beim Super Bowl mal so ein bisschen eine Brustwarze zu sehen ist. Da sieht man doch schon, dass die da ein bisschen komisch sind.
Aber die Argumentation ist, die ja durchaus nachvollziehend finde, selbst, wie heißt dieser gigantische Markter, der Walmart, der ja nun wirklich alles zensiert, was nicht bei drei auf den Bäumen ist in seiner Abteilung, selbst der hat keine Probleme mit einem Wörterbuch, in dem das Wort FAK drin auftaucht. Der würde das deswegen niemals zensieren oder raten. Oder haben sie bisher noch nicht gemacht. Apple macht das plötzlich. Apple sagt, pass auf, du kaufst ein Wörterbuch, in dem Wörter drin auftauchen könnte, die englische Sprache sind. Und da muss man ja sagen, das ist ja, die haben ja sogar noch irgendwie...
Weil sie es da noch nicht auf 17 plus taggen konnten.
Nein, aber warum ein Wörterbuch auf 17 plus steht auf einem Duden drauf? Achtung!
Wir sind ja ja in Deutschland.
Nee, ich glaube nicht, dass die da... Also wie gesagt, es gibt auch im App Store, gibt es auch andere Diktionaries, die hier veranhalten.
Ja, die haben einen Stock im Arsch.
Und wahrscheinlich sogar deswegen, weil da könnte so eine Mama ankommen, die irgendwie ein Junior oder ein Mädchen hat oder so, der irgendwie dann das Diktionär, das Wort sucht, eine Erklärung findet und irgendwie die Welt nicht mehr versteht und ein psychologisches Problem hat.
Und dann hat Apple dran Schuld.
Nicht, wenn er einfach einen psychologischen Schaden nimmt, nachhaltig in seinem Leben, weil er irgendwie auf einmal auf die Forderung ist.
Erfahrene hat, dass es Geschlechtsverkehr gibt.
Ja genau, was ich bin durch Geschlechtsverkehr entstanden. Ja, aber ich dachte unbefleckte Empfängnis und so.
Also das ist affig. Es ist total affig. Und was mir in dem Bereich dann auch wiederum Angst macht, ist, Apple verkauft nicht nur irgendwelche Apps, wo man sagen könnte, naja gut, was sich da auf dem iPhone abspielt, ist das eine. Aber die verkaufen auch Filme, die verkaufen auch Musik. Und wann wären die ähnliche Maßstäbe da anzuwenden?
Na gut, ich meine, Perinsel-Controls sind ja nun bei Filmen gang und gäbe.
Ja, aber...
Das steht da auch drin sozusagen.
Also ich meine, wir können uns wahrscheinlich ein für alle mal abschminken, dass jemals über iTunes Pornografie zu erwerben sein wird.
Ja, eigentlich muss man Angst haben um die Plattform deswegen. Ich meine, das wäre so die erste populäre Technologie, die hier ohne Porn kommt.
Und wenn die dann irgendwann mal anfangen, ihre Maßstäbe tatsächlich auch auf Filme anzuwenden, wenn sie sagen, nee, dieses Rating, was andere vorgeben, das ist uns nix, weil hier sagt irgendjemand das Wort...
Da sollte man so ein Porn-Smartphone bauen. Nehmst du irgendwie Android, baust spezielle Pornofeatures ein. Pornoid.
Es gibt doch so eine Art...
Ich bin Pornoid.
Ich weiß nicht, was da draus geworfen hat. Mit diesem Android, der so dicke Titten hat vorne.
Jetzt dreht der schon wieder völlig durch.
Nur weil ich Pornoid bin, heißt das noch lange nicht.
Aber es gibt doch in Amerika, da gibt es doch von Pornoherstellern, es gibt ja diese Hulu und diese ganzen Plattformen, also auch Apple TV gehört ja dazu, die man so auf seinen Fernseher sitzen kann und Filme gucken kann. Pornos kann man über die alle nicht gucken, aber die Pornoindustrie hat ein eigenes Gerät dafür gebaut. Was dann auch auf den Pornokonsum zu Recht optimiert ist.
Was für ein eigenes Gerät haben sie gebaut?
Ein Gerät, was du, ich weiß leider nicht mehr von wem es war, ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, ob es jemals in Handel gekommen ist oder nicht mehr auf irgendeinem Messer gezeigt worden ist. Es ist so eine kleine Set-Up-Box, die du in deinen Internetanschluss anschließt und darüber halt Filme gucken kannst und die ausschließlich für Pornografie gedacht ist. Und dann auch so Features hat, wie gib mir die letzten zwei Minuten im Looping-Modus oder so.
Hatten wir ja letztes Mal schon. Ich find ja Pornos super. Ich hatte so ein bisschen berichtet aus meinem früheren Leben.
Ach stimmt, als Pornosynchron.
Als Pornodarsteller.
Nein, als in einer Firma arbeitend, wo Pornos auch synchronisiert worden sind.
Die sich so ein bisschen aus Haut finanziert hat vor allem. Wir haben nicht so sehr Porno gemacht, aber wir haben einfach davon gelebt, von dem Pornodollar. Was ja auch okay ist. Pornos leiten einfach einen echten gesellschaftlichen Beitrag. Stell dir mal vor, du würdest hier morgen alle Sex-Shops und prostituierten Läden und alle Hörnbars schließen in Deutschland. Weißt du, was ich als erstes machen würde? Ich würde zum Baumarkt fahren, mir irgendwie eine Lastwagenladung Dachlatten holen und vorne meine Fenster zunageln. Weil es dauert keine Woche und dann hast du hier Loonies, die durch die Straße rennen und einfach nur noch um sich schießen. Weil es einfach nichts Schlimmeres gibt als eine unterversorgte, mit Pornografie unterversorgte Gesellschaft. Dann drehen die mich alle total durch. Wenn du das irgendwie nicht bietest...
Oder sie würden ihre Fantasie wiederentwickeln.
Ach schnick schnack, die gehen auf den Zahnflaschen. So ein Pornoladen, so ein Beate-Uses-Shop, der hat einfach eine soziale Aufgabe in diesem Land. Da bin ich mittlerweile so tief von überzeugt. Diese Politiker, die immer irgendwie Pornografie verdammen und so weiter. Naja, das ist nicht nur so, dass sie so ein bisschen daneben liegen. Die verkennen einfach die Situation. Das ist auf der gleichen Ebene, als würdest du morgen Fußballspiele vermieten. Kannst du dir vorstellen, wenn Bundesliga-Verboten-Schilder irgendwo rumstehen würde und so weiter, was hier abgehen würde, dann würdest du aber auch sofort in den Baumarkt fahren. Und ich dachte, bei Porno ist das einfach genauso.
Aber bei Porno-Verbot erstmal eine Latte kaufen, ist natürlich auch lustig.
Wollen wir noch den zweiten Teil von Phil Schiller? Kannst du den vielleicht auch nochmal nachtragen, Dennis? Jetzt, wo du dich bei der Porno-Diskussion schon so rausgehalten hast, so verdächtig.
Also bei Porno kann ich nur nochmal nachschieben, dass ich letztens nochmal einen Kumpel getroffen hab, mit dem ich mal früher in der Videothek gearbeitet hab. Und der hat gesagt, früher war der Porno-Anteil in der Videothek 40 Prozent.
Und jetzt?
Drei bis vier.
Wirklich?
Also nicht gedacht, vielleicht schon. Hab ich nur nie gedacht.
Aber es ist so dramatisch eingebrochen, als hätte ich ihn wirklich nicht geahnt.
Naja, ich meine, warum sollen wir da Geld ausgeben?
Ja, wohl Leute im geschlechtsfähigen Alter haben wahrscheinlich alle, also es ist wahrscheinlich, dass da diese Altersgap, die noch keinen Internetanschluss hat, die auch keine Bedarfe mit Pornos hat.
Du kriegst ja im Internet auch anderen Porn. Du kriegst ja diesen ganzen Privatporn irgendwie Nachbarschaftssex-Dinger irgendwie.
Im Internet gibt es ja alles, oder?
Naja, aber es gibt da halt auch Special Interest. Den kriegst du, glaube ich, so ohne weiteres auch in der Videothek nicht abgedeckt, weil da gleich wieder irgendein Gütesiegel fehlt oder so.
Wahrscheinlich.
Wobei, wer es noch nicht gemacht hat, kann ich immer wieder empfehlen, einfach so in Videotheken mal in die Porno-Abteilung gehen und einfach mal nur die Titel durchlesen.
Ich kenne da noch meinen Lieblingstitel.
Chicks with Sticks. Das war der Lieblingstitel.
Kann man immer gut aus der Tasche holen, wenn man irgendwie einen ärgern will mit Pornos. Chicks with Sticks. Und dann so, hä?
Na gut, ich will mich jetzt nicht so sehr in Pornotiteln ergehen, aber jetzt nochmal Filmchiller Teil 2, die letzte Gelegenheit.
Jetzt muss ich wieder ein bisschen rumeiern, aber das ist ja unsere Stärke. Und zwar gab es da wohl einen Developer, der meinte, er hätte jetzt die ganze Schnauze voll davon.
Steven F von Panic.
Erzähl du das mal, ich glaub, ich weiß da gar nicht so viel. Ich weiß nur, dass einer ausgestiegen ist.
Der ist einfach frustriert.
Bist du auch nicht einfach irgendein Apple-Entwickler?
Ja, Panic ist halt so, die machen so Transmit und diesen ganzen Kram. Und der sprach aber auch explizit für sich und nicht so sehr jetzt für Panic. Wobei ich meine, also Panic hat keine iPhone-Software. Am Start, oder?
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Würde mich erstens nicht wundern, wenn sie welche in Vorbereitung hätten, aber...
Ja, hätte mich jetzt auch nicht gewundert. Die sind ja irgendwie ganz gut unterwegs, aber wie auch immer.
Nee, ich glaube, die haben tatsächlich keinen iPhone ab bisher.
Ich wüsste auch nicht, was sie haben. Was sehr schade ist, weil ich finde Panic macht, ist einfach eine dieser wirklich geilen Buden.
Die waren die ersten, die so Candy-Software entwickelt hatten. Ja, aber auch so die schön aussah, die geile Alkons hatte. Die wirklich, die wirklich.
Waren sie die ersten?
Naja, mit die ersten, würde ich sagen.
Ja, sie waren auf jeden Fall vorne weg.
Also Transmission ist ja nun, das gab es ja schon zu Mac OS 9 Zeiten. Das wäre wirklich ein richtig, richtig, richtig altes Programm.
Transmit meinst du?
Transmit, ja. Transmit.
Also Transmit gab es nicht zu Mac OS 9 Zeiten.
Doch. Ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, dass das Alkan plötzlich als Mac OS X Alkan draußen war.
Nein, nein, nein. Sicher?
Ich glaub es nicht.
Damals mussten wir uns noch mit Fetch rumschlagen und so ein Scheiß.
Doch, ich glaub aber auch.
Transmit, Mac OS 9? Hab ich da so eine Gedankenlücke?
Also die Wikipedia sagt, dass es das, dass es das schon zu Mac OS Classic gibt.
Ich bin euch sicher? Ist das alles schon so lange her?
Transmit? Das kam damals raus als Konkurrenz zu Fetch.
Das war damals plötzlich, ja, ja, da gab's so.
Fetch gibt's auch noch.
Ja, guck mal, da haben sie sogar noch die Seite drauf, so mit dem alten Transmit 1.7 von Mac OS 9.
Ach.
Das ist schon 1.7, also kannst du dir vorstellen.
Das gab's schon zu acht irgendwaszahlen.
Hab ich da was verpasst? Ja. Okay, gut, ich nehm alles zurück und behaupte, das geht nicht.
Ich fand den damals schon doof, ich fand immer Fetch irgendwie cool. Saß zwar nicht so schick aus.
Fetch war wirklich furchtbar buggy.
Nee, hat aber gerockt, wieso?
Wie lange hat das gedauert, bis sie in der Lage waren, lange Dateinamen zu unterstützen? Sehr, sehr, sehr lange.
Braucht doch keinen.
Und Transmit ist auch vor allem deshalb geil, weil es irgendwie einer der wenigen FTP Clients ist und vor allem SFTP Clients ist, muss ich sagen. Also ich benutze das Teil ja vor allem für SFTP. Ich benutze eigentlich eh nur SFTP. Und das Tool kommt halt klar mit der Keychain. Das heißt, du hast halt deinen SSH Key in der Keychain.
Na ja, das können aber auch andere.
Das können aber auch andere nicht. Also dieses Cyber Duck zum Beispiel kriegt das irgendwie glaube ich auch in der neuesten Version noch nicht hin. Und ich kenne viele Probleme mit, also viele Programme, die es einfach nicht gemacht bekommen. Aber mit Transmit ist es einfach mal easy going. Also wenn man SFTP mit Keys macht, Transmit kaufen.
Also zwei Programme, die es definitiv können, ist Jummy FTP heißt das. Das ist eins, was ich mir irgendwann mal gekauft habe. Das hat den Vorteil, das ist ziemlich unbekannt. Also ich war früher mal ein totaler Interarchy-Freund. Kennt man bestimmt auch noch.
Und was der Nachfolger, der Rename war von Anarchy.
Und das gibt es bis heute, wird noch weiterentwickelt, hat irgendwann mal an Schönheit verloren. Was die hatten, die konnten diese Spalten an sich. Also Transmit hat ja dieses relativ Norton-Commandereske oder wie auch immer, also dieses zweispaltige linke Spalte, Mac-rechte Spalte, FDP-Sicht. So diese klassische Ansicht. Und dieses Jummy-FTP, genauso wie Interarchy, hatte halt diese Spalten an sich, die ich immer sehr gemocht habe.
Wie jetzt im Finder meinst du?
So aus wie im Finder, genau. Das hat aber auch Transmit. Ja, das hat es mittlerweile auch. Aber es hat so richtig schick, fand ich. Und was ich bei Interarchy immer noch total auch geil fand und dann bei Jummy FTP auch gut fand, obwohl Transmit kann es mittlerweile auch, das konntest du aber ewig lange nicht, dass ich für unterschiedliche Dateiendungen unterschiedliche Editoren definieren konnte.
Ah, verstehe.
Also für CSS-Dateien. Genau, also ich kannte, dass ich eine Datei direkt auf dem Server bearbeiten kann, dass ich dann mit Apfelj in einem Fall Text-Mail fliege.
Direkt auf dem Server, sondern so scheinbar.
Genau.
Du lädst eine Kopie runter, die geht ins Tempverzeichnis, der Editor wird gelancht, du änderst es, dann sagst du save in dem Programm und dann geht's wieder zurück zur Applikation.
Genau. Interarki kann das auf jeden Fall, was aber relativ teuer war, das kann dieses Jummy-FTP, was nebenbei auch noch so eine Sache kann, wie Dateien, gerade per SFTP, Dateien direkt auf den Server komprimieren. Also kannst du ein Ordner auswählen, mach mir daraus mal ein ZIP-Archiv. Dann schmeißt du den Befehl direkt oben an und lädt die Dateien nicht vorher alle runter. Na auf den Server. Wenn du SFTP hast, hast du ja in den meisten Fällen auch SSH Zugang.
Ach so, der macht dann sozusagen über SSH ein Login und ruft die Kommandezahler auf. Weiß nicht.
Ist eine Option, die man hat. Wenn es funktioniert, ist es wahrscheinlich cool. Ich hab's tatsächlich nicht sonderlich oft genutzt, aber die ein, zwei Mal, die ich's genutzt habe, waren's wirklich so. Das ist schick. Und was ich jetzt ganz gerne nutze, was ich mir gekauft habe, ist Expand Drive. Das ist so was, was das mit diesem McFuse in den Finder integriert. Also das Laufwerk gemontet wird wie eine echte Platte. Und das gibt's auch. Es gibt McFusion. Das ist ein kostenloses Programm, was was ganz ähnliches macht. Und es gibt Expand Drive. Das kostet ein bisschen was. Aber macht das Ganze besser.
Es basiert aber beides auf...
Es basiert beides auf...
Also auf den User, Space, File System, Drivers, der Google, der Haini, der...
Auf jeden Fall hat Google das doch angetrieben.
Ja, das ist ja eine Main Developer, der auch im Kongress war.
Ahmed Singh.
Der das Buch geschrieben hat. Der hat das auch partiert.
Genau. Und Mac Fusion kann das Ganze kostenlos, aber hat so Bugs wie zum Beispiel in der Finder Sidebar erscheinen aus irgendeinem Grund die Volumes nicht, die nachgeladen worden sind.
Mac Fusion bringt das schon komplett mit?
Und was es noch ist, es matcht die User-IDs nicht. Das heißt, man kann unter Umständen, man sieht dann im Finder hat man dann einen Ordner und obwohl man per SFTP theoretisch auf den zugreifen könnte, glaubt der Finder, dass man auf diesen Ordner nicht zugreifen darf. Und das kann man mit einem zusätzlichen Parameter auch abstellen, das heißt, man kann eigentlich theoretisch einen ähnlichen Komfort, wie ihn Expand Drive für Geld bietet, auch mit der Mac Fusion kostenlos Version irgendwie hinbiegen. Aber ich hab irgendwann mal gesagt, die 30 Dollar ist es mir wert. Und bin sehr glücklich mit Expand Drive.
Okay, ich hab auch schon mal drüber nachgedacht, aber ich hab schon immer Transmit und eigentlich... Ich vertraue ja dem Finder nicht so. Weil der Finder macht halt so Scheiße. Und wenn das so Fallsystem ist, dann macht der mir da so meine Punkt-tralala...
Ich weiß, was du meinst. Wobei ich glaube, dieses Punkt-tralala machen sie gar nicht. Muss ich allerdings nochmal nachgucken.
Dann kann man da abschalten oder so, dass sie das irgendwie nicht machen. Aber es ist halt so ein gefährlicher Bereich. Bei Transmit, das ist halt so weit entkoppelt, da bin ich irgendwie noch sehr konservativ, glaube ich. Weil ich hasse es einfach, wie Apple mit dem Finder auf Unix-Verzeichnissen umgeht. Das ist einfach nicht okay.
Ja, wobei sie müssen es noch nicht mal tun. Ich hab's jetzt in ein paar Situationen, konnte ich sehr an. Also zum Beispiel so, du hast, ich musste neulich mal mit Find, habe ich dann auf der Mac-Seite ein Find gestartet, habe nach Dateien gesucht und habe mir die alle per Kommando-Zeile direkt in Text-Made bzw. dann BB-Edit öffnen lassen. Das ist sowas, das kannst du per Transmit oder sowas, kannst du das total knicken.
Verstehe, weil es halt eben nicht...
Also es gibt, man hat halt, genau, es kann zwei Systeme. Das hat schon schöne Anwendungsfelder.
Auf jeden Fall, ok, das ist ein guter Punkt.
Ja, aber wir waren ja eigentlich bei Steven F und seiner Kritik am iPhone.
Genau, naja er hat einfach, wenn ich es richtig mitbekommen habe, im Wesentlichen einfach öffentlich und plastisch dargelegt, dass er das einfach mal alles total scheiße findet und er einfach sein Vertrauen in Apple verloren hat, so jetzt mal übertragen gesagt, und hat sich sozusagen einen Boykott auferlegt. Hat also gesagt, ich boykottiere das jetzt einfach mal, eigentlich nicht sehr viel mehr. Also er hat weder jetzt zum Boykott aufgerufen, noch, weißte, ein großes Hauptabdruck rumgemacht, sondern er war einfach nur so ein depressiver Software- Developer mitten im Leben, der irgendwie gesagt hat, ich würde ja gerne, aber so fühle ich mich einfach mal verarschen, ihr seid doof. So. Und dadurch, dass es halt einfach ein Entwickler von Panic war, der dann entsprechende Aufmerksamkeit im Netz bekam, hat es wohl auch gereicht, um auch hier wieder für Schiller losreiten zu lassen. Und die Mail hat er ja nicht veröffentlicht, sondern er hat ja nur gesagt, ja, also sehr kleine Auszüge, nicht so wie bei Jordan Gruber, da war ja mehr. Im Wesentlichen ging es halt darum, dass er ihm gesagt hat, dass das und das und das und das, was er angesprochen hat, da würden sie daran arbeiten. Andere Dinge nicht, die seien so nicht umsetzbar, er hat jetzt nicht gesagt, welche das sind. Und naja, ich glaube ja schon, dass die ganz schön wach geworden sind. Ich verstehe allerdings nicht, warum, warum sie es überhaupt so weit haben kommen lassen. Also, dass die jetzt gerade unter einem massiven Expansionsdruck stehen. Okay, das sehe ich ja auch. Wie viele Developer haben sie jetzt offiziell?
Über 100.000.
Developer? 100.000 Developer?
Ja, ja, das gehen noch die, allein seit März oder so, haben die doch 50.000.
Ja, das ist schon voll alt. Was aber auch daran liegen kann, weil irgendwann diese...
Aber es gibt doch nur irgendwie 60.000 Ups.
Ja, und? Ich bin auch Developer und habe auch noch keine eigene App draußen.
Na gut, aber mit Developer, die keine Ups haben, haben sie ja keinerlei Upstore-Kommunikation. Also ich rede jetzt wirklich so von aktiven...
Weiß man ja nicht. Also die Leute, die Programme draußen haben halt.
Gut, aber was ich meine ist, dass dieser real existierende Traffic und diese Probleme... Es gibt einfach so viele Sachen, die er angesprochen hat, die sind einfach mal verdammt wahr. Und ich habe damit gerechnet, dass Apple da schneller eine Lösung findet. Das Problem eins ist einfach dieses... Also wir hatten ja eben schon diesen Fall, dass einfach die komplette Kundenbeziehung gekündigt wird, dadurch, dass die Applikation rausgenommen wird. Das ist einfach schon mal besonders hart. Aber jetzt in dem Fall gehen sie einfach um sowas wie schnelle Updates.
Das geht ja auch nach hinten los, weil wenn jetzt die Kunden denken, wenn ich mir das kaufe, und das ist eh schon so ein heikles Programm, wer weiß, ob demnächst Apple das nicht rausschmeißt, dann kaufe ich es nicht.
Uncertainty und Doubt.
Das will Apple eigentlich auch nicht, dass der Kunde irgendwie unsicher ist. Also das mit den Developern so umgehen kann ja sein, aber der Kunde muss halt das iPhone cool finden, der darf sowas nicht denken.
Genau.
Und ich glaube, das ist bei Apple jetzt ein bisschen zu heiß geworden. Und dass der Filmchiller an den Gruber schreibt, der ja schon, wie sagt man, stark gesehen wird nach außen, also Außenwirkung, wie man es dann nennt, weißt schon, dass der da hinschreibt und der weiß auch, dass das auf jeden Fall dann gepublished wird, heißt ja schon, dass sie da irgendwas machen, weil der labert ja nicht nur rum und dann kommt demnächst nicht. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Sehr gut, aber die Frage ist, was tun sie? Ich hatte jetzt auch diesen Fall, ich bin da gerade mal ebenso nicht in die Falle reingetippt, hier diese Bankapplikation, die ich auf dem iPhone verwende, da haben wir glaube ich schon mal drüber gesprochen, dieses iOutBank Pro, was soweit für mich ganz gut funktioniert. Und jetzt auch, ich glaube als wir drüber geredet hatten, gab es das Update für Überweisen noch nicht, also man kann damit jetzt auch irgendwie überweisen. Hat auch funktioniert, als ich es getestet habe. So, da kam dann irgendwie ein neues Update. Und ich mach's mir immer so, ich hab so die Routine, dass ich mir vorher immer anschaue, was hat sich geändert. Das ist ja auf dem iPhone ganz schön gelöst, auf dem Mac muss man immer irgendwie so gucken.
Das ist echt lustig, dass es auf dem iPhone so viel besser funktioniert.
Jaja, manche es funktioniert auf dem iPhone besser, manche es auf dem Mac. Wie auch immer, da hab ich mir das durchgelesen, und was steht da? Warnung, dieses Update bitte nicht runterladen, es löscht ihre Pins. Warten Sie, bis die neue Version 2016 kommt. Wir sind in Kontakt mit Apple. Dass das möglich schneller geht. Das hat zwei Wochen gedauert. Zwei Wochen stand dieses Update im Store, mit dieser Meldung, und das war alles, was sie tun konnten.
Glück gehabt, dass wir die ändern konnten überhaupt.
Ja, also ich meine, warum können sie nicht revertieren auf die Version davor? Zum Beispiel. Also als schnelle Maßnahme. Also wenn dir jetzt wirklich ein Update sozusagen passiert, gut kann sein, dass das Update davor noch schlimmer war. Weil die Version, mit der ich die ganze Zeit gearbeitet habe, da war ja eigentlich alles okay. Also sie können nicht einfach etwas rückgängig machen und sagen, eine Version, die schon mal da war, nehme ich jetzt wieder rein. Und natürlich auch, sie können, obwohl sie zwei Wochen lang vorher schon angekündigt haben, wir haben schon den Fix, kommt der einfach nicht durch. Und das ist einfach mal nicht in Ordnung.
Also ich meine, da kann man im Zweifelsfall auch einfach mal einen gewissen Vertrauensbonus reinchecken und sagen, wenn da jemand drei Versionen reingeschmissen hat, die alle super waren, warum soll der plötzlich anfangen, das Programm mittendrin funktionell wahnsinnig zu verändern?
Es ist echt ein Drama und ich hab auch schon den Eindruck, ihr Kack, also ihr System, dieser wir schauen uns wirklich jedes Update an und wirklich wieder so mit nem, wie sitzen die Leute da? Ich hab das Gefühl, die sitzen da so ein bisschen, ne das sag ich jetzt nicht, aber das können die doch nicht ernst meinen, dass die sich wirklich jedes scheiß Update anschauen wollen. Das skaliert doch einfach nicht. Wie viele Leute wollen die da beschäftigen? Wollen die da irgendwie ganz China einspannen, damit die da irgendwie ihre Software-Updates checken?
Hab ich ja auch gelesen, dass diese pakistanische Firma irgendwie komplett rausgeschmissen hat, die über 950 Programme schon in den App-Store eingereicht hat, die auch alle schon im Store waren, und weil aber die sich um keinen Copyright und keinen gar nichts gekümmert haben und überall geklaut haben, was nur geht, haben sie den kompletten Laden gesperrt und alle 900 Programme rausgeschmissen.
Weil das auch total Bullshit-Programme waren. Also in dem Fall muss ich sagen...
Ja, das ist schon okay, aber da sieht man ja, was die da zu tun haben, weil die Firma alleine hat fünf, also im Durchschnitt fünf neue Apps pro Tag eingereicht.
Naja, furchtbar. Was war denn das überhaupt für Programme?
Ich glaube im Wesentlichen haben die so Bildchen gezeigt. So nackt Bildchen.
Nackt Bildchen?
Also ein Bildchen halt, irgendwie Mädchen in Badeanzügen für einen Dollar.
Ich hab auch gelesen, dass die ja auch irgendwie Sporten, News und Zeug, also alles immer nur zusammen geklaut haben, wo sie Lack haben.
Okay, vielleicht gab's da noch mehr.
Hier der Flash irgendwie. Der Flash klagt hier auch im Chat irgendwie, er könnte seit zwei Monaten nichts tun mit seinem Update. Irgendwie jede Anfrage per Mail ans Review-Team läuft ins Leere. Keine einzige Mail bekommen seit zwei Monaten, egal um was es ging. Also auch vollständige Totenstille. Also nicht nur irgendwie scheiß Mail und nein, sondern halt auch nichts. Das muss richtig frustrierend sein. Das ist so wie Einzelhaft eigentlich, so ein bisschen. So Isolationsfolter ist das. Die armen Software-Developer, die sitzen da einfach zu Hause. Apple, ich liebe dich, rede mit mir. Ich geb dir alles, was ich habe. Und dann einfach nichts.
Alles nicht, 30 Prozent.
Die machen sich natürlich alle schon extrem abhängig davon. Wenn du dich dafür entscheidest, iPhone-Development zu machen, das ist jetzt irgendwie dein Business. Bei all ihren ganzen Veranstaltungen haben sie immer diese Videos gezeigt, von der einsamen Developer, der in der großen Firma gearbeitet hat. Und dann hat er das iPhone entwickelt und jetzt macht er sich selbstständig. Und er ernährt seine ganze Familie nur noch von iPhone-Development.
Dann sollten wir mal das gleiche Video drehen, wie einer das gemacht hat, abgelehnt wurde.
Genau, wie er seine Familie verhungert, die Kinder schreien, seine Frau verlässt ihn unter der Brücke. Genau, das Auto explodiert, das ist furchtbar. Und da bringt er sich um. Das wär mal ein schöner Film, oder? Genau, Apple, the power to be your best.
Und wir machen Werbung für Apple. So, aber jetzt wollten wir ein bisschen noch iPhone direkt reden. Sind wir am Store durch jetzt?
Ja, ich finde, wir haben jetzt genug geratet. Jetzt können wir sie wieder loben. Es gibt ja nichts zu loben. Das ist ja alles scheiße und es stinkt.
Wir haben drei neue Spielzeuge, ne?
Zwei.
Also drei und eins ist?
Ich will nicht spielen.
Jaja, ich darf wieder nicht mitspielen.
Fangen wir erst mit den positiven oder erst mit den negativen Nachrichten an?
Ja, ich war ja sowieso die ganze Zeit nicht beteiligt. Erzählt ihr einfach mal, was passiert ist.
Der erste positiven oder der erste negativen?
Der Roddy hat uns...
Ja, was weiß ich?
Er hat sich angeboten, uns aus Italien iPhones mitzubringen, wo wir alle drei geschrien haben. Ja, bring uns iPhones mit!
Genau, wir wollen ganz viel Geld ausgeben.
Wir wollen ganz viel Geld ausgeben, was wir dann auch betan haben. Und darum haben wir drei iPhones bekommen.
Aus dem Apple Store.
Aus dem Apple Store in Roma.
Genau. Und da gibt es auch ein Bild, der hat irgendwie gleich fünf Stück gekauft.
Echt?
Ja, das waren ein paar mehr.
Mir nicht.
Was?
Hat er mir dann nochmal geschickt. Da warst du definitiv mit dran. Der hat dann wohl den Store-Typen auch gefragt, was denn hier so die maximale Anzahl an iPhones ist, die man kaufen kann. Weil in anderen Stores gilt wohl die Regel zwei pro Käufer. Und der Typ in Italien meinte, was? Maximal? Nee, kann man ja nicht ganz so viel kaufen, wie wir da haben. Wie viel willst du? Hat er fünf Stück gekauft.
Guck an. Die halten sich mal wieder an keine Regeln. Der Typ ist wahrscheinlich am nächsten Tag gefeuert worden.
Der ist so scheiß angebunden, der Laden, dass dort sich die Phones irgendwie stapeln, weil man da irgendwie nicht so toll hinkommt.
Also man findet den Laden nicht. Den Apple Store, Rom, findet man nicht. In der Mall. Ich such mal das Foto.
Und ja, darum haben wir jetzt...
Ach, drei iPhones.
Drei iPhones.
Drei GS, 32 Gig und alle schwarz.
Genau. Ich hab diesmal auch ein schwarzes genommen, weil ich mag ja das Weiße eigentlich lieber.
Warum hast du nicht ein Weißes genommen?
Weil ich mit...
Ah hier.
Weil das doch so ein bisschen angerissen war beim letzten Mal.
Weil das weiße Plastik anderes anfälliger war, meinst du?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es anderes anfälliger ist oder anderes sieht man besser anfälliger ist, aber auf jeden Fall sah es nach relativ kurzer Zeit schon nicht mehr schick aus.
Ich hab das Foto nicht. Bei mir kam das nicht durch.
Kriegste später Timme.
Dann bleiben wir es dir noch weiter.
Ja, mach mal.
Und, ja und jetzt war eins davon war quasi. Da bleibt der, das kam an, da war der Akku leer. Wo ich mich erstmal sehr gewundert habe, wieso ist denn da der scheiß Akku leer? Dann hab ich gedacht, na okay, lade ich's eben. Hab's in die Steckdose gesteckt, hab so lange das andere aktiviert, das andere war überhaupt gar kein Problem, da war der Akku nicht leer. Da dacht ich, na gut, letztes. Dann beim festgestellt nach einer Weile, warum denn der Akku leer war von dem Gerät? Weil nämlich der einen Ausschalter kaputt ist. Und der die ganze Zeit zickt. Da müssen wir jetzt irgendwie das iPhone nach Italien wiederbringen und tauschen lassen.
So, jetzt müssen wir uns hier mal an die Community wenden. Ist denn jemand von euch, wohnt denn jemand von euch in Rom? Das wär ganz toll. Wir brauchen einfach mal eine zuverlässige Person, die irgendwie bereit ist, mal mindestens einen Nachmittag einen Kleinen zu opfern und dann mal hinzulatschen und den Leuten irgendwie in fließendem Italienisch klarzumachen, dass sie uns da Scheißverkauf haben.
Alldreckige Arschlöcher sind.
Genau, alldreckige Arschlöcher sind. Und überhaupt, dann soll man klarkommen. Und sonst, wenn sie in unserem nächsten Steve Jobs Pornomovie irgendwie eingeblendet. Wir filmen sie einfach und dann, wenn sie da mit Final Cut Studio da rein operiert. Und ja. Und dann hätte ich es gerne in heile wieder zurück. Keine Ahnung, ich meine, die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist hoch, dass sie sich motiviert fühlen, da sofort ein heiles Gerät aus dem Regal zu nehmen, weil dieses Teil ist einfach mal ganz offensichtlich im Arsch.
Das ist wirklich so ausgepackt worden. Also das ist offensichtlich schon beim Transport kaputt gewesen, weil ansonsten wäre der Akku nicht leer gewesen.
Ja, also ich meine, das hat auch durch das Liegen in seinem eigenen Karton nicht kaputt zu gehen. Also das ist einfach mal so.
Also und der Karton ist ja komplett unbeschädigt.
Genau. Und wenn keiner in Rom wohnt, dann was weiß ich, vielleicht fährt ja irgendwer hin oder macht da mal Urlaub oder so. Und wenn er in Berlin wohnt, wäre es natürlich nochmal besonders toll.
Es sollte aber auf jeden Fall Rom sein, weil dann geht es wahrscheinlich am schnellsten. Und wir haben halt das Gerät original verpackt. Wir haben die Rechnung, ist alles da.
Und weiß irgendjemand, ob man das einfach auch einschicken kann mit irgendwelchen Tricks?
Das wäre natürlich auch interessant zu sehen, ob da irgendjemand Erfahrungen sind. Aber ich habe so ein bisschen mein Italienisches, irgendwie ein bisschen mau. Mit anderen Worten, ich kann es nicht.
Also es gab ja Leute, die es geschafft haben, im Apple Store zu bestellen in Italien?
Ja gut, aber das ist ja nicht der Store Retail, sondern der Store...
Na ja, aber die Reparaturen müssen sich ja immer der selber kümmern sozusagen, oder?
Apple Store Online und Apple Store Retail, das sind zwei vollständig disjunkte Unternehmen. Also das kannst du nicht vergleichen. It's a different story man. Wir haben jetzt genug den Papst.
Der bunt doch auch noch rum.
Keiner Italienisch, der redet doch bestimmt Latein mit dem W.
Hey Ratze, bringst du mal unser iPhone vorbei? Ich auch, ich gebe ein bisschen Apfel drauf.
Ansonsten hätten wir das hier vielleicht mit HBemos 3GS irgendwie aufgemacht. Ihr durftet ja jetzt schon eine Woche spielen, ich bin ja irgendwie raus.
Meine ganze Woche noch nicht.
Du warst doch im Urlaub, ich war der erste, der abholen durfte.
Na ja, ist ja in Ordnung, aber ich dachte ja, ich komm wieder und freu mich. Und jetzt das Desaster. Ich bring mich um. Okay, ich bring mich nicht um.
Gut.
Nee, ehrlich gesagt, das ist jetzt so schlimm auch nicht, aber ich hätte so nichts dagegen gehabt. Das ist ein Gerät, für das ich bezahlt habe, aber auch funktioniert.
Ja.
Aber das kriegen wir schon. Aber ich mein's behalten. Genau, aber es ist tatsächlich ein sehr schönes Gerät.
So generös bin ich. Ich wähle einfach freiwillig das Kaputte.
Du hast mir gesagt, du hast mir ein Name geschrieben, aber dafür schuldest du mir einen Gefallen.
Du wolltest eh Pizza besorgen heute. Hast du gesagt.
Ich wollte Pizza? Nein.
Du hast gesagt, du hättest irgendwie Geld zum Geburtstag für Pizza und wir könnten ja mal was aussuchen.
Nein, ich habe ein Angebot von einem Hörer bekommen, dass wir uns hier mal Pizza bestellen könnten.
Das war nochmal was anderes.
Nein, ich weiß.
Aber normalerweise haben wir ja...
Hast du nicht gesagt, dass da einer zu deinem Geburtstag auf dich zukam, dir Geld gegeben hat und wieder gegangen ist?
Stimmt, dann hättest du vorgeschlagen, dass das ja für uns alle sein könnte.
Ich hab gar nichts vorgeschlagen und gar nicht geantwortet auf die Mail.
Ich dachte, das war die Sache mit der Clubmarte.
Ich hab dafür eine Flasche Sekt ausgegeben auf meinem Geburtstag.
Whatever.
Und mit der Clubmarte hab ich auch schon mal... Das war bei Zur Republika. Das war aber explizit... Hier, Jungs, ihr macht so eine tolle Sendung.
Das ist ja auch in Clubmarte geflossen. Die steht ja hier auf dem Tisch.
Ja, aber iPhone 3GS ist eine tolle Sache.
Schwerd mal schön vor.
Na gut, fangt an.
Weil meine Story ist bestimmt schön lang. Also, ich hatte ja vorher noch so ein Classic. Bekannt als kann nix. Und hab mich vorher informiert, weil ich ja eine freudige Erwartung war, wie man das so nennt. Und wusste schon, ich hab eine O2-Karte, die 10 Jahre alt ist.
Und nicht UMTS kann.
Und die kein UMTS kann. Hab ich mich vorher informiert, weil ich wusste es ja schon, ich kriege ein 3GS. Also irgendwie angerufen hier bei... Quatsch, nicht angerufen. Bin in die Friedrichstraße hier gegangen, bin in den O2-Store, der da ist, gegangen, hab gesagt, hier, 10 Jahre alte Karte, ich hätte gerne eine UMTS-Karte, hat da rausgeholt, hat da selber angerufen, das klargemacht, weil die können das da auch nicht selber, die rufen da auch nur an. Und dann zack, hatte ich schon mal eine neue SIM-Karte. Prima, steht nicht mehr Entercom in meinem Telefon da, sondern schon mal o2.de. Also immer noch in dem alten. Aber ich hatte schon mal die neue Karte. So, dann jetzt diesen Sonntag kam das 3GS an. Also die kam aus Italien, dann hab ich es mir da abgeholt, hab die neue Karte reingesteckt. Ich kann telefonieren, geht, das ist ja ein Unlocktes. Aber ich hab nur GPS. Also ich kann irgendwie GPS benutzen. Es geht alles, alles funktioniert. Ich kann telefonieren und so weiter. Aber nur GPS. Und dann hab ich irgendwie ein bisschen umgefragt bei unseren Telefonexperten. Mein O2-Vertrag ist gar nicht freigeschaltet, weil der so u-alt ist, dass bei UMTS muss man sich irgendwie auch noch mal das Fachwort des Wohlprovisionieren lassen. Musste also noch mal bei O2 anrufen. Hab ich gesagt, ja, hier folgendes Problem, neue Karte, aber kann kein UMTS, aber Datenrate hier 200 MB im Monat für 10 Euro hab ich. Irgendwie, und das ist jetzt keine Werbesende, auch wenn ich so oft O2 sagen muss. Aber hier schaltet mal frei, war der Typi ganz nett, hat's auch gleich freigeschaltet, wollte mir gleich noch DSL anreden, hab ich gesagt, nee danke, bin schon bedient. Und dann irgendwie eine Stunde später mit einmal Telefon neu starten, gingen dann auch 3G, UMTS, tralala und so weiter. So. Und dann aber, es ist ja noch nicht fertig, dann hat schon erstmal funktioniert das iPhone, aber ich hab natürlich auf meinem 3GS die Daten von dem alten Telefon gleich eingespielt, weil das kann man ja machen. Du steckst das Telefon ran an iTunes, der macht das so ein bisschen, alles klar, er aktiviert es gleich, weil es ja ein Unlocked ist, macht das gleich, weil vorher geht es nämlich auch irgendwie nicht so richtig. Dann spielst du dein altes Backup ein, da hast du alle SMS, Telefonnummer, Programme, alles, kannst alles komplett eins zu eins aufs neue Telefon schieben. So, dann klicke ich irgendwie alles so durch, was ich weiß, was früher schon so Probleme gemacht hab, und zwar YouTube. Klicke ich, geht nicht.
Wie hat früher schon Probleme gemacht?
Na, ging bei mir nie so richtig, außer du hast gerade den Hack irgendwie den...
Was, die YouTube-Applikation?
Doch, die läuft, aber die sagt, dann sie kann nicht connecten.
Ach.
Das ist immer dann, da gibt's, das wird vielleicht bei Red Snobies, den Hackertools da eigentlich gleich mit geregelt, dass wenn du das nicht richtig aktiviert hast, dass die das irgendwie für dich machen, indem die wahrscheinlich sich irgendwie eine ID zusammenklauen oder was auch immer die da machen. Aber manchmal ging's dann halt auch immer irgendwie nicht. Und hab ich mich schon immer so ein bisschen mit abgefunden und so gelassen, weil ich ja auch keinen Bock hab, immer wieder neu zu installieren, nur weil der Scheiß da geht. So und dann dachte ich mir aber schon, alles klar, das geht jetzt auch nicht, das YouTube auf dem neuen Telefon, weil ich natürlich mit dem Backup einspielen die alte YouTube ID wahrscheinlich auch mit eingespielt habe.
Wie ID?
Ist doch aber die Geräte-ID, oder?
YouTube ist doch Google.
Google will dich tracken. Also funktioniert YouTube von Google nur mit irgendwie einer ID, damit sie immer wissen, du bist es. So, die ID wird irgendwie beim Starten vom Telefon erstellt, hat wahrscheinlich auch mit dem Aktivieren irgendwie zu tun, oder wird...
Wie meinst du jetzt ID, dein Google-Account?
Ich weiß nie was, die erzeugen sich da so eine Art...
Es gibt so eine Geräte-ID...
Es kann auch eine ganz eigene sein, es muss gar nicht mal die vom iPhone sein, aber die erzeugen...
Die beim Aktivieren des Geräts erzeugt wird und die unter anderem auch an die YouTube-Applikation übergeben wird.
Nein.
Und nur mit der geht's, weil sonst geht's dir nicht.
Und wenn du einen Unlock machst, aktivierst du ja nicht über iTunes und darum wird diese ID nicht erzeugt.
Ach. Und so wie Push nicht geht, geht dann auch YouTube nicht.
Genau das Gleiche, genau.
So könnte man es so ungefähr sagen.
Aber was will denn YouTube mit...
Damit sie dann wissen, ich bin's und ich bleib's. Nicht mehr wer ich bin, aber damit sie wissen, der kam heute, der kam nächste Woche und wenn der in fünf Monaten wiederkommt, dann ist es immer noch der gleiche von dann und dann. Damit sie halt alle...
Die machen sozusagen User-Tracking ohne Account? Nein. Schweinerei!
Google ist evil.
Google ist evil? Verdammte Scheiße.
So, aber jetzt geht's noch ein bisschen weiter.
Jetzt muss es ja in Apple sein, die das größte ist.
Das war?
Ja. Also konnte ich YouTube nicht benutzen.
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob die tatsächlich an Google übergeben wird, die ID oder ob die nicht einfach nur irgendwie...
Ja sonst würd's ja funktionieren. Es hat nicht funktioniert. Ich konnte nicht YouTube benutzen.
Ja, aber es kann doch sein, dass das App einfach irgendwie sich rückversichert oder weiß der Teufel was.
Das ist auch möglich, aber ich denke mal, die brauchen die ID.
Also auf jeden Fall, YouTube funktioniert ja nicht so richtig. Was hast du denn gemacht?
So, jetzt ist halt die Sache, kannst du natürlich denken so. Alles klar. Also ich hab mir gedacht, das kommt über das Backup mit rein, diese alte ID, deswegen brauch ich jetzt eine neue. Weil ich kann das Problem ja schon. Ich hab mir gedacht, wenn ich jetzt meinen Rechner neu installiere und das Backup nicht einspiele, hab ich keine SMS mehr. Und das ist ja scheiße. Mein Adressbuch hätt ich noch, weil es wird ja im Adressbuch gespeichert, aber die SMS werden weg.
Man kann ja Backup entweder nur alles oder nichts.
Genau. Also hab ich ein bisschen überlegt. Und ich find meinen als klar, es gibt ja so einen Reset-Modus bei Settings, Allgemein. Gibt's ganz unten Reset, bin ich reingegangen. Und dann gibt's da Reset All Settings. Ich dachte mir, Backup hab ich ja falls schief geht. Mach ich einfach mal.
Im Network-Bereich?
Nee, Settings Allgemein. Und dann ganz unten gibt's so nur Reset. Da gehst du rein, da gibt's noch so Unterpunkte. Du kannst irgendwie Netzwerkeinstellungen zurücksetzen. Du kannst auch All Settings zurücksetzen und dann irgendwie Erase, iPhone, da gibts diese ganze Einstellung und alles, was mit Löschen zu tun hat. Und da hab ich halt Reset All Settings gemacht. Hat dann irgendwie, glaub ich auch, das Telefon neu gestartet. Und dann waren halt wirklich auch meine WLAN-Einstellungen weg. Das YouTube ging dann. Und was, ja, also Passcode, also alles, alle...
Aber SMS war noch da.
Ja, SMS war noch da. Also alle Einstellungen sozusagen waren weg. Also auch hier bei Google Maps hab ich wieder die ganze Deutschlandkarte gesehen und nicht mehr da, wo ich vorher war. Also alles war einmal schick, sauber zurückgesetzt. Und dann, seitdem geht auch alles. Also es hat mich sozusagen 24 Stunden gekostet, bis das Telefon so ging, wie es sollte.
Aber ich glaube, an irgendwas an deiner Theorie stimmt nicht, weil ich hatte, ich hab ja auch schon mal, ich hab ja auch schon mal von einem geanlockten iPhone auf ein 3G damals aktualisiert und hatte nie Probleme mit YouTube.
Ja, dann hast du vielleicht schon so eine ordentlich hacktivierte ID für YouTube, weil die haben ja auch was, dass es funktioniert. Die hackten auch irgendwas rum. Also, die erstellen diese ID irgendwie. Und du hast dann wahrscheinlich die übernommen, die dann auch so funktioniert, aber ich hatte vorher sozusagen mein Classic hat gerade nicht funktioniert und das habe ich mir wohl übernommen und deswegen hat es weiterhin nicht funktioniert. Und jetzt funktioniert es aber gut. Und das ist, seitdem geht es. Achso, und dann, genau, was ich noch erzählen muss, das ist auch wichtig, es gibt ja für das Tethering braucht man ja so eine Carrier-P-List. So, übrigens, was man bei Settings und About sehen kann, wo da Carrier 5.0 steht, das ist übrigens die Seriennummer sozusagen von dieser Carrier-P-List, da kann man sehen, auf welchem Stand diese P-List ist, weil früher war man nicht klar, was das genau sein soll. Na, es gibt doch hier in Settings diesen About-Modus. Gehen wir alle mal rein.
Genau, dann General, wir haben leider alles in Englisch.
Alle Hörer jetzt auch.
Dann in About und dann scrollt man ein bisschen runter.
Halt dich so schnell, ich hab nur ein 3G.
Sorry.
Wo soll ich reingehen?
Settings, About, Settings, General, About, so rum.
Also Einstellungen Allgemein, Info.
Genau. Und dann gibt es da einen Punkt unter Versionen, da heißt Carrier. Da steht bei mir O2 5.0.
Und diese 5.0 ist die Serial-Nummer sozusagen, oder die von diesem Carrier-P-List. Ich hab die halt irgendjemand erstellt, weil du hast auch fürs Tethering die eine einspielen lassen. Ja, du hast ja auch fürs Tethering eine einspielen lassen. Richtig so. Alle, die bei der Telekom sind und sich da nicht rumgefrischt haben, die sollten wahrscheinlich alle die gleichen haben, nämlich 5.0 oder so. Meinen ist auch 5.0, nehme ich mal an, weil die Telekom die Ursprungs-Carrier-P-List war und diese 5.0 übernommen wurde. Das finde ich deswegen wichtig zu erwähnen, weil diese, es gibt ja Seiten, wo man die jetzt so runterladen kann. Man muss sie nicht mal mehr per E-Mail schicken lassen, sondern dann kann sie direkt mit dem Safari auf dem iPhone anklicken und dann erkennt er das und dann installiert er die. Eine Seite zum Beispiel, die sowas macht, ist help.benm.at, so ein österreichischer. Ich finde, die sollten jetzt auch mal das ein bisschen mit unterstützen, Versionsnummer einzuführen, wenn sie ihre Carrier-P-List dann nämlich auch immer mal wieder updaten oder neue bringen, dass sie sich sozusagen erstens ihren eigenen Namen mit reinhängen, damit man weiß, alles klar kommt von da, das ist keine offizielle, und dann durchnummerieren, also durchversionieren. So, jetzt kommt nämlich der Punkt, warum. Es ist nämlich eine Bekannte aus dem Club, wollte nämlich auch Tethering haben, und das ging bei ihr nicht. Und ich habe ihr gesagt, ja, hier spielst du hier so eine, oder ich glaube, sie hatte auch gar keinen 3G, es kam einfach kein Byte rüber, also APN falsch eingestellt.
Ja, war das auch O2 dann oder was?
Ja, und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, hier lädst du runter, da hast du auch gleich Tethering, da steht alles drin, wie es so sein sollte. Also je, dass der Name halt Internet ist und Passwort und so, soll man halt nichts drin haben. Habe ich ihr zugespielt, hat sie eingetragen, das wird ja dann auch bei den, wie sozusagen, wie diese Provisions, diese Profiles, die man fürs Developen braucht, da wird es ja mit angezeigt, dieses Tethering, wenn du das schon mal gesehen habt.
Wobei es immer nur eins gibt, ne?
Ja.
Kannst du nicht mehrere haben? Hab ich nämlich jetzt auch gerade bemerkt.
Wobei es auf dem Telefon liegen ja ganz viele davon. Nämlich für jeden Provider, den Apple unterstützt, liegt da so ein Carrier-P-List drin.
Die werden ja aber nicht angezeigt, du kannst die jetzt nicht auswählen, sondern die sind halt nur so da.
Na, die werden ausgewählt über deine SIM-Karte, weil die haben da nämlich eine Zahl drin. Das ist die Date, ich hab mir... Jetzt hab ich die Seite zugemacht, scheiße. Ich glaub, das heißt SMNC oder so? Hab ich jetzt vergessen.
Was heißt so?
Na, in diesem Carrier-P-List ist so ein Eintrag, ich glaub, der heißt MNC. Oder irgendwie so ähnlich. Ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher. Zum Kürzel auf jeden Fall. Und da ist so eine 5-stellige Zahl drin. Wie zum Beispiel 26703 oder irgendwie so ähnlich. Und da drüber wird deine SIM-Karte halt erkannt, weil deine SIM-Karte halt auch diese Nummer hat. Und dann weiß er alles klar, für diese SIM-Karte muss ich diese Carrier-P-List benutzen. So, und für diese Bekannte aus dem Club, da hatte die, das Carrier-P-List von Ben M, hatte nur eine Nummer drin. Und da wurde nur eine Gruppe von SIM-Cards mit erkannt, aber nicht die beiden anderen Gruppen. Deswegen hat es wahrscheinlich bei ihr nicht funktioniert. So, und deswegen hat jetzt unsere Telefonspezie aus dem Club mal eine ordentliche Carrier-P-List für O2 erstellt, wo alle drei Nummern drin sind. Und die sollte man benutzen. Man muss da ein bisschen aufpassen. Das heißt nicht, dass was kaputt ist, wenn man die falsch hat, aber es kann sein, dass wenn es nicht geht, dass man nicht die richtige hat. Na die könnte man sich zur Not auch selber machen.
Nee, aber du hast doch gesagt, dass der die erstellt hat und dass man die benutzen sollte. Würde ich jetzt gerne, wo kriege ich die her?
Also ich würde jetzt nicht verteilen wollen an Fremde, weil ich auch nicht weiß, ob sie komplett richtig ist, weil es ja immer so eine Sache ist, was geht und was nicht, aber ich kann dir die gerne geben.
Naja, ich meine, auf einen Blick sofort weiter.
Ja, lass uns die mit auf die Seite packen, oder?
Dann müssen wir die noch ein bisschen anpassen, weil da steht auch noch von Nord an so Stellen, wo es nicht sein sollte, was man wegmachen muss.
Okay, dann passen wir sie noch an.
Man kann ja auch da personalisieren, da waren noch irgendwie Bilder drin, die dann oben als Logo kommen, und so habe ich aber auch entfernt, weil wollte ich nicht.
Ja, ich kann da übrigens direkt anschließen, weil ich bin ja...
Also man kann aber schon mal, mach mal gleich, kann man schon eine Menge steuern mit dieser Carrier-P-List.
Ich habe das jetzt mit den Nummern ehrlich gesagt immer noch nicht so ganz verstanden, was die aussagt.
Was ich ganz gerne hätte, wäre mal, was ich jetzt, weil ich noch keinen Jailbreak gemacht habe, ist, dass ich noch dieses, wenn ich eine Telefonnummer wähle bei O2, dass dann dieses Rufweiterleitung aktiviert.
Das kann man mit dieser Carrier-P-List auch ausschalten.
Das geht auch mit der EPCC?
Ja, das bin ich damit auch los geworden.
Da kannst du dann auch dieses Low-Edge-Editing einschalten, dass man überhaupt diese ganzen APNs einschalten kann. Dann kann man die einstellen. Für MMS kann man davor nehmen und welchen Proxy und welchen MMSC und SMSC oder wie diese ganzen Services da heißen und so.
Die Rechner im GSM-Netz, die dann halt die MSL...
Genau, die Logos kannst du da einstellen und dann...
Wir machen hier gleich nochmal ein fröhliches Profiltaschen.
Ja, aber lass uns doch mal was... Ich meine, jetzt der IPCC...
Kannst du mir das nochmal mit dieser Nummer erklären? Ich hab's nicht verstanden. Also in dieser Pille sind drei Nummern für O2, oder was? Drei Mobile... Was identifizieren diese Nummern?
Die SIM-Karte. Ich bin jetzt nicht der Telefonaxe-Welt, jetzt müsste ich...
Die SIM-Karte?
Ja, die SIM-Karte ist halt von O2, von einem gewissen Provider und die kriegen also... Die haben ja nicht nur 0179 bei O2, sondern ich glaube, die haben ja inzwischen jetzt auch andere Nummern bereich. Ich weiß nicht ganz, ob es damit zu tun hat, aber ich glaube schon. Und dann kriegen die halt immer so ID's für diese Nummernblöcke zugewiesen. Das Carrier-P-List kriegt, trickst halt diese Nummern ein, dass das iPhone weiß, alles klar, wenn da so eine SIM-Karte drin ist, dann ist diese Carrier-P-List zuständig. Und wenn da keine findet, die die Nummer hat, wird nämlich das Default Carrier-P-List benutzt, die auf dem iPhone liegt, die sozusagen nichts kann, wo alles so Default ist.
Und deswegen hat sich das bei dir erinnert, als du eine neue SIM-Karte eingelegt hast.
Nee, bei mir war das eigentlich kein Problem. Bei der Karte war es ein Problem, weil sie hatte anscheinend nur eine Nummer drin, weil die bei Band N nur eine Nummer eingetragen hatten und sie aber eine Karte aus einem anderen Bereich hatte.
Du hast aber jetzt auch eine neue SIM-Karte bekommen, oder?
Das hat damit gar nichts zu tun.
Damit du überhaupt UMTS machen kannst. Das hat damit nichts zu tun. Gut, dann lass mich da mal kurz gleich noch nachtragen, weil ich bin ja jetzt auch gerade nach Österreich gefahren, war eine Woche in Wien, war noch ein paar Tage in Wien. Und Österreich ist ja einfach mal Mobilfunk-Wunderland. Also es ist ja einfach mal da preislich und service- und angebotsmäßig so irre. Da möchte man einfach nur noch weinen. Das wusste ich auch schon vorher. Und ich hatte noch vom letzten Mal so eine Yes-Karte. Das ist so ein, das kriegste da beim HOFA, das ist so das österreichische Aldi. Also es ist auch wirklich Aldi sozusagen in Österreichisch. Also es gehört Aldi und sieht auch aus wie Aldi, aber heißt nicht Aldi. Und bei Aldi gibt es halt diese Yes-Karten. Und da zahlst du halt irgendwie 20 Euro und kriegst dafür irgendwie einen Gigabyte Fragen. Das ist halt so prepaid, irgendwie Internet mit allem drum und dran. Das ist natürlich super für, ich fahr mal ein paar Tage dahin, kannst das dann irgendwie über die Webseite aufladen. Das funktioniert auch ordentlich. Das ist nicht irgendwie so eine merkwürdige Webseite, was weiß ich, wie O2 online oder so ein Scheiß, sondern irgendwie einfach, kannst du verstehen, kannst du mal schnell aufladen. Wobei es mir nicht gelungen ist, da meinen Betrag über Kreditkarte aufzuladen, weil sie Kreditkarten nur dann akzeptieren, wenn du dir da von Visa ein Passwort zuteilen lässt. Das geht wohl mittlerweile, wusste ich auch noch gar nicht. Wie auch immer. Habe ich dann irgendwie einfach in so einem Trafik, weißt du, in so einem allgemeinen Laden, da kannst du halt einfach rangehen und dir da irgendwie dein Guthaben ausdrucken lassen. Anyway, jetzt hatte ich erstmal das Problem, ich saß halt im Zug, habe die Grenze überschritten, wartet immer die ganze Zeit, guckte, starte so auf Google Maps, weil ich dann über die Grenze rüber bin. Und irgendwann war es dann halt so weit und dann wollte ich halt irgendwie meine SIM-Karte tauschen. Hab erst mal festgestellt, dass ich natürlich keine Büroklammer dabei habe.
Hast du dein SIM-Eject Tool nicht dabei gehabt?
Nee, hatte ich nicht.
Was ist ja dabei bei den iPhones?
Ja und dann find ich erstmal was.
Schweizer Taschenmesser, da ist ein Lade mit drin.
Schön, dass du das sagst, weil mein Nachbar im Zug zog, nehm ich dann irgendwie ein Tool raus, was ich bis dahin noch gar nicht kannte.
Na die Büroklammer.
Nee.
Zuhause meist immer mit der Büroklammer.
Das hier. Hast du das schon mal gesehen? Eine Swiss-Card von Victorinox.
Das hast du dir auch gleich geschoppt.
Ich bin natürlich auch gleich geschoppt, weil das total großartig ist.
Lass mich doch mal zu Ende spielen.
Also wer das noch nicht kennt, das ist halt so im Kreditkartenformat so eine kleine Plastebox, recht flach, wo eine Schere drin ist, wo ein Messer drin ist, wo eine Lupe drin ist. In dieser Version auch noch eine LED drin ist. Das heißt, man kann unten einen Schalter legen.
Das ist halt so eine Art Schraubenzieher hier.
Das ist so ein Schraubenzieher mit so, einfach so ein Plättchen mit vier Schraubenzieherecken und dann kannst du damit irgendwie machen.
Und natürlich die obligatorische Pinzette.
Die obligatorische Pinzette. Und aber auch die obligatorische Stecknadel. Also unter anderem hast du halt auch da eine Stecknadel. Einfach so eine Stecknadel, um mal eben was zu pieksen.
Die kann man sogar als Ersatzteil nachkaufen.
Ja, eine Stecknadel. Großartig.
Die muss ja genau hier passen und so weiter.
Na ja, klar.
Auch die Pinzetten und so. Man kann alle Teile am Swiss-Schweizer Taschenmeister langkaufen.
Und das ist besonders geil, ein Kugelschreiber.
Ja, das ist ja beim Taschenmeister auch dabei. Und die Pinzette halt, die ist ja auch dabei. Aber du hast keinen Zahnstocher, ne?
Nee, keinen Zahnstocher. Aber Zahnstocher gibt es in Zügen genug. Das war nicht so das Problem. Ich hab's auch mit einem Zahnstocher geschafft.
Okay, was kostet das? 20 Euro. Ne, mehr 30.
Die billige Variante, ja, so in dem Bereich 30 Euro.
Ich hab ja dieses Schweizer Taschmesser, dieses Cybertool. Die mittlere Version, das ist schon auch cool.
Okay, du hast irgendwie auf dein... Ich wollt jetzt irgendwann mal... Kinder, wir reden übers iPhone 3GS und worüber wir das hergeredet haben, waren irgendwelche SIM-Card-IDs und Überstecknadel.
Lass uns mal zum Punkt kommen. Ich hab halt noch kein richtiges 3G. Also muss ich mich auch über andere Sachen unterhalten.
Oder du?
Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall hab ich das auch gemacht. Und jetzt komm ich auch zu dieser Sache mit dem Profil. So, weil dann war ich nämlich auch erstmal in der Situation, dass ich das passende Profil brauch. Bei diesem Help-Ben-Tralala-AT gab's dann für Yes kein spezifisches Profil. Ich hab mir da irgendwie über Twitter ein bisschen die Tipps geben lassen. Und zwar schon im Vorfeld, weil dann hatte ich ja kein Netz mehr. Die Lösung war... Was war nochmal die Lösung? Ah ja, genau. Dass ich dann selber editiert habe, also das Problem war, ich konnte einfach so ein normales Dingsbums-Profil nehmen, musste dann aber eben spezifische ähm... APNs eintragen. Was ja dann auch das iPhone mir die Möglichkeit bot. Nur funktionierte es dann nicht. Es funktionierte nämlich erst dann, wenn ich dann am Ende dieser Einstellungs-Settings gibt's nämlich nochmal einen Reset oder Wiederherstellen, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau wie es heißt. Rücksetzen, Button und den musst du halt nochmal klicken und erst dann geht's auch. Also irgendwie gibt's da auch noch so ein Update.
Und wie hast du das denn draufgebracht, das ganze IPCC?
Safari auf dem iPhone direkt...
Ich konnte einfach nur... Ja, ich meine...
Ansonsten gibt's halt so ein Default, was man ins Terminal pastet, damit auch mit iTunes das wieder reinschiebbar ist. So, ich hab jetzt nochmal kurz Informationen zu diesem... zu dieser ID und zwar ist das wirklich... die heißt MCC und MNC und das ist zusammengesetzt aus Mobile Country Code und Mobile Network Code und danach wird irgendwie deine...
Okay, das ist aber dann nicht die SIM-Karte, sondern das ist das Netz.
Genau.
Das ist die SIM-Karte, die das Netz identifiziert.
Genau. Das wird ja nicht deine SIM-Karte erkannt, sondern von wem die ist sozusagen.
Du kennst es an der Nummer und die Nummer kommt ja over the air. Auf der SIM-Karte steht nur, wie das Netz heißt. Auf der SIM-Karte steht der Text, der String.
Da wär ich mir nicht so sicher.
Doch, das ist so.
Ich könnte schwören, dass es over the air, dass ich airplane mode anhab und der trotzdem erkennt, welchen Dings er nehmen soll. Das muss ja auf der Karte draufstehen, von wem die ist.
Ja, klar, okay. Das meinst du, die Karte kann sich an ein anderes Netz gar nicht einbuchen?
Na doch, aber damit ist ihr Heimatnetz, von wem sie ausgestellt wurde, damit klar. Aus welchem Country und von welchem Provider.
Ja gut, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall diese Zuordnung, also der String selber. Bei dir kam doch auch immer Viac Intercom noch.
Der steht aber noch auf der SIM-Karte drauf.
Ja, der steht auf der Karte.
Das wird eine zusätzliche Information sein.
Das ist ja nicht die Idee, über die wir reden. Wir reden ja über diese 2.
Ja, aber die matcht ja sozusagen die Nummer auf den String. Also von daher steht die Nummer da halt auch drauf. Wie auch immer, ich bin echt müde.
So, so, so. Lass uns bitte mal, lass uns bitte endlich. Also, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt will ich ja mal. Ich hab vorher ein iPhone 3G gehabt, jetzt hab ich ein iPhone 3G S. Und jetzt geht's darum, was hat das Ding für Unterschiede. Ich hatte ehrlich gesagt nicht gedacht, dass die Unterschiede doch so deutlich sind. Also dieses S zum Beispiel, worüber du jetzt so kein Wort verloren hast, das weiß doch schon jeder. Nee, das weiß man nicht.
Was weiß noch keiner?
Das ist wirklich schneller.
Ach, wirklich?
Ja, es ist wirklich schneller. Es ist nicht nur ein bisschen schneller, es ist dramatisch schneller. Es ist, das hatte ich vorher so nicht.
Es ist schneller entladen.
Nee, das nicht.
Doch, mein 3G S ist schneller entladen.
Achso, dein 3G S ist schneller entladen. Ja, sorry, aber ich meine, sollen wir jetzt nichts drüber erzählen, nur weil du noch keins hast?
Ja, einen Trauertragen.
Guck mal, ich trag schon was relativ Dunkles. Aber darf ich jetzt ein bisschen darüber erzählen?
Ja, mach doch.
Voll News jetzt, das ist schneller. Okay, was noch?
Ich geh nach hinten und bring mich um.
Es hat Stimmen. Voice over.
Oh, auf Deutsch? Auf Deutsch. Echt?
Das Ding hat echt gute deutsche Stimmen.
Und jetzt musst du deine Englische... Redest du jetzt von dem... Ach du redest von dem...
Jetzt führ mal vor.
Du siehst jetzt schon Audio, jetzt kannst du es ja auch mal vorführen. Das ist jetzt so ein Voice-Over-Modus. Mit dem man... Also das ist eigentlich gedacht für Blinde. Aber ich hab das einfach mal so spaßeshalber ausprobiert.
Super für Hörer, weil die sind ja auch blind.
Genau. Darum schalte ich das jetzt mal ein. Jetzt hab ich... Was? Jetzt mach ich mal...
Das ist ein bisschen schnell.
Das ist ein bisschen schnell. Ich mach's mal wieder aus. Ich hab's nämlich auf sehr...
Mach mal normal.
Ich mach mal...
Mach mal Voice-Over-Out.
Auf normale Geschwindigkeit. So.
Kann man es nicht einfach mit ganz lange festhalten.
Das war immer noch sehr schnell.
Kannst immer noch ein bisschen langsamer machen.
Ich weiß, Blinde können extrem schnell.
Aber es spricht gut Deutsch.
Das würden wir ja wohl erwarten.
Nee, Moment mal, du hast Voice-Over, hast du auch auf dem Mac und ich weiß nicht, ob du das mal eingeschaltet hast, spaßeshalber. Das spricht dir alles auf Deutsch vor, aber in einem absurd schlechten englischen Akzent.
Der will nicht.
Und...
Du hast so ein Sau-Spiel.
Du musst auf Englisch sprechen, nicht auf Deutsch und Englisch.
Play Random Music ist nicht Englisch?
Stell es einfach auf Deutsch, dann kannst du nicht auf Deutsch mit dem Ding sprechen.
Du weißt, ich soll doch auf Englisch fluchen?
Du sollst einfach englischen Dialek an den Tag legen.
Also das Ding hat eine gute deutsche Stimme drin. Das Ding hat auch übrigens eine gute deutsche Spracherkennung drin, weil man kann, über dieses Voice Control, kann man relativ gut das Ding steuern.
Hast du es mal ausprobiert?
Ich hab's ausprobiert, ich probier's die ganze Zeit aus. Ich kann's dir mal zum Beispiel mal sagen, mal gucken, ob das jetzt klappt.
Redest du auf Deutsch oder Englisch mit ihm?
Ruf Tim.
Keine Treffer. Ruf Tim. Du musst Ruf Tim noch klar sagen.
Nee, Tim reicht eigentlich.
Und was heißt überhaupt Ruf? Ruf an.
Ruf Tim.
Ruf Tim an. Siehste, ruf Tim an, funktioniert. Hat er jetzt mir zugehört? Und was macht er jetzt eigentlich?
Er kann anrufen.
Ich muss das jetzt anrufen. Tim.
Na super, das ist ja mein schöner Vorfilm. Es hat bisher...
Jetzt kann ich dir sagen, ah, jetzt kann ich wieder meinen CAE-Plug machen. Chaos Radio Express 131 irgendwie. Das hat alles keinen Sinn mit diesem... Nee, äh, Entschuldigung, 132? 131.
Mit Sparherkennung hat alles keinen Sinn?
Ja, es ist furchtbar. Kommst du dir nicht ein bisschen doof vor, wenn du dich mit deinem Telefon unterhältst?
Ich hab das vorhin auf dem Fahrrad genutzt. Mehrfach. Du fährst auf dem Rad.
Das geht nur, wenn keiner zuhört, ne?
Du hörst Musik, drückst kurz die Taste. Und dann? Nimmst das Telefon nicht aus der Tasse und dann sagst du, ruf...
Tim.
Tim?
Der hat mich aber nicht angerufen.
Und er hat dich angerufen.
Was? Du hast ihm ruf, Tim gesagt, und er hat mich angerufen?
Genau. Und er sagt, rufe an, Tim, Pritloff, mobil. Nee, er sagt dann Pritlofe, weil er Pritloff, weil er es so deutsch ausspricht. Er sagt auch, ja ich spiele jetzt mal Juni Cash. Ich sag Johnny Cash. Ja, aber es ist ein vernünftiger, deutscher Name spricht das wirklich gut deutsch aus und versteht es auch ziemlich gut. Und da bin ich echt beeindruckt von. Also es hat jetzt natürlich super auf Anhieb nicht funktioniert, aber die anderen Male, wo ich es bisher war, es war nicht so dieses, ja im achten Versuch klappt es dann irgendwann mal, sondern es funktioniert eigentlich immer auf Anhieb. Es ist so, dass er intelligente Vorschläge macht. Also ich hab zum Beispiel ruf Michael an, dann sagt er mehrere Treffer, ich kenn Michael so und so und Michael so und so und Michael so und so, dann muss ich noch einen Nachnamen sagen, dann fragt er dich mobil, privat oder... Und je nachdem, wenn er nur eine Nummer hat, dann...
Stundenlange Dialoge. Mann, jetzt rufe ich an.
Es geht schnell, es ist wirklich gut. Es ist echt, ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass es so ein geiles Feature ist. Also das ging so komplett unter und ich dachte auch so, ja, das kann dann vielleicht ein bisschen Englisch verstehen und so was. Aber nein, es versteht gutes Englisch und es spricht vor allen Dingen gut... Es kann gut Deutsch verstehen und es kann auch Deutsch sprechen. Und ich wünsche mir auch mal eine vernünftige Stimme, deutsche Stimme für einen Mac.
Und wenn ihr sagt, fuck you, dann schaltet er Parallel-Controls an.
Wahrscheinlich. Was noch so eine Sache ist, an die ich nicht geglaubt habe, aber die bisher sehr gut funktioniert, ist dieses schmutzabweisende Display. Ich glaube, man merkt es ein bisschen, wenn man so rüberrutscht. Das Display macht mehr Widerstand als bei einem alten iPhone.
Mehr?
Ja, würde ich sagen.
Ich kann da keinen Unterschied feststellen.
Kannst du da keinen Unterschied feststellen? Also ich habe das Gefühl, dass man eher mit dem Finger so ein bisschen klebt. Nicht unangenehm.
Ich sehe auch nicht deutlich weniger Fingerabdrückungen.
Man sieht deutlich weniger Fingerabdrücke, wenn man einmal das über die Hose rüberwischt.
Und dann?
Ein bisschen. Nein, einmal reicht tatsächlich. Und das ist einfach, das Neue ist dann sauber.
Ach, das ist doch Mythos, das ist doch Quatsch.
Okay, nächste.
Da ist mein fetter Fingerabdruck drauf, voll schäuplemäßig hier. Du glaubst die Propaganda.
Also meinst du, bei meinem Alten habe ich regelmäßig das Tuch gebraucht? Weil es wirklich so verdreckt war? Ja, und das hier ist...
Also ich weiß nicht, ich hab noch nie ein Problem mit Fingerabdrücken. Da sind halt Fingerabdrücke drauf, Kerz. Ist doch hell genug. Man sieht doch alles. Also ich hab noch nie gesehen, dass jetzt irgendwie der Fingerabdruck irgendein Detail auf meiner Landkarte verdeckt hätte.
Mann, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass da Berg-Fingerdreck drauf war. Ja, ich merke schon.
Ja, Scheißladen.
Ein Kompass hat es, habe ich mir sagen lassen.
Ja, aber funktioniert nicht bei dir oder was?
Das ist halt so ein altbekanntes Feature. Es ist halt schön im Maps-Programm. Ich warte jetzt noch auf die Applikation.
Geh mal davon aus, die meisten Leute haben so einen Teil nicht.
Ja, aber ich meine, das ist das Feature, wenn du auf apple.com gehst, dann steht da als allererstes ein Kompass drin.
Ja, aber wenn Apple das sagt, dann ist das ja was anderes, als wenn du das sagst.
Das steht aber auch als erstes, dass es doppelt so schnell ist.
Ja, aber komm, Geschwindigkeitsverbesserungen, die sind angeblich immer, dass das Telefon doppelt so schnell ist. Das haben sie auch schon beim iPhone 3G gesagt und da war nur die Netzwerkverbindung etwa doppelt so schnell. Jetzt ist tatsächlich, du, ich hab hier, ich weiß nicht, hast du Bejive zum Beispiel drauf, auf dem Ding, auf Time?
Nein.
Bejive ist so ein Instant-Messaging-Client für Google Talk und so was.
Haben wir schon drüber geredet letztes Mal.
Ja, haben wir schon mal drüber geredet. Oder? Ja, wir haben da schon mal drüber geredet.
Du hast es trotzdem noch mal erwähnt.
Ich wollte nur mal sagen, Instant-Messaging-Client. Und der hat auf dem iPhone 3G, braucht der einfach. Der braucht, ich würde mal schätzen, 10 bis 15 Sekunden, bis der gestartet ist. Hier drücke ich den Knopf. Und er ist da. Und das ist wirklich, dass man in jeder Situation merkt, das Ding ist um einiges schneller. Es tippt sich schneller, jedes Programm ist schneller. Es ist wirklich rundum schneller. Das hätte ich so nicht gedacht. Und jetzt ein Kompass da drinnen, das eigentliche ist wirklich die Geschwindigkeit.
Das liegt auch daran, dass es ja irgendwie mehr RAM hat. Also nicht mehr Flash hat es ja sowieso, aber auch mehr RAM hat. 256 MB und nicht mehr 128. Dadurch kann Apple jetzt auch Sachen, muss es nicht so schnell rausschmeißen, so Images oder was er sonst so nachlädt, dann einfach alle im RAM bleiben.
Genau genommen hat er nicht doppelt so viel RAM, sondern eigentlich hat er...
Noch mehr, weil das OS ja gleich viel verbraucht wie vorher.
Da ist verbraucht ein bisschen mehr freien RAM.
Genau. Ich glaub, drei oder viermal so viel, das ist letztlich was zur Verfügung steht. Sollte der Punkt gekommen sein.
So, Akkulaufzeit hab ich jetzt keinen großen Unterschied festgestellt. Vielleicht minimal besser.
Na, es gibt ganz viele Leute, auch gerade auf der MacHackers Mailinglist hier, die sich beschweren, dass er schaltet alles aus, also auch wohl 3G und überhaupt alles und das ist so morgens frisch geladen und abends leer. Find ich ein bisschen komisch, weil man meint's jetzt, ich hab echt auch schon eine Stunde Musik gehört, hab schon mehrere Spiele, Flight Control gespielt, hab irgendwie telefoniert, SMS'd und so weiter und ich hab jetzt ein Uptemp von 2,5 Tagen oder so und ich glaub, ich bin jetzt immer noch ein Viertel voll oder so was. Also auch mit 3G an und alles. Aber ich hab Push aus, weil ich schon beim Classic festgestellt hab, Push zieht mir die Batterie leer wie nix. Aber man meinte, er hätte das auch aus gehabt auf der Merckackers-Main-Liste. Was ich jetzt noch vermute, ist, dass natürlich immer noch, ich weiß nicht, was die Jail-Breaks und so weiter, was die da alles noch so für Zeug machen, kann sein, dass es an denen liegt, dass die das so schnell leer saugen. Da gibt es ja auch so Features wie, dass das WLAN die ganze Zeit daueran bleibt, damit irgendwie da irgendwelche Programme laufen können.
Na ja, aber das hat er vermutlich auch reingeschrieben, oder? Ja, ich hab ja nichts mehr laufen, ich hab 3G abgeschaltet.
Weil Jail-Breaking ist heute schon so normal, dass es vielleicht, dass das nicht irgendwie funktioniert.
Nee, aber er hätte reingeschrieben, wenn er ein Tool installiert hätte, das die ganze Zeit WLAN aktiviert, oder?
Wer weiß, was diese Jail-Break sonst so tun. Das müssen wir nochmal nachfragen. Das wär so eine Vermutung. Er hat es auch nicht spätere gesagt, aber das wollte ich eigentlich nochmal nachfragen.
Also ich hab damals keinen Unterschied zwischen Jail-Break, also ich werd bei dem Gerät wieder ein Jail-Break machen, weil mir doch ein paar Features fehlen. Und ich hab damals keinen wesentlichen Unterschied oder keinen bemerkbaren Unterschied bei der Akkulaufzeit gehabt.
Ich seh im Chat auch einer, dass irgendwie normale Nutzung ohne UMTS, ohne Push, ohne WLAN das 24 Stunden hält. Also meins hat alles an, außer Push. Aber auch schon Musik gehört, gespielt und so weiter. Und ist jetzt auf jeden Fall über zwei Tage schon.
Ja, aber meins hält auch mit WLAN und UMTS. Also ich meine, ich will WLAN haben, ich will UMTS haben. Dafür hab ich doch das Ding. Und das hält auch deutlich länger als 24 Stunden durch.
Ja, das geht halt die Vermutung, dass es halt da so ein Batterieproblem gibt.
Ach, da gab's doch, es gab doch so Gerüchte darüber, über SIM-Karten, dass es irgendwelche 5-Volt-SIM-Karten und 3,3-Volt-SIM-Karten oder irgendwie so was gäbe.
Das ist aber zehn Jahre her, das war ganz früher, dass man irgendwie mit einer neueren SIM-Karte irgendwie Strom sparen kann oder so.
Nee, und das Apple ist, dass das iPhone wohl mit dem alten Typ oder dem neuen Typ oder ich weiß nicht, was, totale Probleme hat und der Akku total schnell leer wird. Ich weiß nicht, ob's stimmt.
Ist mir egal, meine Karte ist total frisch.
Ja, vielleicht. Du hast jetzt so eine 5-Volt schon. Du bist total durch.
Der Misch lebt schon ein.
Haben wir noch was auf der Liste?
Wir müssen Schluss machen.
Wir sind schon seit gefühlt 24 Stunden.
Die meiste Zeit davon haben wir über MMC-Symkarten gesprochen. Und jetzt schaffen wir tatsächlich das fucking iPhone.
Aber du warst der Erste, der geschrien hat, dass er dieses Carrier-P-List haben wollte. Jetzt kriegst du es nicht so.
Tja, das hast du jetzt davon.
Wenn es schon läuft, brauchst du es gar nicht, weil du hast ja schon die richtige Nummer.
Ich würde gerne, dass dieses Anruf-Weiterleitung aktiviert.
Ach so, ja, verstehe, verstehe.
Das nervt einfach.
Ich bin total fettig. Ich hab heute schon ein bisschen viel gepodcastet.
Du bist durch.
Ja, ich hab vor allem sehr früh anfangen müssen schon. Dazwischen gab es keinen Schlaf.
Diese, äh, mir mit den Links, wie machst du das?
So werden die Hörer am Podcast nie erfahren, dass das neue iPhone auf Videos aufnehmen kann.
Mit welchen Links?
Na, hier, äh, der iPhone Carrier Bundle Generator. Hab ich hier so einen Link? Du machst den doch immer noch mit dran an dem...
Ja, meine Herren, wollen wir dann mal irgendwie wieder zurück ins Lied und dann mal, äh, Tschüss sagen? Mhm. Das war jetzt kein Porno-Witz.
Nein, nein, nein, das war kein... Ich find's jetzt bloß lustig, dass wir uns jetzt ausführlich über alle möglichen Themen unterhalten haben, aber nicht über's iPhone.
Ja, gibt's noch was zu erzählen? Ich mein, du kannst auch gerne noch ein bisschen reden.
Nein, nein, nein. Ist okay, ist okay.
Ich kann dem Ding jetzt nicht mehr so beiwohnen.
Ich bin müde und...
Ich will erst dann nur darüber reden, wenn...
Wenn du's auch hast.
Wenn ich auch, also...
Ich weiß schon, was dann kommt, dann sag ich, oh, jetzt die neuen, geilen Podcasts noch viel schneller.
Ja, wenn...
Ja, wird dann alles nochmal berichten, was Max auch schon berichtet hat. Guck mal diese Applikation, wie schnell das geht.
Das ist unglaublich.
Haben wir's?
Na gut.
Also wir machen jetzt hier mal Schluss, Jungs. Wir sind durch. Also ich bin durch. Die anderen sind ja noch total fit und so.
Ich könnte ja noch stundenlang weiter podcasten.
Nächste Sendung kommt irgendwann. Ist derzeit noch alles völlig unklar. Deswegen will ich mir jetzt auch mal keine, einen Termin ankündigen. Wieder hier noch auf der Webseite, aber irgendwann taucht er wieder auf. Mal gucken, wie das tolle Skript funktioniert, wenn kein nächster Termin da ist.
Das müsstest du theoretisch jetzt schon sehen wahrscheinlich.
Das stimmt. Das müsste man jetzt theoretisch auch schon feststellen können.
Da steht, ich glaube, kein Termin geplant. Zurzeit ist keine Live-Sendung geplant.
Hammer. Super Skript. So sieht es aus. Zurzeit ist keine Live-Sendung geplant. Aber heute ist nicht alle Tage. Wir kommen wieder, keine Frage, das war Ausgaben Nummer 33. Demnächst wieder mehr von uns.